TO.
ARE APRIL NINTH HEARING OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
WE ARE STILL AWAITING THE ARE
MEMBERS AND SO WE WILL START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
LET ME MAKE SOME BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENTS HERE FIRST.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM HAS BEEN
APPOINTED FOR TODAY TO FILL THE
VACANCY ON THE COMMITTEE.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB THREE ZERO
TWO SEVEN BY MISTER CHAVEZ HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING.
THERE ARE FOUR BILLS ON CONSENT.
ITEM TO A. B. EIGHTEEN OH FOUR
BY MISTER BERMAN. ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY NINETY SEVEN BY MISTER
ACOSTA.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY SIX BY MS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. AN ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY SIX ALSO BY
MR BERMAN.
SO WE'LL TAKE THAT UP AS SOON AS
WE.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AND.
ON Q. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLEND IS JOINING US THIS IS HER
FIRST HEARING WHAT THE
COMMITTEES SO WELCOME.
WELCOME IS MELENDEZ.
I'M SUPPOSED TO ANNOUNCES THIS
THIS HEARING IS BEING TELEVISED
ON CHANNEL TWENTY ONE.
AND WE HAVE TWENTY ONE BILLS.
SO.
WITHOUT WASTING ANY FOR THE
TIME LIMITS THAT WE ARE GOING BY
SIGN IN ORDER.
SALAS PLEASE.
PRESENT YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT.
BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS A
REINCARNATION OF A. BILL THAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S PREVIOUSLY
HEARD IN A COUPLE OF GENERATIONS
OKAY ALRIGHT.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT.
I I I WILL SAY THAT I WILL
ACCEPT YOUR AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY. LET'S CALL THE ROLL TWO
STEMS COOPER.
FAMILY MEMBERS WERE OUT TO
TREAT.
MURATSUCHI HERE ACOSTA HERE
ACOSTA HERE BLOOM.
CHAU.
CHAO HERE EGGMAN.
FLORA.
LARA HERE LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
STONE HERE.
MELINDA'S HERE.
DO WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
SO MR SELFRIDGE LIKE CLOSE.
WITH THE.
.
THE CAP AND TRADE MONEY THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR I SEE THIS IS A
VERY BENEFICIAL BILL TO HELP
WITH RENEWABLE ENERGY IN MOVING
US INTO THE NEXT CENTURY.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I'VE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS SIR.
BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WITH AMENDMENTS.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
TOP MOTION WAS MADE BY MISTER
FLORA.
OKAY
REPORTER AND I.
OKAY FLORA I LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ. BLUNDERS AYE STONE.
STONE NO.
IT'S ONE.
ALRIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT
VENTILATION THANK YOU.
NEXT UP WE HAVE MISTER
O'DONNELL.
BEFORE WE TAKE UP A MISTER
O'DONNELL SO A BILL I'D LIKE TO.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR DO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CONSENT
RECOMMENDATION.
BUT MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
RELATIVELY AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
CASA AYE BLOOM.
CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ LINDA'S AYE STONE.
STONE I.
SEVEN ZERO.
VERY MUCH MISTER DONALD FLOOR IS
YOURS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR FOUR WHICH WILL
ELIMINATE THE CAP ON THE OIL
TRUST FUND. AND HELP ENSURE THE
CLEAN UP OF ABANDONED WELLS IN
MY DISTRICT.
THE LONG BEACH THAILAND'S ARE
HOME TO THE WILMINGTON OIL
FIELD.
ONE ARE LARGEST OIL AND NATURAL
GAS FIELDS IN THE NATION.
THE FEEL PRODUCES APPROXIMATELY
FORTY SIX THOUSAND BARRELS OFFER
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED ACTIVE
WELLS A YEAR.
BECAUSE HE'S OPERATIONS ARE
LOCATED ON STATE LANDS ENTRUSTED
TO THE CITY OF LONG BEACH THE
STATE RECEIVES A SHARE OF THE
NET PROFITS. FROM THESE
OPERATIONS.
HOWEVER THESE WELLS WILL NOT RUN
FOR EVER.
AND CURRENT PROJECTIONS
ESTIMATED OIL OPERATIONS WILL
CEASE AROUND THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY SIX.
TO ENSURE THE STATE HAS THE
NECESSARY FUNDS TO DECOMMISSION
THE WELLS AND MITIGATE POTENTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE CREATED THE OIL TRUST FUND.
A PORTION OF THE STATE'S SHARE
OF THE NET PROFITS BEGAN GOING
IN THE FUN WITH THE INTENT OF
COVERING THE EVENTUAL
DECOMMISSIONING COSTS WHEN THESE
OPERATIONS CEASE.
AT THAT TIME A CAP OF THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WAS
PLACED ON THE FUND BASED ON THE
PREMISE THAT WE SHOULDN'T SAY
MORE MONEY. THAN IS NECESSARY.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE OIL TRUST
FUND REACHED THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CAP.
ESTIMATES PLACE THE STATE'S
EVENTUAL COSTS OF CLEANING UP
THE WELLS AT EIGHT HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS WILL LEAVE THE STATE WITH A
SHORTFALL OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WILL LIKELY
HAVE TO COME OUT OF THE STATE
GENERAL FUND.
WE MUST ALLOW THE OIL TRUST FUND
TO KEEP GROWING TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN MEET THE STATE'S
OBLIGATION TO CLEAN UP THIS OIL
FIELD.
AB TWO THOUSAND TO AB TWENTY
FOUR A FOUR ELIMINATES THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CAP
WHICH WILL ALLOW THE FUND TO
GROW AND COVER THE COSTS OF THE
EVENTUAL OIL CLEANUP.
I HAVE MY WITNESSES HERE TODAY
ARE SHARED HAVE WRITTEN WITH THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
AND SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND ALSO
ALICE KESSLER REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH
RICHARD.
PLEASE THANK YOU AS SHERI
PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION THE COMMISSION A
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FOR.
AN OVERSEAS THAT GRANTED LANDS
ON THE OIL OPERATIONS AT THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH AND.
THERE IS IN FACT OF A VAST GULF
BETWEEN WHAT'S IN THE OIL TRUST
FUND. AND THE ESTIMATED EVENTUAL
LIABILITY WITH THE OPERATIONS
AND IN AROUND TWENTY THIRTY OR
SO SO WE THINK THAT SPELL. IS AN
IMPORTANT WAY FOR THE STATE TO
ENSURE ITS BUILT UP SUFFICIENT
FUNDING SO IT'S MORE LIKELY TO
BE READY TO PAY FOR THOSE COSTS
WHICH ARE THE STATE'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR THE
OPERATIONS AND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ALICE KESSLER HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH.
AS THE AUTHOR AND CO SPONSOR
AND SPONSOR OF THE BILL STATED
OF THERE'S A SHORTFALL OF THE
CITY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR OF THE
OIL OPERATIONS AND PART OF THAT
IS DEALING WITH THESE ABANDONED
WELLS AND. WE NEED THESE
ADDITIONAL ON FUNDS IN ORDER TO
RESPONSIBLY CONTINUE TO MANAGE
THE LAND SO WE WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
MISS SURE O'DONNELL WHICH LIKE
CLOSE RECESS WHEN I VOTE.
MOTIONS AND MADE AND SECONDED.
BROKE UP THIS.
I AM FIFTEEN A BETWEEN FOR A FOR
BY O'DONNELL. THE MOTION IS DO
PASS REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WANT
TO TREAT AYE ROUTE SO SHE AYE
ACOSTA AYE AYE ACOSTA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
STONE I.
WHO?
YEAH OKAY.
ZERO.
ZERO OKAY THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OUR RATES.
.
WE HAVE MISTER FRAZIER UP BUT I
DON'T SEE HIM AND I I SEE
MISTER.
DO YOU HAVE YOUR WITNESSES.
OKAY. AREA.
.
MR APPROACH NOW.
YEAH EXCEPT TO.
OKAY SO MISTER PATTERSON IF.
YOU WOULD GRANT THE COURTESY TO
MS MELENDEZ.
MISS MELENDEZ INDICATED TO ME
THAT SHE HAS A WITNESS THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY NEEDS TO LEAVE
AND SO. WITHOUT OBJECTION FROM
THE COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCOMMODATE HIS BLUNDERS
.
AND WHILE YOU'RE GETTING SET UP
I SHOULD HAVE ANALYSIS IN THE
BEGINNING BUT.
THE GENERAL FORMAT OF OUR BILL
PRESENTATIONS WILL BE AS FOLLOWS
THE AUTHOR WILL OPEN SOME.
FOLLOWED BY A THREE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT LIMITED TO
TWO MINUTES EACH.
A WE HAVE THE OPPOSITIONTHREE
MAIN WITNESSES ALSO TWO MINUTES
EACH.
I AND THAT WILL BE THE FORMATS
THAT WE WILL TRY TO STICK WITH
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE.
I HAD TWENTY ONE BILLS TO TAKE
CARE OF TODAY.
OKAY.
OKAY ALRIGHT WATER WE HAVE MS
MIND AS FOLLOWING HIS PATTERSON
AND SO MISTER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU FOR THE.
YOUR COURTESY.
AND WALKED THE PICKET MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS WE CAN BE.
A VERY QUICK AB.
AT PRESENTING UP AB NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR THIS WILL EXTEND THE
TIMBER HARVEST PLAN EXEMPTION
FOR ANOTHER THREE YEARS. SETTING
THE PROGRAM TO EXPIRE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO.
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
STAFF WORKING WITH ME ON THIS WE
WILL.
GLADLY ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THIS A AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
WAS PASSED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
CREATE A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM TO ALLOW LANDOWNERS WHEN
CLEARING UP TO THREE HUNDRED
FEET OF DISK DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
AROUND A HABITABLE STRUCTURE ON
THE PROPERTY TO THEN SELL THE
TIMBER THEY CUT DOWN WITHOUT
HAVING TO CREATE AND SUBMIT A
TIMBER HARVESTING PLAN TO CAL
FIRE. THIS A PILOT HAS HELPED
REDUCE THE RISK THAT DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES POST HOMES IN ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES BY OFFSETTING. SOME
OF THE HIGH COST FOR LANDOWNERS
TO INCREASED IF DEFENSIBLE.
SPACE AROUND THEIR HOMES AS OF
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR THE
EXEMPTION HAD BEEN UTILIZED THAT
SEVENTY ONE TIMES. OF THE BILL
BEFORE YOU EXTENSIVE SUNSET.
I'M HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN FIFTY FORESTS ARE A
KIRSTEN KOPECKY WITH THE CAL
FOREST AND BRIAN QUITE
REPRESENTING FORCED LANDOWNERS.
OF CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
LICENSE FORCES ASSOCIATION.
YOUR CIRCLE FIFTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION
FROM TIMBER HARVESTING PLAN FOR
THE REMOVAL OF TREES.
THAT ARE BETWEEN A HUNDRED FIFTY
AND THREE HUNDRED FEET FROM
UMMAH LEGALLY PERMITTED
HABITABLE STRUCTURE.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF REDUCING
FLAMMABLE MATERIALS AND
MAINTAINING A FEEL BREAK.
AND
BECAUSE OF THE DEVASTATING
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES WERE
HOPING THAT.
THIS IS A REMINDER OF THE NEED
TO BETTER MANAGE OUR FORESTS AND
AND THE STRUCTURES THAT ARE
NEAR.
.
NEAR OUR FORCE.
AND WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
MISTER MEMBERS BRING WHITE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE TELFER
ELECTIONS FORCED ASSOCIATION AND
THE FORCE LEVELS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR.
I ITS DESIGN HELP LAND MANAGERS
ENFORCERS CARE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
TIMBERLANDS SIMPLY BY EXTENDING
THE CURRENT THREE UNDERFOOT
DEFENSIBLE SPACE EXEMPTION.
WE THINK ENCOURAGING LANDOWNERS
TO CREATE MAINTAIN DEFENSIBLE
SPACE.
I'M FORCED TO COMMUNITIES TO
CREATE SAFE AND DEFENSIBLE
COMMUNITIES.
WE THINK THIS IS REALLY A NO
BRAINER THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FORCED RELATED BILLS
THIS YEAR BUT THIS WAS CLEARLY A
COMMONSENSE MEASURE FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY.
OTHER WITNESSES PLEASE THEY'RE
JUST STATE HERE.
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS CHRIS MCKAY
LEE ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
DAHLE NARROW FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
PROMISE OF THE SENATE FOR
STRESSED ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS AMENDED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
STACEY HEAT IN RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THIS.
A BILL.
ENJOYS A OUR RECOMMENDATION OF
I DO PASS AS AMENDMENT.
YOU HAVE ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENT
YES.
MISTER PATTERSON WHICH LIKE
THOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY VOTE.
I DON'T FIVE AB NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR. BY A PATTERSON THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS ROUTE TO CHEAT AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
ACOSTA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I OF THE MOON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THE BILLS
OUT GRAPHICS CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS THAT.
ALRIGHT.
MS MELENDEZ DO YOU HAVE YOUR
WITNESSES OKAY.
WHICH FRAZIER AYE THANK YOU FOR
ACCOMMODATING AS MELENDEZ AYE
SHE HAS WITNESSED THAT
APPARENTLY.
ALRIGHT SO WE ARE.
HERE FOR MS MELENDEZ THIS BILL.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
ACCOMMODATING ME AND MY WITNESS
YET TO LEAVE TO GET HIS
GRANDDAUGHTER AND I'M ALSO.
THINKING MEMBERS FOR GIVING YOUR
ATTENTION TODAY.
I ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY SIX IS A SIMPLE BILL AS WE
LIKE STAY IN THE ASSEMBLY. AS
YOU ALL KNOW ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROBLEMS FACING CALIFORNIA'S THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
LOWER AND MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
FAMILIES ARE SPENDING OVER A
THIRD OF THEIR PAYCHECK. JUST TO
KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR
CHILDREN'S HEADS AND ONLY ONE
THIRD OF FAMILIES CAN AFFORD A
MEDIUM SIZED. UP MEDIATISED
PRAISE HOME IN CALIFORNIA.
THE KYROCKETING COST OF HOUSING
HAS LED TO A HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN BEFORE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
MORE THAN A QUARTER OF THE
COUNTRY'S HOMELESS POPULATION
RIGHT HERE IN OUR HOME STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS IS HOW DO YOU HOUSING
SHORTAGE IS NOT A PROBLEM THAT
DEVELOPED OVERNIGHT BUT A
PROBLEM THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
HAS CREATED IN YEARS PAST AND
REFUSE TO ADDRESSED.
THE REGULATIONS THAT WERE MEANT
TO PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT HAVE
INSTEAD BEEN USED AS A WEAPON
FOR PRIVATE COMPANIES AND OTHER
INTEREST GROUPS TO BLOCK
PROJECTS TO FURTHER THEIR OWN
AGENDA.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN TO
FIFTEEN ALONE SEQUEL LAWSUITS
BLOCKED NEARLY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA FOURTEEN THOUSAND
HOMES. THEY PEOPLE COULD HAVE
MOVED INTO WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
THE TIMES WERE. PLANNED TO BE
BUILT ON VACANT LOTS BY THE WAY
THERE IS NOTHING THAT NEEDED TO
BE TORN DOWN IN ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE ITS DEVELOPMENT.
THE ELLIOTTS OFFICE RECENTLY
REPORTED THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO PRODUCE APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND UNITS OF
HOUSING PER YEAR JUST TO KEEP UP
WITH THE POPULATION GROWTH.
IT'S A DO TIME THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ACTS IMPASSES NEEDS
TO COR FOR HIM TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR EVERYONE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
DEBORAH DEBORAH CARLTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
AND JOHN GAMBOA FROM THE TWO
HUNDRED ORGANIZATION A STATEWIDE
COALITION OF ADVOCATES WORKING
ON BEHALF. OF LOW INCOME
MINORITIES HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS
MEMBERS I AM I KNOW IT'S NOT AN
EASY TOPIC BUT I AM GOING TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
THINK JOHN IS GOING TO STE TO
START.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO ADDRESS YOU ON SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
TO MOST PEOPLE.
HOUSE SCENE IN HOMEOWNERSHIP IS
SAY.
ADEQUATE SHELTER ISSUE.
FOR MINORITIES IN THE
UNDERSERVED IT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS
IT IN ECONOMIC JUSTICE ISSUE.
ON IT.
MARTIN LUTHER KING. FIFTY WE'VE
BEEN CELEBRATING HIS JET
RECENTLY AND IS WORTH A.
STATED SUCCINCTLY THAT.
CIVIL THERE IS NO CIVIL RIGHTS
WITHOUT ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
ON IT.
FIFTY YEARS AGO ALSO PRESIDENT
JOHNSON.
PUT TOGETHER THE KERNER
COMMISSION.
TO INVESTIGATE THE CAUSES OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
THE COMMISSION CAME UP WITH.
THREE CAUSES FOR THOSE RIGHTS.
ONE WAS RAMPANT RACISM THE OTHER
ONE WAS HOUSING OF SEGREGATION
AND THE LAST WAS AGGRESSIVE
POLICING AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
A KIND OF STILL RESOUNDS TODAY
RIGHT
ON IT.
RIGHT AFTER THAT.
THE.
FOR FIFTY YEARS AFTER THAT THE
UPDATE ON THE KERNER COMMISSION
FONG.
THAT THERE WAS NO CHANGE AND IN
FACT.
THE WEALTH GAP IN THIS COUNTRY
HAD INCREASED.
THE REASON I RAISE THIS IS
BECAUSE.
HOUSING THEM HOMEOWNERSHIP.
IS THE MAJOR AVENUE TO WEALTH
ACCUMULATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
HOMEOWNERSHIP FROM NINETEEN
THIRTY TO NINETEEN SEVENTY
CREATED THE GREATEST MIDDLE
CLASS THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER
SEEN.
BECAUSE IT SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
AND MORTGAGES FOR QUITE FAMILIES
UNFORTUNATELY IT LEFT MINORITY
COMMUNITIES BEHIND ON IT.
MINORITY COMMUNITIES NINETEEN
SEVENTY STARTED CATCHING UP.
BECAUSE OF THE FAIR.
LET.
.
FAIR LAWS AROUND NOW EQUAL ON
THEM PREDICT ACT ON AND AS WE
STARTED CLOSING THAT GAP MONEY.
THROUGH HOMEOWNERSHIP.
ALL OF A SUDDEN. THE GREAT HOOK.
THE CALL NOW THE RECESSION CAME
ABOUT AND DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED MINORITY COMMUNITIES
BLACK AND LATINOS LOST.
THIRTY YEARS OF WEALTH AND JUST
THREE.
WE WERE BACK TO WHERE WE WHERE.
RIGHT AFTER THE ALL OF THE RED
LINE UNIT TAKEN PLACE WHEN.
YESTERDAY.
IN THE NEW YORK TIMES THE MAJOR
EDITORIAL CAME OUT AND STATED.
AND I QUOTE IT.
SIR I UP.
JUST LOOKED UP AT MY CLOCK HERE
AND THAT YOU HAVE EXCEEDED YOUR
TIME IF YOU CAN TRY TO WRAP UP
OKAY I'LL JUST SAVE VERY QUICKLY
ON.
THE MAJOR IMPEDIMENT TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN THE STATE IS.
THE MISUSE OF SEQUEL SEQUEL IS
ONE OF THE GREATEST.
LEGISLATION THAT WERE PASSED IN
THE STATE BUT IT'S BEEN MISUSED
BECAUSE THERE'S TWO LOOPHOLES.
ONE IS YOU CAN FILE ANONYMOUSLY
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PUT YOUR NAME
ON THE. ON THE BILL TO BLOCK ANY
HOUSING IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD AND
THE SECOND IS YOU CAN FILE A
LAWSUIT AFTER LAWSUIT DELAY
CONSTRUCTION. OF OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS HONEY.
WHAT'S COME ABOUT THAT IS LEFT
OUR COMMUNITY SO FAR SO FAR
BEHIND I URGE YOU IN OUR
ORGANIZATION URGES YOU. TO AT
LEAST PASS THIS BILL AND LET IT
GET TO THE FULL FLOOR. TO ALL
OUR LEGISLATORS AND IN THE STATE
CAN VOTE ON IT THANK YOU.
THE THING WAS CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS KEEP DONE FILLING IN FOR
DEMOCRATS AND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION COMPANY
PARTNER SOCIAIS XIN HAS LONG
RECOGNIZED AND HOMEOWNERSHIP IS
THE BEST WAY TO BUILD UP
COMMUNITIES TO HAVE THEM
INVESTED IN THOSE COMMUNITIES TO
PROVIDE. A STABLE ENVIRONMENT
FOR FAMILIES FOR SCHOOLS TO
EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN AND TO MOVE
THEM FORWARD IN THE ECONOMIC
ENGINE THAT IS CALIFORNIA WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO FINDING.
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO PROVIDE THAT
HOUSING.
WE THINK THIS IS A A NOVEL
APPROACH ONE THAT WE'VE TRIED
BEFORE.
BUT BUT MEETING THE HOUSING
NEEDS OF OUR CITIZENS REMAINS
CRITICAL SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
STRONG MIDDLE CLASS A TRAINED
AND SKILLED WORKFORCE TO HELP US
BUILD CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO BE
ABLE TO LIVE IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT THEY'RE
WORKING.
WE ENCOURAGE SUPPORT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
WE PROVIDE HOUSING FOR WORKERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ON BOB BREMER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YEAH WE COVERAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT THINK
YOU.
AT A RALLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SEEING NO
FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
HAVE WHAT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON COW JONES THE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL TODAY OUT WE AGREE
THAT THERE IS A HOUSING CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA BUT NOT THAT SEEK
WHAT IS THE STANDALONE BECAUSE
OF THE CRISIS THAT WE FACE NOW.
.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN DATA OUT THERE
TO POINT DEFINITIVELY THAT IT IS
JUST SEQUENCE EQUAL LOAN THAT IS
CAUSING. THE PRICES OF HOUSING
TO SOAR THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
NUMEROUS FACTORS IN THAT AND
FORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE DATA
ON LITIGATION RATES.
WE DON'T HAVE GOOD DATA ON THE
AMOUNT OF THE. TOTAL CASES FILED
OR OR HOW THOSE RESULT SO
WITHOUT THAT DATA IS IT'S REALLY
HARD TO JUST SAY THAT THIS IS
THE PROBLEM.
.
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S THERE'S
PROBLEMS WITH.
THE PROPOSALS IN THIS BILL.
REGARDLESS OF THE SITUATION ARE
BY LIMITING INJUNCTIONS ON CASES
ARE YOU THERE CAN BE SOMEWHAT
PERVERSE OUTCOMES. UP FOR
EXAMPLE WE'VE SEEN THAT WERE
INJUNCTIONS WERE NOT SOCCER
GRANTED IN PROJECTS THAT. THE
COURTS CAN ACTUALLY ORDER
DEMOLITION IF THEY DON'T COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
IF SUBSEQUENTLY I OURS ARE
REQUIRED I'M I THINK IT DOES PUT
A LOT OF UNDUE PRESSURE ON LEAD
AGENCIES ANALYZING THESE CASES.
TO BUT NOT GO AHEAD WITH WITH
ANY ANY CHANGES TO THE PROJECT
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY BUILT
OUT.
AND THIS COULD LEAD TO
UNINTENTIONAL IMPACTS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT GO ON MEDICAID
IT.
.
I'LL THERE ARE ALREADY
REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER TO MEET
INJUNCTIONS AND WE THINK IT WAS
INSUFFICIENT UP FOR SEQUEL
PURPOSES.
AND SO WE JUST DON'T THINK THIS
OUT THIS BILL. THIS BILL WILL
HAVE MORE PROBLEMS THAN THAN
WHAT SIX TO SOFTEN SO WHAT WE
ARE CHEN ABOUT.
TURN MEMBERS TAMPON FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE JEWISH
COUNCIL IS OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
FOR REASONS A SIMILAR TO THAT
THIRTY. OTHER BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN PENDING OVER.
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
A BIT OF GOOD BEEN DESIGNED TO
EITHER EXPEDITE.
SEVERELY EXPEDITE THE JUDICIAL
REVIEW TIME LINES ARE PROVIDE
THE SAME KIND THE LIMITS ON
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF.
TO BE CLEAR OUR OPPOSITION IS
NOT BASED ON ANY POSITIONS ON
SEQUEL OR THE MERITS OF THE
PARTICULAR HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE COVERED BY THIS
LEGISLATION. THOSE ARE POLICY
ISSUES OUTSIDE OUR PURVIEW OUR
SOLE FOCUS OR IS ON WHAT THE
COURT IMPACT THE ADVERSE COURT
IMPACTS LEGISLATION LIKE THIS.
NOT RESULT IN
THE COURTS HAVE BROAD EQUITABLE
POWERS IN EVERY CASE INCLUDING
SECRET MATTERS.
A FASHION AN INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
WHEN VIOLATIONS OF BEEN FOUND
BASED ON THE RECORD IN FRONT OF
THE COURT. AND APPLICABLES LA IT
IS OFTEN THE CASE ARE SECRETIVE
JUST TELL US.
THAT THAT IT'S NOT THAT THE
ENTIRE PROJECT IS FLAWED AND
NEEDS TO START OVER THERE
TARGETED SPECIFIC AREAS. OF
NONCOMPLIANCE IN THE COURT BASED
ON THOSE FINDINGS
A ISSUES AN INJUNCTION THAT IS
TARGETED TO REMEDYING THOSE
PARTICULAR VIOLATIONS
BILLS LIKE THIS SAY THAT THE
COURT IS ABSOLUTELY PROHIBITED.
FROM ISSUING SUCH A TARGETED
INJUNCTION REGARDLESS OF THE
FACTS.
AND THE LAWN IN FRONT OF THE
COURT IN ITS FOR THOSE REASONS
IN THE COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSES THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY UP FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
SEEING NINE
COMING FORWARD USE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY.
I MATTHEW FIGURE WITH A P. C.
OPENING CONSERVATION THE WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. FOR THE.
STATEMENTS MADE PREVIOUSLY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
SEEN AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MR ACOSTA.
BOB.
THANK YOU.
MS ONE IS FOR BRING IN THE BILL
IN FEAR YOUR WITNESS.
I DID HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
FOR THE SIERRA CLUB REPRESENTED
THAT'S OKAY.
I'M GONNA I'M GONNA PASS ON
THAT I WILL JUST SAY THIS THAT
I'M HERE HAVING SO MANY SICK
RELATED ISSUES IN MY DISTRICT.
THERE'S THERE'S FRANKLY SEEK
WAS.
A LANDMARK LEGISLATION AYE YOUR
WITNESS US ARE YOU YOU MENTION
WHAT WHAT WHAT THE.
LANDMARK LEGISLATION IT IS IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALL WANT TO
PROTECT AND PRESERVE.
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY WERE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE ONE APPROACH
PROTECT PRESERVE THOSE BUT OUR
QUALITY AND OUR WAY OF LIFE.
BUT PART OF THAT.
IT IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US AS
WELL AS LEGISLATE TOURS.
THAT WE ALSO TAKE CARE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THIS
STATE.
AND I APPLAUD YOU BECAUSE I'M
LOOKING AT.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW VARIOUS ARENAS AND
STADIUMS AND FRANKLY THE CAPITAL
ANNEX THAT IS PROPOSED RIGHT
HERE IT'S AT.
THE STATE CAPITOL THAT WHILE
WILL BE GRANTED OR IS.
PROPOSED TO BE GRANTED A IN
SOME FORM OF SECRET RELIEF WE'VE
HAD MULTIPLE.
HEARINGS IN THIS VERY CHAMBER
REGARDING SEEK RELIEF FOR THOSE
VERY STADIUMS AND ARENAS THAT
I'M ALL FOR THEY CREATE JOBS.
IN IN IN ECONOMIC VITALITY IN
OUR DISTRICTS IN OUR COMMUNITY
IN THE STATE. BUT WE ALSO HAVE
HAVE A PLACE FOR THOSE PEOPLE TO
LIVE.
AND THIS IS A PIECE OF THAT.
ALSO THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND.
MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT THE
COURTS WILL THE COURTS ARE THERE
TO SERVE THE PUBLIC.
AND IF WE HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
COURTS THAT WE SHOULD TAKE
IT WE SHOULD GO INTO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND AND
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND ADDRESS
THEM. SATISFACTORILY IN THE
BUDGET BECAUSE IF YOU ARE DENIED
YOUR DAY IN COURT FOLKS.
YOU'RE YOUR YOUR JUSTICES
TONIGHT THAT'S ALL OFTENTIMES IF
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED AS THE EXPRESSION GOES.
SO I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS I
DID SECOND TO THE MOTION BUT I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THIS COMMITTEE NEEDS TO TAKE A
VERY GOOD SERIOUS HARD LOOK AT
WHETHER IT'S THIS BILL OR
ANOTHER BILL. I JUST BE.
JUST PREDISPOSED TO THIS BILL
IN FRONT OF US BUT I DID MAKE
AMENDMENTS IN THIS VERY
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR ON THIS VERY
ISSUE.
THAT WE'RE IN I WAS NOT
SUCCESSFUL
BUT THAT'S NOT THE POINT THE
POINT IS IS THAT WE NEED TO
MILLION UNITS IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE NEVER GONNA GET THERE IF
WE KEEP SAYING IT'S A. IT'S ONLY
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS ALL THESE
OTHER ISSUES LET'S TACKLE THIS
ONE THAT WILL MOVE ON TO
JUDICIARY WILL MOVE ON THE LABOR
WILL MOVE ON TO OTHER ISSUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND THEN
WE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE A PLACE
FOR OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
GRANDCHILDREN TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND AFFORDABLE RATE
AS OPPOSED TO. A HAVING THE MOVE
OUT OF STATE WHICH IS HAPPENING.
RIGHT LEFT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
THE BILL.
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE FROM THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO.
ASK QUESTIONS SAYING NONE.
MISS SURE I'M MS MELENDEZ.
SO.
MY CONCERN.
IS
THAT.
WHILE.
I THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT.
.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MY CONCERN IS IS THAT YOUR BILL
SEEKS A. ENTIRE CATEGORICAL.
LIMITATION TO INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
FOR ALL NEW HOUSING.
AND.
.
IT IS MY OPINION THAT THE WILD.
YOU KNOW EVER SINCE I FIRST CAME
UP HERE WITH YOU IN TWENTY
TWELVE I'VE BEEN.
OPEN TO IDEAS ON.
HOW TO?
IMPROVE SEQUEL HOW TO.
CUT DOWN ON THE ABUSES.
WITH A SEQUEL LITIGATION.
BUT I.
I DO NOT SEE THAT WITH THIS BILL
IN TERMS OF A CATEGORICAL.
LIMITATION ON INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
FOR ALL NEW HOUSING.
ONE TO GIVE YOUR RESPONSE CHEST
WAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
IT AND I'D.
YOU KNOW I WILL SAY THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
THE FACT THAT WE YOU AND I CAME
UP HERE AT THE SAME TIME IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE.
.
AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN THINGS GET
BETTER.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM IS WE'VE SEEN
HOMELESSNESS INCREASE WE'VE SEEN
AYE THE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
MORE HOUSING UNITS FOR PEOPLE.
STIFLE MORE AND MORE OVER THE
YEARS SO WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
WITNESSES COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
WHEN WE HAVE BILLS LIKE THAT
WHETHER IT'S DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN AND WE PLAY THIS GAME
OF HIDE THE P.. YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T DO THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
DO THAT WE CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO DO THIS AND WE'LL
JUST KEEP MOVING. ALL THE PARTS
AROUND UNTIL WE NEVER DO
ANYTHING AND THAT'S ON HELPING
ANYWAY. WE WE HAVE MORE THAN A
FOURTH OF THE NATION'S HOMELESS
POPULATION RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
NOT SAYING THAT EVERYONE OF THE
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE
HOMELESS WOULD ULTIMATELY WIND
UP PURCHASING A HOME ARE RENTING
A HOME BUT A VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT WOULD. AND THAT'S A REALITY
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
HASN'T GOTTEN BETTER WALK AROUND
IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO MY
GOODNESS
THAT'S GOT CERTAINLY GOTTEN
WORSE GO DOWN TO ORANGE COUNTY
WHERE THEY HAVE MILES. AND TENT
CITIES.
FOR PEOPLE WHO WHO DON'T HAVE
HOMES
THIS IS A MODEST PROPOSAL I GET
IT I KNOW PEOPLE GET. THEY GET
LEERY THEY GET TIMID THE SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS COMMAND THAT
EVERYBODY WANTS TO PROTECT THEIR
TURF I UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THAT AT SOME POINT WE
AS LEGISLATORS HAVE TO JUST.
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO LISTEN TO ALL THE NOISE
OUT THERE WE'RE GONNA LISTEN TO
WHAT'S IN OUR HEAD BUT IS WHAT
WE BELIEVE TO BE TRUE AND THAT
WILL BE HELPFUL. TO CALIFORNIANS
AND WE'RE JUST GONNA. RIP THE
BANDAID OFF IN MARCH FORWARD AND
DO WHAT'S RIGHT WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING. WE KEEP GOING IN
CIRCLES.
AND I JUST IT IT IT SADDENS ME
TO LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE HOMES A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BUY HIM BUT
CAN'T AFFORD IT. THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO JUST THERE JUST ARE
NO HOMES AVAILABLE EVEN IF THEY
COULD AFFORD IT THIS IS.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS WE I'M ASKING
YOU
I JUST
JOIN ME IN THIS MODEST EFFORT
BELIEVE ME I WOULD LIKE TO DO
MUCH OF. OUR BUT I KNOW BETTER
THAN TO BRING THAT BILL TO THIS
COMMITTEE BUT I THINK THIS IS
MODEST AND I THINK THIS WILL
HELP CALIFORNIANS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN MIND THIS IS
HOUSING IS IN A PARTISAN ISSUE
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL TAKE
THAT AS YOUR CLOSING STATEMENT.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION AS A
NO.
WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
THE ROLE.
I AM TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY SIX BY MELENDEZ THE MOTION
IS TO PASS A REFER TO HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
NOW BROUGHT SUIT YOU KNOW ACOSTA
AYE AYE CUSTER AYE BLOOM.
LUNA VOTING.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING.
FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
LIMON NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ AYE.
MELINDA'S AYE STONE.
THREE TWO.
SO THIS BILL IS ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT MISTER FRAZIER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
YOU ARE NEXT UP
.
SCISSOR AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
ONE.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS TODAY A PRESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE. WHICH
WILL SECURE
SECURE DESPERATELY NEEDED
FUNDING TO REMOVE ABANDON
COMMERCIAL VESSELS THROUGHOUT
THE DELTA.
FIRST I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
WE MOVE THE BILL FORWARD.
ABANDONED VESSELS ARE A MASSIVE
PROBLEM THE SACRAMENT SACRAMENTO
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA.
IT'S ESTIMATED THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ABANDONED
VESSELS.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE TO
COMPLETELY ERADICATE.
THESE VESSELS POSE A DIRECT
THREAT TO THE DELTA ENVIRONMENT
THE NAVIGATION OF THE DELTA AND
THE ENTIRE STATE'S WATER
QUALITY.
THEY LEACH OF ASBESTOS LEAD
PETROLEUM AND MANY OTHER
DANGEROUS TOXINS INTO OUR WATER
SUPPLY.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT AERIAL
SURVEY.
THERE ARE ABOUT FIFTY FOUR
BANDICOOTS OF VESSELS IN THE
DELTA REGION AND AND WILL COST
THOUSAND TO REMOVE.
UNLIKE RECREATIONAL VESSELS
COMMERCIAL VESSELS TO NOT HAVING
ANY AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR
REMOVAL.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE WOULD
RE DIRECT STATE PROPERTY LEASE
REVENUE. WITHIN THE FIVE DELTA
COUNTY COUNTIES OF CONTRA COSTA
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN SOLANO
AND YOLO. INTO A NEW ACCOUNT FOR
THE REMOVAL OF ABANDON
COMMERCIAL VESSELS OR SKIN IN
THE GAME.
THIS NEW ACCOUNT WOULD BE
MANAGED BY THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AS THEY WOULD WORK
WITH LOCAL AGENCIES TO REMOVE
THESE ABANDONED VESSELS.
WITH ME TODAY'S SERGEANT MIKE
BERRY.
WITH THE CONTRA COSTA SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT TO SPEAK ON THE
SITUATION AND THE IMPACT THESE
VESSELS HAVE ON THE PATROLLING
THE PIA DELTA. AND SHERRY
PEMBERTON.
FROM THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
TO RESPOND ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMISSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON SERGEANT MICHAEL
VERY WITH CONTRAST SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
FIRST VALUES LIKE TO THANK THE
MEMBER AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR YOUR SERVICE IT'S GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO STATE THAT AS
THE SUPERVISOR OF THE MARINE
SERVICES UNIT. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL VESSELS THAT INTO
GETTING A BANDAID. ABATED AND
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO GO DOWN OR
TO GO DOWN OUR WATERWAYS.
WE HAVE A MEANS TO DEAL WITH
THOSE IF THE RECREATIONAL
VESSELS WE HAVE GRANT FUNDS TO
DO THAT BUT IF IT'S COMMERCIAL
ALSO WE HAVE KNOWN MEANS
WHATSOEVER. DO YOU THAT.
WE HAVE SEVERAL COMMERCIAL
VESSELS THAT ARE IN OUR
WATERWAYS CURRENTLY. THAT ARE IN
NATURAL HABITATS POLLUTING THOSE
HABITATS.
IF THEY DO GO DOWN HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO DO EVEN MORE DAMAGE
WITH THE LEADS IN THAT THE
SOLVENTS ARE GOING TO IT.
I AM HERE REPRESENTING IN THE
ATION. VOTING AND WATERCRAFT SIX
COMMITTEE ALSO.
.
AND JUST WANT TO SHOW MY SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AS SHERRY PEMBERTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION ARE COMMISSION
DOES NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
ON THIS LEGISLATION BUT IT'S
SLATED TO CONSIDER ADOPTING A.
POSITION NEXT WEEK AND A STAFF
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF OF THE BILL.
WE HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF THE
COMMISSION OF TRYING TO REMOVE
ABANDONED VESSELS FROM STATE
WATER WAYS BUT WE LACK THE
FUNDING. WE THINK THE CONCEPT IN
THE SPELL IS A REALLY GREAT WAY
TO TRY TO PROVIDE THAT FUNDING
AND REMOVE ABANDONED VESSELS
FROM OUR WATERWAYS AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. MOVE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS SHOT HERE AND TO
HIM BEHALF OF THE COUNTY SOLANO
AND THE FIVE COUNTY DELTA. A
COUNTIES COALITION AFTER THE
REASONS MISTER FRAZIER STATED
RELATING TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS OF THESE VESSELS PRESENT
AS WELL AS THE SAFETY CONCERNS
THAT ARE OUT THERE IS A USER THE
DELTA. I SEE IT ALL THE TIME.
THESE BOATS ARE A NUISANCE
IMMIGRATION WE APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS EFFORTS TO GET MORE
RESOURCES STATE LANDS COMMISSION
TO TACKLE THE PROBLEM THANK YOU
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY MOST.
THAT BENJAMIN PALMER BEHALF
CONTRA COSTA ANNUAL COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
JERRY MEMBERS PRESSMAN UNION
BEHALF OF THE SPACE REGIONAL
PARK DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS JERRY DOES BEEN
WITH RECREATIONAL BOATERS A
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
IN SUPPORT OF THE CONCEPT. TO
LOOK AT THE ABANDONED COMMERCIAL
WATERCRAFT IN THE RESOURCES TO
READ THOSE OF THE WATERWAYS OF
THOSE VESSELS WERE SENSITIVE TO
WHAT THE. FINAL SOLUTION OF THE
MONEY WILL BE TO PAY FOR THAT OF
WERE ALWAYS SENSITIVE TO THE
HARBORS WATER FROM HOLDING FUND
IS A MEMBER FRAZIER IS VERY WELL
AWARE BUT WE APPRECIATE THE.
CONCEPT OF THE BILL TO GET RID
OF COMMERCIAL ABANDONED
WATERCRAFT.
THANK YOU.
BUT THINK YOU AND I WANT THINK
OTHER FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD HAVE REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND AS WE ARE ALSO TALKING
EARLIER ABOUT HOUSING IS AN
ISSUE THAT HAPPENS WITH THAT
ABANDONED VESSELS HOMELESS TAKEN
OVER AND THEY BECOME PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE USE DRUGS AND. THEN
TRAFFIC OTHER HUMANS AND THEY
BECOME LIKE FLOATING LITTLE
LITTLE ISLANDS OF OF THINGS THAT
WE DON'T WANT GOING ON. THEM AND
WHEN THE TIME TO PUT IT LIKE TO
BE AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU'D BE SO
KIND.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
I AM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY ONE BY MEMBER FRAZIER DO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI. MURATSUCHI AYE
ACOSTA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA AYE FLORA AYE
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ. LINDA'S
AYE STONE.
SEVEN ZERO.
SOME TIME CELEBRATE MY FIRST ONE
OF THE OUT OF THIS COMPUTER.
ALRIGHT NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
GRAYSON.
AND THIS IS.
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINETY ONE.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL. AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
AS AMENDED AB TWENTY NINETY ONE
ESTABLISHES A PRESCRIBED BURN
MANAGER CERTIFICATE OF SPECIAL
WITH A SPECIALIZATION WITHIN THE
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL FORSTER
PROGRAM. AND TASK CALIFORNIA
WITH CREATING AN INSURANCE
OPTION FOR CERTIFIED BURN
MANAGES TO LOWER COSTS AND
IMPROVE LIABILITY PROTECTION.
THIS BILL IS AN ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS ONE ASPECT OF OUR
RESPONSE TO THE DEVASTATING TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WILDFIRE
SEASON. WHICH IS THE NEED TO
INCREASE THE SCALE OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE AS A BENEFICIAL FORCE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICE.
REPORTS ON FORCED HEALTH
RELEASED BY THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE AND THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION
BOTH ADVOCATE FOR MORE ACTIVE
MANAGEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
FOREST INCLUDING THE INCREASED
USE OF PRESCRIBED FIRE. HOWEVER
LIABILITY CONCERNS AND THE COST
OF INSURANCE HAVE CONSISTENTLY
BEEN CITED AS ROADBLOCKS TO THE
USE OF.
SCRIBE FIRE WHILE INSURANCE FOR
LANDOWNERS AND PRACTITIONERS IS
AVAILABLE IT IS OFTEN
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE.
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE IN TWO STEPS
FIRST IT ESTABLISHES A
PRESCRIBED BURN MANAGER
CERTIFICATE OF SPECIALIZATION
WITHIN THE LICENSE PROFESSIONAL
FORSTER PROGRAM.
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION HAS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE TRAINING.
EXAMINING AND REGISTERING
PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS
THEREFORE IT'S THE APPROPRIATE
ENTITY TO TAKE ON THIS TASK
SECOND IT DIRECTS CAL FIRE TO
DEVELOP AN INSURANCE OPTION FOR
CERTIFIED BURN MANAGERS THAT
WOULD LOWER COST. AND IMPROVE
LIABILITY PROTECTION.
NO THIS BILL IS NOT PRESCRIPTIVE
AS TO THAT TYPE OF PRODUCT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR SHOULD OFFER IS
MY FACT IT DOES REQUIRE THE GOAL
THAT THE OPTION INCREASE THE
USE.
A PRESCRIBED FIRE I'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE WHITE
WIDE RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS TO
REFINE AND IMPROVE THIS BILL SO
THAT IT ACHIEVES ITS GOAL OF
GETTING MORE FIRE ON THE LAND IN
A SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
I LOOK FORWARD TO A CONTINUING
TOAPPROVE THIS BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD.
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU
DO YOU HAVE A WITNESSES AND.
I DO.
ALLY THEMSELF INTRODUCE.
GOOD MORNING ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAUL MASON FOR PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THEM
LIMON GRAYSON'S
WORK ON THIS ISSUE IT'S BEEN
GRATIFYING TO SEE THE LEVEL OF
ATTENTION. TO THE INCREASED USE
OF PROACTIVE PRESCRIBED FIRE AS
AN ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION AND
MAINTENANCE TOOL. WROTE PRETTY
AT THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE OTHER.
IS A NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS
DEALING WITH PRESCRIBED FIRE AND
ECOSYSTEM RESILIENCE AND THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE A CONVERSATION
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE
PROCESS TO ALIGN THOSE DIFFERENT
BILLS. THERE'S A BILL BY MISTER
WOULD INVITE HIM SENATOR JACKSON
IN THIS BILL. COMMIT ONGOING
CONVERSATION WE ARE MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRINGING THESE ISSUES FORWARD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
TWITTER'S.
SINGLE PICKY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
BUT WE'VE SUBMITTED LETTERS.
JUST TRYING TO.
PUT OUT THERE FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WHAT A COMPREHENSIVE
PRESCRIBED BURN. LEGISLATION
WOULD WOULD LOOK LIKE AND WHAT
COMPONENTS WE THINK ARE
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR FOLKS TO
ACTUALLY.
BE ABLE TO START USING
PRESCRIBED BURN.
WE THINK THAT LIABILITY FOR
SOME FOREMOST HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
EITHER BY.
.
USING PRIMA FISHEL LANGUAGE OR
BY.
CHANGING NEGLIGENCE TO.
A HIGHER. BURDEN.
WE ALSO THINK THAT INSURANCE
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED CURRENTLY
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN SIX STATES THAT CAL FIRE
IN ITS DISCRETION MAY PURCHASE A
THIRD PARTY LIABILITY. POLICY OF
INSURANCE THAT PROVIDES COVERAGE
AGAINST LOS.
.
BUT IF THEY ELECT NOT TO
PURCHASE THE INSURANCE THEY MUST
AGREE TO INDEMNIFY AND HOLD
HARMLESS THE PERSON OR PUBLIC
AGENCY IN CURRENTLY THAT ISN'T
HAPPENING IN THE CONTRACTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS THE
CERTIFIED BURNERS.
AND THAT CAL FIRE. HAS A LOT OF
FOLKS THAT WHOSE EXPERTISE IS TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS TYPE OF WORK
HOWEVER. THOSE FOLKS ARE ALSO
DOING MULTIPLE JOBS AT THE SAME
TIME AND AS THE STATE MOVES TO
YEAR ROUND FIRE SEASON. THOSE
FOLKS THAT ARE CAPABLE OF DOING
THAT KIND OF WORK BECOME
UNAVAILABLE.
.
WE ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WHILE
A LOT OF FOLKS ARE TALKING ABOUT
PRESCRIBED FIRE AS ONE OF THE
TOOLS THAT WE CAN USE TO HELP US
GET OUT OF THE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN NOW WITH THE FOREST.
THAT IS CERTAINLY NOT THE ONLY
TOOL WE NEED TO HAVE ALL THE
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO
USE.
PARTICULARLY MECHANICAL
THINNING AND ORDER TO HAVE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE PRESCRIBED BURNS
THAT WE CAN OUT THERE. IN MOST
CASES WE HAVE TO DO MECHANICAL
THINNING FIRST AND FOREMOST
UNLIKE SURE THOSE ISSUES ARE NOT
LEFT BEHIND.
AND OTHER ISSUES THAT MAY NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED ARE THINGS LIKE.
.
GETTINGAIR PERMIT AND
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE KINDS OF
OF.
I ISSUES ARE ALSO IMPORTANT HER
FOLKS BUT WE HAVE WORKED WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM. AND HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION
FOR PRESCRIBED FOR.
MR MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE HERE FOR
CALVET ELECTIONS FORCE
ASSOCIATION FORCED LANDINGS OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO DON'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT WE
HAVEN'T SHE DISCUSSIONS WITH.
GRAYSON WEEK WE APPRECIATE HIM
FOR NOTICES BILL TO GET THE
DISCUSSION STARTED I I THINK WE
SHARE SOME THE SAME CONCERNS
PARTICULAR LIABILITY. IT IS THE
SINGLE BIGGEST IMPEDIMENT TO TRY
TO GET THESE PRESCRIBED BURNS
STARTED. AND I THINK THE OTHER
AIR QUALITY ISSUE WITH RESPECT
TO THE AIRPORT.
HOW WE ADDRESS THAT AS WELL BUT
WE LOOK TOWARD WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THIS BILL FOR?
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND ONLY SERVER WITH DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN THE NOTICES WORK
IN PROGRESS BUT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MISS THE MARK WELL I'LL JUST
COMMENT THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT CONSIDERING SOME OF
THE WILD FIRES WE HAD AND I KNOW
IT'S PART OF A GREATER
CONVERSATION THE STATE SO I
APPRECIATE BRING IT FORWARD AND
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS. THANK
MS EGGMAN. AND ALSO IT'S
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE YOU'RE AT THE TABLE
AND MEETING WITH EVERYBODY TO
TRY TO GET SOMETHING THAT'S
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL FOR OFFICE
SPACE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OCEAN MOVES AND SECONDED.
SO MISTER GRAYSON AND I THINK
IT'S CLEAR THAT.
SEEM TO HAVE BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS THAT THIS IS A A GOOD
EFFORT AND AND THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE WE ARE.
SURE THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND
SO.
BUT THAT.
.
SHARES RECOMMENDATION IS TO.
DO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND WITH THAT.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I DO NINE AB TWENTY NINETY ONE
BY MEMBER GRAYSON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS BROUGHT TO TREAT AYE
ROUTE TO GI ACOSTA.
LOU.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MELENDEZ LINDA'S AYE
STONE.
SEVEN ZERO.
BILLS OUT FLICK ASHES.
ALRIGHT NEXT TO HAVE MISTER
BERMAN WITH AB TWENTY NINE OH
EIGHT
.
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THE YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES KNOW ME START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR HER WORK ON THIS
BILL AS WELL AS THE PREVIOUS
VERSIONS OF IT.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SUGGESTS
CRACKING DRAFTING ERRORS.
INCORRECT DATES ON PAGES NOT ON
PAGE NINE LINE SEVEN IN TEN
WHICH WERE NOT UPDATED FROM THE
PREVIOUS BILL CORRECTING A
MISSPELLING AND FILLING IN A
BLANK DATE WITH. THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIANS GENERATE
FORTY FOUR MILLION USED TO TIRES
EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND THE
MANAGEMENT OF THESE TIRES HAS
PROVEN DIFFICULT.
ILLEGALLY DUMPED TIRES POSE A
SIGNIFICANT COST TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS
IN THE STATE.
AND AND THE STATE.
LARGE ABANDONED HIGHER POWERS
HAVE RESULTED IN WEEKS LONG
FIRES AND THE OVERALL RECYCLING
RATE HAS GONE DOWN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS.
IN ORDER TO SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE TIRE RECYCLING KALRA
CYCLE RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IMPLEMENT AN
EXPANDED INCENTIVE PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES PAYMENTS FOR DIVIDE FOR
DESIRED AND USES OF TIRES.
AB TWENTY NINE OH WAIT WOULD
CREATE THE TIRE RECYCLING
INCENTIVE PROGRAM HELP EXPAND
THE STATE'S TIRE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES. CREATE JOBS
AND CUT THE STATEWIDE AND LOCAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH HIGHER
PILE CLEANUP AND ILLEGALLY
DUMPED TIRES.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WOULD
EMPLOY A PROVEN MODEL OF
PERFORMANCE BASED INCENTIVE
FUNDING.
SUPPORT THE USE OF RUBBERIZED
PAVEMENT AND OTHER CONSUMER
PRODUCT USES FOR RECYCLED TIRES.
IT WOULD AUTHORIZE AN INCENTIVE
PAYMENT TO END USERS OF RECYCLED
TIRES INCLUDING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT USED TIRES AS
RUBBERIZED PAVEMENT. AND
MANUFACTURERS TO PRODUCE
CONSUMER PRODUCTS USING RECYCLED
TIRES.
THE FUN THIS NEW PROGRAM COVER
CYCLE WITH FIRST EXHAUST ANY
SURPLUS DOLLARS IN THE
CALIFORNIA TIRE RECYCLING
MANAGEMENT FIVE.
ONCE THE TIRE FUND SURPLUSES
DRAWN DOWN COVER CYCLE WILL BE
AUTHORIZED TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA TIRE REGULATORY FEE
AN AMOUNT NOT TO EXCEED ONE
DOLLAR PER TIRE. IN ORDER TO
COVER ITS COSTS OF REGULATING
WASTE TIRES.
IN ORDER TO INSURE THAT THE FEE
IS PROPERLY SET AND REYES IS
ONLY THE AMOUNT NEEDED TOWER
CYCLE WOULD BE REQUIRED TO ADOPT
A FEE IMPLEMENTATION
REGULATIONS.
TO IMPLEMENT THE FEE AND HAVE A
PUBLIC PROCESS FOR SETTING THE
FEE AND FOR FUTURE ADJUSTMENTS.
COLLEAGUES THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT OUR CURRENT TIRE RECYCLING
PROGRAM IS NOT GENERATING THE
RESULTS THAT WE NEED.
AND ESTABLISHING THIS NEW TIRE
RECYCLING INCENTIVE PROGRAM
WOULD RESULT IN REDUCED
POLLUTION AND ILLEGAL DUMPING
WHILE ALSO CREATING NEW JOBS AND
STIMULATING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY NINE OH EIGHT.
AND I HAVE.
EXPERTS HERE TO TESTIFY AS WELL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
MURRAY WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE.
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
OF THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THIS COMMITTEE IS SEEN IN
ADVANCE TO THE SAME PROPOSAL
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME ON THIS
BILL HAS BEEN BEFORE AND WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT IN THE
PAST.
THE.
BUT IN THE LAST YEAR THE
RECYCLING RATE IN THE RECOVERY
RATE FOR TIRES CONTINUES TO MOVE
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
AND CONSUMERS ARE SPENDING A
GREAT DEAL OF MONEY MOVING TIRES
AROUND BUT THOSE TIRES ARE NOT
GETTING RECYCLED. THIS IS THIS
PROPOSAL IS AIMED AT.
.
SHIFTING THE PARADIGM WITH
REGARD TO THE TIRE RECYCLING
PROGRAM SO THAT INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING THE DOLLARS ALL AT THE
BACKEND WHERE CONSUMERS ARE
CHARGE FOR THE DISPOSAL THE
TIRES. WE'RE GOING TO CREATE THE
INCENTIVES AT THE END USE THAT
WE DESIRE AT THE NINETY PERCENT
RECYCLING AND USE THAT IS IN THE
LEGISLATION.
THIS PROGRAM IS MODELED AFTER
EXISTING RECYCLING INCENTIVES
PROGRAMS WE HAVE FOR ELECTRONIC
WASTE FOR BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
AND OTHER MATERIALS WE KNOW HOW
TO DO THIS WE KNOW HOW TO GET
THESE TIRES RECYCLED AND TO.
THE THE HIGHEST AND BEST USE.
AND THAT HIGHEST AND BEST USE
ISN'T JUST UP APPROPRIATE IN
TERMS OF RECOVERING THOSE TIRES
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ILLEGALLY DUMPED TIRES WE
DON'T HAVE TIRES GOING TO LAND
FULLER WE DON'T HAVE TIRES BEING
BURNED.
YOU KNOW THAT WHEN WE UTILIZE
THOSE TIRES AS RIVER PAVING
MATERIALS IT MAKES FOR BETTER.
LONGER LASTING ROADS THAT ARE
QUIETER ON AND THAT ULTIMATELY
SAVE.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT MONEY
SO WE HAVE A THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE AREAS WHERE WE KNOW WE
HAVE AN IN USE WE JUST GOT TO
CONNECT THE DOTS LIKE PUTTING
THE INCENTIVES IN THE RIGHT
PLACE. RATHER THAN HAVING ALL
THE INCENTIVE AT THE BACK AND TO
JUST GO TO THE CHEAPEST DISPOSAL
WERE BURNED FOR EXPORT. THE
URGENT AYE VOTE.
JEFF SERIES ON HALF OF THE U. S.
TIRE MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
WE'VE BEEN WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AND HAD DIFFERENT POSITIONS OF
THE PAST SEVERAL VERSIONS BUT TO
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH CAO
RECYCLE.
JESSICA AND A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
SUPPORT IT OF THEM I THINK
ORIGINALLY WAS A LOT OF CONCERNS
BECAUSE THIS PARASITE ALREADY
HAD AN ENORMOUS SURPLUS AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THINGS WE ASK FOR WAS
LET'S SPEND DOWN. ALL THE MONEY
BEFORE YOU ALLOWED CHARGING A
ONE OF THE AGREED TO THAT. WE
ALSO AGREE WITH WHAT THE MARK
MURRAY JUST SAID WHICH IS
PROBABLY THE HIGHEST AND BEST
USE IS PUTTING THIS ON OUR ROADS
WHICH IS WHY THERE'S LANGUAGE IN
THERE THAT CAO RECYCLED SEPASANG
BUT AT LEAST FIFTY PERCENT HAS
TO GO TO THE ROOTS. NOW WE HAVE
S. B. ONE FUNDING HOPEFULLY WILL
START BUILDING MORE ROADS IN
ADDRESSING THIS PROBLEM.
SO YEAH WE APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH THEM.
THE BILL MAY OR MAY NOT BE
PERFECT BUT IT'S UNCERTAIN MOST
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND WE
ENCOURAGE OUR SPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MARKETS AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
HERE IN SUPPORT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE CRITICAL
PARTNERS WITH THE STUDY I TO
DENVER ARE RECYCLABLE MATERIALS
OUT OF OUR LANDFILLS BUT REALLY
ARE CRITICAL TO THIS PROCESS IS.
MARKET INCENTIVES AND AND USES
FOR THESE TYPES OF PRODUCTS AND
WE FEEL THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
PROVIDE SOME STABILITY AND LONG
TERM FUNDING. AND THOSE
INCENTIVES FOR THAT PROCESS THAT
WE AREN'T SUPPORT THINK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS JUST LOAN FOR
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT AS A SAUCE BY WATER
BOND CALIFORNIA TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL FOR THE BILL
THANK YOU.
AND LISA PARA DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RECALL MONSTER
THAT AUTO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND IN SUPPORT.
MARY PICK OVERALL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THEY'RE LUCAS FOR SOME HALF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
HI MERRILY ECKERD I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE TODAY AND
I'M IN SUPPORT.
FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS CLIFF
COST AND THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION I'M A TWEENER
PRECISELY THIS THE RIGHT TIME TO
COME UP. OF THE COMPANY NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION HAS
PREVIOUSLY OPPOSE PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS BILL A WE'VE
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT.
PER TIRE ALLOCATION VERSUS A PER
VEHICLE AT ALLOCATION A WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THIS MEASURE LAST YEAR WE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION WITH A
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
AND TRY TO FIND A WAY TO FIX
THAT. THAT PROPOSAL BEING A TWO
THIRDS VOTE BILL WE DECIDED TO
WAIT UNTIL TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD ON THAT BUT WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THE BILL. THAT'S WHY
WE ARE AGGRESSIVELY NEUTRAL
THINKS EMERGING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS.
AT PUB OUR ON BEHALF OF CRM.
I.
ONE DAY INTRODUCED MY CLIENT
WILL BE MAKING SOME TESTIMONY IS
VERY TALK LOU WITH C. ARE AND
HE'S BEEN IN THE RECYCLING
BUSINESS FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND. RECYCLES.
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TIRES A
YEAR AND HAD SOME.
VERY WELL THOUGHT OUT WELL
CONSTRUCTED.
.
VIEWS ON THIS LEGISLATION A
LECTURE AT THE COMMITTEE.
A.
BOARD MEMBERS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON VERY TACKLE WHAT'S YOUR M. ON
THE PRESIDENT AND OWNER OF CRM
COMPANY.
WE'VE BEEN IN RECYCLING THEISEN
STILL CALIFORNIA FOR OVER.
TWENTY YEARS WE HAVE APPLYING TO
KEENE COMPTON AT THIS TIME FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS AND. YOU ARE
UNDER CONSTRUCTION A NEW PLAN IN
THIS STOCKTON TO CYCLE OVER
SEVEN MILLION TIRES.
ANNUALLY.
AND.
.
WE ALSO PLANS ALL POLL THE OTHER
LOCATIONS SAYS SUCH AS NEW YORK
ARIZONA HANG CANADA.
AND. MY PERSONAL BACKGROUND HE'S
RATHER MODIFIED ASPHALT ON THE
REGISTER PROFESSIONALS OF AN
ENGINEER. I FORTY SUPPORT.
MISTER BERMAN SO.
BILL HA EVER. AL WE HAVE SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE ISSUES VETO
THE BILL HAS EATEN.
AND. IT THIS TIME MY COMPANY A
LONG WEEK.
OVER NINETY FISH NOT THE TOY YOU
SLACKERS OF A STILL CALIFORNIA
OPPOSING THIS BILL FOR THREE
MAIN REASONS.
NUMBER ONE WE BELIEVE RATHER
MODIFIED WHAT IS A GREAT.
THE IN USE FOR RUBBER MOTHER OF
FOUR RECYCLED RUBBER WE LIKE THE
MONEY MOVES FROM THE STATE
GOVERNMENT TO DENOTE CHO
GOVERNMENT. LIKE AB FIVE TWO
TEAM IS BEING DOING.
WE WERE BELIEVE THAT'S WHERE DID
YOU CAN GET THE BEST RECYCLING
AND THAT'S WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
GET MARKET PULLED FLOODED THE
MARKET PUSH.
THE THE SECOND ITEM JUST BILL
WOULD.
JESUS DISCOURAGE USE OPTED
ROBERT HIM FEEL. IN AS IN
PLAYFIELDS WE WE WERE THAT'S
THAT'S OVER TWENTY FIRST OF ALL
OF THE TALKS ARE BEING RECYCLED
SO CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO THAT
USE AND THAT'S A GREAT KEEPS.
AND.
FINALLY SITS ON MAKING A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
IN A STOCKTON.
GENERATING THE OR FIRST FACE
FIFTEEN YOU JOBS GOING UP TO
HUNDRED SHOPS.
BECAUSE IT'S WHY RECYCLER DE
SPILLED HAS.
HE'S IT GIVES SO MUCH ON ON
CERTAINTY HAS IT BEEN BUSTING
INTO RECYCLING JOBS AND
BUSINESSES TO ENCOURAGE MORE
INVESTMENT
TIED RECYCLING.
AND DEPENDENCY TO DECLINE TO DID
TODAY INCENTIVES IT'S IS GOING
TO A WRONG DIRECTION BICU HAVE
STATED IN CHATTANOOGA.
EATING WHAT'S A LOTS OF
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITIES
SO WE DO NOT WANT RECYCLING P.
ALWAYS DB CHANT DEPENDENT TO
TODAY INCENTIVES SO. IRVINE FOR
THESE THREE REASONS OF MY SOUL
PAN OVER NINETY PERCENT OF THE
TIRE RECYCLERS OFF CALIFORNIA
PRODUCE POINT B. OPPOSING.
APPEAL HOWEVER.
I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH AUTHOR TO TO MAKE IT.
PERFECT BILL. THIS IS MY WHOLE
OF HIS STATE.
THIS IS THIS IS ALL PASSIONATE
ABOUT IT BECAUSE THE.
MY NAME IS BRIAN HIRSCH ON THE
OWNER OF NATIONAL BLENNY COMPANY
BASED ON LAFAYETTE.
FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS HAVE
BEEN A CONTRACTOR ASSOCIATE WITH
RUBBERIZED ASPHALT BLENDING.
UP ON A YEARLY BASIS WE'VE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH ENOUGH
RUBBERIZED ASPHALT BLENDING YOU
COULD PAVE ONE LANE OF I. FIVE
ALL THE WAY FROM. A READING TO
LOS ANGELES.
IN THE FIFTEEN YEARS PRIOR TO
THE CONTRACTING.
A I WORK FOR LOCAL AGENCIES WHO
ARE RECIPIENTS OF THE CAL
RECYCLE GRANTS.
UTILIZE RUBBERIZED.
HOUSEHOLD RELATED PRODUCTS IN
THEIR ROADWAYS FUEL FOR FIXING
YOUR LOCAL STREETS.
AND THE BILL DOES NOT GUARANTEE
THAT FUNDING FOR EMBRACE PAYMENT
RELATED PRODUCTS.
WOULD GO.
TO THE CITIES AND THE COUNTIES.
AND WE SEE THE BILL IS HURTING
OF THE PROGRESS THAT THE
RUBBERIZED ASPHALT HAS MAIN
CALIFORNIA WHICH. IS IS MADE
GREAT STRIDES.
ENCLOSING ARE JUST REQUESTING
THAT THE MONEY FOR THE
RUBBERIZED ASPHALT. ACTUALLY GO
TO THE CITY AND COUNTIES.
AND REAFFIRMED THAT WE'RE
OPPOSED TO. THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IS COME FORWARD.
STEVE KRAUSE ON BEHALF OF THE
HOWEVER PAVEMENT ASSOCIATION.
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR LINE MISSPEAK REAL
QUICK. AND WEBER PEYTON
ASSOCIATION IS COMPRISED OF
RUBBER SUPPLIERS AS WELL AS
ASPHALT RUBBER CONTRACTORS.
WE'VE BEEN IN.
EXISTENCE SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE AND WE PROMOTE THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY BUT ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA THE USE OF US ASPHALT
RUBBER. NAM WE.
OPPOSE THIS BILL PRIMARILY AS A
PIPE PERSON JUST INDICATED
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE LANGUAGE
IN THIS BILL. THAT ALLOWS CAO
RECYCLED THE ABILITY TO CSUS
SHIFT.
FUNDS FROM THE ELIGIBLE ENTITY
THE ELIGIBLE ENTITY BEING
POTENTIALLY I WOULD.
SHOULD BE.
PUBLIC COUNTIES.
CITIES.
AND AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT
IT.
HAS ABILITY TO UTILIZE THE
EXISTING GRANT PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM COULD POTENTIALLY STRIP
THOSE COUNTIES.
IN CITIES OF THE RIGHT TO USE
THOSE FUNDS SACRAMENTO COUNTY
JUSTIN LAST.
FOUR YEARS IS USED OVER ONE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
AND. THIRTY MILLION HAS GONE TO
CALIFORNIA.
LOCAL.
CITIES AND COUNTIES FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS AND WE'D HATE TO SEE.
THOSE CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
DESPERATELY NEED THIS MONEY. AND
NOT TO HAVE NOT TO BE AN
ELIGIBLE ENTITY IF THERE'S EVER
CHANGE IN. ADMINISTRATION TO
COVER CYCLE THAT HAS DIFFERENT
IDEAS AND DIFFERENT THOUGHTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BEGAN RPA OPPOSES THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL OF
COURSE MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID WOLFE THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. AND JUST AS WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE AFRASIAB AUSTER
OPPOSED TO THIS ONE AS WELL
THANK YOU.
HI JACK MADONNA FROM BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TIRE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION THE AUTOMOTIVE
SERVICE COUNCILS OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE.
.
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS.
ASSOCIATION OF PRIMARILY BY.
WERE OPPOSED TO THE DOLLAR FEE
WE THINK IT'S GOING TO HURT.
THE.
LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES OUT
THERE BECAUSE IT'S THE A DOLLAR
FEES ON TOP OF THE DOLLAR
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH RESULTS IN. A
NEW SET OF TIRES WILL COST THE
ADDITIONAL ELEVEN DOLLARS IN
FEES WE THINK THAT'S OF. WILL
HURT THE LOW INCOME FOLKS AWARE
OPPOSED TO THAT WERE ALSO WE
FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT THE.
THE TIRE FUND HAS A PARKS ME
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AN
AVERAGE LAST THREE YEARS SO THEY
HAVE PLENTY OF MONEY WE FEEL
LIKE THEY SHOULD SPEND THE MONEY
RESPONSIBLY BEFORE THE ADD
ANOTHER DOLLAR TO CONSUMERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING LIKE AND TIRES FOR
THE LARGEST TIRE PROCESSOR IN
CALIFORNIA. AND AS PREVIOUS SON
SPEAKERS A STATE WHERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
IRAN FLANAGAN A BEHALF OF
INSTITUTE SCRAP RECYCLING
INDUSTRIES ARE IN OPPOSITION AS
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND MENTION
WHERE PARTICULAR CONCERN WITH
THE ASPECT OF THIS BILL THAT.
DISCOURAGES THE AND USE WITH
CRUMB RUBBER FOR INFILL FOR
FIELD TURF.
FOR PLAYGROUND MULCH ARM WOULD
LIKE IT'S IN CONTINUE TO SEE
THIS IS A VIABLE OPTION FOR AND
USE RECYCLED TIRES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT WE'LL OPEN IT TO THE
COMMITTEE I AM LIKE FIRST INVITE
A MISTER BERMAN TO. RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS RAISED.
SURE.
.
MARK JOIN THINK FIRST CRACK
YOUR.
HE ANY ANY CONCERNS IN
PARTICULAR WELL UM I KNOW THAT
WHEN I MET WITH THE WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF C. R. AND.
HE RAISED THE POINT.
WHICH.
RACE TO.
YELLOW FLAG AT LEAST HIM IN MY
MIND ABOUT TO. YOU KNOW HOW THE
STATE HOUSE CAL RECYCLING HAS
BEEN.
SITTING ON A SURPLUS AND AND WE
WERE.
PROPOSE YOUR BILL IS PROPOSING
A NEW FEE.
SPIKE THE SURPLUS EXISTING COULD
YOU EXPLAIN SURE.
AND AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE FIRST
CRACK AND MARK CAN.
GONNA FILL IN THE GAPS SO I I
AGREE COMPLETELY THAT WE
SHOULDN'T. APPLY AN ADDITIONAL
FEE INTO A SURPLUS IS DRAWN DOWN
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES OF THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY STATES WHICH IS
PART OF PRIOR NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE CURRENT OPPOSITION WHO WAS
THEN A SUPPORTER.
OF THE BILL AND AND OTHERS.
THAT WE SHOULD FIRST DRIVE DOWN
TO TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONCE THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS LEVEL IS REACHED THEN
CAL RECYCLE CAN START THE
PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING WITH THE
APPROPRIATE FEE IS. THAT TAKES
ABOUT A YEAR TO DO BECAUSE IT'S
A THOROUGH PUBLIC PROCESS AND
IT'S IMPORTANT KNOW THAT IT'S UP
TO A DOLLAR IT IS NOT A DOLLAR
FEE.
DURING THAT TIME THE HOPE IS
THAT.
THIS PROGRAM.
WILL GENERATE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS HEARING GRANTS
AND SO WHILE WE'RE DETERMINING
WHAT THE FEES SHOULD BE WILL BE
SPENDING THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT ARE IN THE
IN THE FIND. AND THEN AS SOON AS
THE FUND IS FULLY EXHAUSTED IT
THAT IS WHEN THE NEW FEE WILL
KICK IN.
ADD TO HELP PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES FOR THE CONTINUATION
AND I SHOULD ADD STABILITY.
OF THE PROGRAM SO THIS CREATES
STABILITY AND DOES NOT CREATE
INSTABILITY FOR THE PROGRAM SO.
THIS IS IT YOU KNOW.
I'M NEW TO THIS I THIS IS MY
FIRST TIME AUTHOR YOU THE BILL
THE BILL'S.
COME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND
IN PASSED OUT TWICE BEFORE AND A
LOT OF THE DETAILS HAVE BEEN
HASHED OUT DURING THAT TIME. OF
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHY I THINK
THAT WE HAVE A VERY SOLID BILL
TODAY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
JUST WONDERING WITH RESPECT TO
THE MATERIALS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM THIS PROGRAM COULD
YOU EXPLAIN WHY THAT IS THE CASE
SIR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
SO FIRST OFF TIRE DERIVE FUELS
A BURNING TIRES LANDFILL USES AN
EXPORTING TIRES DON'T FURTHER
THE RECYCLING GOALS.
SO THAT'S WHY THOSE NOW USES
ARE EXCLUDED THE DECISION TO
EXCLUDE PLAYGROUND IN TURF
PRODUCTS WITH THE COMPROMISE
THAT WAS REACHED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. OR MY PREDECESSOR RICH
GORDON WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. AND WALTER OF ISN'T
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS NEW INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THE BILL DOES NOT
ELIMINATE THE OTHER EXISTING
GRANT PROGRAMS OR CAL RECYCLES
AUTHORITY. TO DISTRIBUTE GRANTS
UNDER THOSE PROGRAMS
THE THE BILL EVEN PROVIDES OF
THE RECYCLING AND USES THAT ARE
NOT COVERED MAY CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED THROUGH THE GRANT
PROGRAMS. A AND I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT THE SYNTHETIC TURF
GRANTS HAVE NOT BEEN
SIGNIFICANT.
IN IN AND INTEREST HAS DECLINED
DRAMATICALLY AYE IN THOSE TYPES
OF GRANTS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE COUNTER
CYCLE HAS AWARDED TWENTY FIVE
GRANTS TOTAL FOR SYNTHETIC TURF
FIELDS THERE WAS ONLY ONE GRANT
AWARDED IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND NO TURF
FIELD REQUESTS.
MORE SUBMITTED IN THE LAST GRANT
CYCLE.
THEN FINALLY IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT THIS COMPROMISE APPROACH
WAS IN BOTH TRUE AB TWELVE
THIRTY NINE.
BY SOME MEMBER GORDON IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND AB FIVE ON
AYE BY SOME THE NUMBER FRAZIER
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THERE
WAS NO OBJECTION WITH EITHER OF
THIS BILL.
MS EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU THINK YOU INTO MISS
MELINDA TO ASK THE QUESTION I
WANT TO ASK.
AND I THINK YOU ENSURE QUITE
EARLY SO THANK YOU.
BUT AND I MET AT THAT LINK TO
THE OPPOSITION IN IN MY DISTRICT
AND AND.
AND I THINK YOU'RE CORRECT IN
AND AND SAYING. ON THAT YOU
NEGOTIATED YOU TOOK WHAT WAS
THERE AND AND AS I WENT OVER.
DURING OUR MEETING YOU ASKED FOR
EIGHT AMENDMENTS EIGHT
AMENDMENTS WERE MADE AND NOW
YOU'RE ASKING FOR THREE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS. AND I
THINK SOME OF THOSE THINGS HAVE
BEEN ANSWERED WHILE WHERE. I'M
SITTING HERE TODAY AND I ASSUME
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AS WE
GO FORWARD.
BUT AT BUT I THINK I THINK IS
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THE OF THE
ARGUMENT THAT THIS WILL TAKE
MONEY FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AWAY.
.
I'M NOT SURE OF THE VERACITY OF
THAT AS WE HAD LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HERE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A RURAL
AREA I CAN TELL AND GREW UP
UNDER RULE AREA AND HAD
COUNTLESS. PILES OF TIRES DUMPED
ON OUR PROPERTY AND ALL UP AND
DOWN AND I CAN TELL YOU WHEN I
GO TO MY FARM BUREAU MEETINGS US
WHEN THE BIGGEST ISSUES PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT. IS TIRES DUMPED
OUT AND THAT SOME HE'S GOTTA GO
PICK HIM UP.
AND FOR SO FOR THOSE REASONS I
WILL BE SUPPORTING. THE THEM
THAT MOVE THE BILL.
MOTIONS MADE HIS SECOND IT ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
.
SO.
MISTER BERMAN I APPRECIATE TO.
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE ALWAYS
WORKING TOWARD THE PERFECT BUT.
AS WE ALL KNOW IN THIS BUSINESS
WE CAN'T LET.
THE PERFECT GET IN THE WAY THE
GOOD AND SO.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
THE STAKEHOLDERS.
TO WORK TOWARD THAT GOAL.
BUT WITH THAT.
AND WITH THE.
ACCEPTANCE OF THE AMENDMENT.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WE DO LIKE CLOSE NOT JUST
REPORTED THE CONVERSATION AND
AND APPRECIATE.
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT
VIEWPOINTS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER AND THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY RECALL PLEASE.
I AM TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY NINE
OH EIGHT BY MEMBER BERMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
AYE ROUTES RICHIE I ACOSTA.
LOU.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMO.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ.
LENDERS KNOW STONE.
FIVE TWO.
FIVE TO THE OF BILLS ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT.
ALRIGHT NEXT A I SAW MS CARDIO.
WAITING PATIENTLY I BELIEVE
SIGNED AN ORDER AND THEN AFTER
THAT AS MR MATHIS.
NOPE SHE HAS STEPPED OUT AND SO
LOOKS LIKE.
MR MATHIS IS UP.
AND THIS IS AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIRST OFF I'D
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
YOUR HARD WORK WITH MY STAFF ON
THIS BILL.
AND WITH THAT.
ALL LAST FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
BILL.
ALRIGHT.
DO YOU HAVE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF THE
SPELL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE ANTI
REPRESENT AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AYE WE ACTUALLY HAD
A SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
AND I'M REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK WITH YOUR COMMITTEE AND
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE TIME. WE
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WERE CERTAIN SITUATIONS
WHERE WE BELIEVE THAT A SEX WERE
STILL IMPORTANT TO BE CONSIDERED
UNDER SEQUEL BUT WITH ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE TAKEN ON
THE COMMITTEE WILL YOU PLEASE TO
MOVE TO FULL SUPPORT POSITION
THANK YOU.
BOB BREMER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH COVERAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
AND RAIL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF.
MATTHEW HARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
AND FOR THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IN FORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALL JOHNSON
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA WE'RE
STILL KIND OF CHEWING OVER AT
THE AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL AND
WILL BE AUTHORS OFFICE NO REAL
AND I JUST WHEN I THINK ANY
STAFF FOR MAKING THOSE.
WE ARE STILL KIND OF
QUESTIONING THE NEEDS THE BILL.
WITH EXISTING CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS UNDER SEQUEL AND WE
DO HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT ADDING
THE WORD AND.
DILAPIDATED TO THE CODE WITHOUT
DEFINING IT COULD ACTUALLY
INCREASED LITIGATION OUT WITHOUT
ANY RESOLUTION ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
TINA.
ALL RIGHT.
.
MR MATHIS AYE.
HAD A CHANCE TO TALK WITH YOU
SHORTLY BEFORE THE HEARING AND.
I TOLD YOU THAT IT SOUNDS LIKE A
COMMON SENSE BILL.
.
I.
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WHEN I READ
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND SAW
THE OPPOSITION FROM.
THIS YEAR CLUB IN THE LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS SINCE THEN
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE.
LEGAL CONSERVATION VOTERS HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION.
BASED ON YOUR AMENDMENTS.
.
AND SO WITH THAT I WILL BE
RECOMMENDING GOOD THAT WE NEED
TO PASS THIS BILL AS AMENDED.
VALUES LIKE DRUGS.
YOU KNOW A IS WE GET OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS IS WE EN EL THESE
THINGS.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN CLEAN UP EXISTING
NEIGHBORHOODS AND MAKE SURE. HOW
WE CAN GET FOLKS LIVING IN ONLY
AND MEG THIS IS JUST A VERY
SIMPLE MEASURE THAT? HELPS OUT
WITH THAT IN HELPS.
KEEPER COMMUNITIES WHAT CAN
GOOD MOVING FORWARD.
SELF THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT. HATEM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THROW.
I DON'T TWELVE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE BY MEMBER MATHIS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
MEMBERS MATTEUCCI AYE ROUTE TO
GI ACOSTA.
BLOOM.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
FLORA. FLORA KILEY MON.
LIMON NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ BELINDA'S
AYE STONE.
FOUR ZERO.
BILLS ON CALL FORCE HERE MCHUGH.
IS MS CUTTY ABACK NO OKAY.
.
DO NOT HAVE ANY OTHER.
MR MCCARTY.
THIS IS AB NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
ITEM NUMBER THREE.
HI I HAVE A BILL BEFORE US
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT NO
OPPOSITION.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE MEASURE WHICH
FRANKLY ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS TO BETTER
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL CONSERVATION
CORPS WE ALL KNOW. OUR CORE
CREATED BY A GOVERNOR.
AND IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX IS
GREAT PROGRAM GIVING YOUNG
PEOPLE BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY FIVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
LEARN IMPORTANT SKILLS IN THE
AREAS OF. ENVIRONMENTAL
MANAGEMENT.
EMERGENCY SERVICE MANAGEMENT
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND FIRE
SUPPRESSION. HOWEVER
UNFORTUNATELY.
STATE LAW DOES NOT ALLOW OUR
STATE COURT TO CONTRACT DIRECTLY
WITH OUR LOCAL COR FOR THE SAME
PROGRAMS THIS WOULD INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES. AND HELP THESE TWO
PROGRAMS WORK TOGETHER.
HOW WITH ME AS A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE NORTH BAY CONSERVATION
CORPS AS WELL AS THE STATE?
HI MY NAME'S MERRILY OCCURRED
AND I'M THE CEO FROM
CONSERVATION CORPS NORTH BAY.
AND I'M ALSO REPRESENTING THE
FOURTEEN CERTIFIED LOCAL CORES
THAT OUR PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES.
LOCAL COURSE RESPOND TO ALL
KINDS OF EMERGENCIES WE RESPOND
TO FIRE FLOOD EARTHQUAKES.
I IN FACT OF MY CORE
CONSERVATION CORPS NORTH BAY WAS
STARTED THIRTY SIX YEARS AGO IN
RESPONSE TO THE FLOODS OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO.
LAST OCTOBER DEVON'S A
DEVASTATING FIRE STORMS HIT
CINEMA AND NAPA COUNTIES.
NOW THIS WOULDN'T.
* THE THINGS EMERGENCIES LIKE
THIS ARE NORMALLY HANDLED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. BUT BECAUSE THIS
WAS SO.
LARGE.
FIRST I WENT TO THE STATE AND
THEN IT WENT TO THE FEDERAL ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
SO NORMALLY WE WOULD JUST BE
BROUGHT IN BY THE LOCAL COUNTY
AND WE'D BE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS AND LOTS OF TIMES THE CC
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS IS ALSO BROUGHT IN. BUT IN
THIS CASE
THINGS HAPPEN SO QUICKLY THAT
THAT WAS IN THE POSSIBILITY.
SO.
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS DID COME IN IMMEDIATELY TO
HELP.
BEN BUT IF YOU REMEMBER THERE
WERE FIRES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THERE WERE. I MEAN SO MANY FIRES
IN THE STATE AND THE CCC. DIDN'T
HAVE.
I ME NAME THEY REALLY THAN HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO RESPOND
ADEQUATELY TO ALL THE PLACES
THAT NEEDED THEIR HELP. AND THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY HAPPY TO
BRING IN THE LOCAL COURSE TO
HELP AND THAT'S.
BUT WE DID NOT I HAVE A
CONTRACTING MECHANISM.
SO.
THE BOOK LOCAL CHOIRS ARE
QUALIFIED TO DO THIS WORK IN
THIS CASE WE COULD'VE HELPED
WITH.
.
WITH CONTAINING THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE THE ARMY CORPS WAS
REMOVING IT BUT.
YOU NO IT RAINS WERE PREDICTED
AND THERE WAS THE FEAR THAT THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE FROM THE BURNED
HOUSES WOULD GO INTO THE OF. THE
COUNTIES WATERSHED AND IT'S THE
WATERSHED FOR ALL OF CINEMA
COUNTY AND NORTHERN MARIN
COUNTY.
WE CAN ALSO DO EROSION CONTROL
AND.
.
AND ALSO.
WHILE EROSION CONTROLS OF IT
WOULD BE A BIG DEAL AND
CONTAINING THE HAZARDOUS WASTE.
.
BUT NOT ONLY THAT ARE CORPS
MEMBERS OR UPS THAT. THERE THEY
KEPT COMING TO ME AND THEY.
WE'RE SAYING Y. THIS IS OUR
COMMUNITY WHY CAN'T WE HOPE.
AND.
.
IT'S
IT IT WAS HARD TO TELL TO
EXPLAIN TO THEM WHY THEY WEREN'T
BEING ABLE TO HELP IN THIS
SITUATION. AND MANY OF OUR CORE
MEMBERS COME FROM DISADVANTAGED
SITUATIONS THEY HAD DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES IN THEIR LIVES.
AND SOME OF THEM HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN NEGATIVE ACTIVITIES
THEY COME TO US TO CHANGE OUR
LIVES.
MA'AM I CAN ASK YOU TO THREATEN
YEAH NOTHING WOULD HELP CHANGE
IT WOULD CREATE LIFELONG CHAINS
LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE A HERO
FOR YOUR COMMUNITY.
SO I'M A.
I'M ASKING YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM FOR FUTURE
EMERGENCIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
MCCARTY.
CELLS ARE GOOD BELL.
MY RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS
JIKES CLOSE THANK YOU ASK YOUR
I'VE BUILT.
LOCAL PLACE.
SO.
WE.
OKAY. SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
ITEM THREE AB NINETEEN TWENTY A
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA LIKE
ACOSTA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
STONE.
STONE I.
ZERO SIX ZERO BILLS UP.
NEXT WE HAVE A MISS FRIEDMAN
WITH THE TWO BILLS ITEM TWENTY
FOUR AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
FIVE.
AND ITEM TWENTY SIX AB THIRTY TO
THIRTY TWO.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
REQUIRES THE SECRETARY OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO TAKE
ACTION TO ADD ANY CALIFORNIA
RIVER IN THE NATIONAL WILD AND
SCENIC RIVERS SYSTEM. THAT IS
REMOVED DELISTED OR WHOSE
PROTECTIONS OR WEAKENED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE
WILD AND SCENIC RIVERS SYSTEM IF
IT IS NOT ALREADY PART OF THAT
STATE'S SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
DIRECTS THE SECRETARY TO ADD
THAT THE RIVER OR RIVER SECTION
TO THE STATE SYSTEM AFTER
HOLDING A PUBLIC HEARING ABOUT
THE FEDERAL ACTION.
THERE WERE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN MILES OF
FEDERALLY PROTECTED WILD AND
SCENIC RIVERS IN CALIFORNIA
BETTER PRESERVED IN THEIR FREE
FLOWING CONDITION FOR THE
BENEFIT AND ENJOYMENT OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. BETTER NOT ALSO
PROTECTED BY THE STATE SYSTEM.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
APPLIES TO THESE FEDERALLY
PROTECTED RIVERS IF CONGRESS OR
THE COURT ADMINISTRATION WERE TO
PASS LEGISLATION OR ENACT ANY
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
TO ELIMINATE FEDERAL PROTECTION
FROM ALL OUR PORTION OF A RIVER
LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA.
FEDERALLY PROTECTED LANDS THAT
HAVE BEEN SET ASIDE FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER ATTACK LAST YEAR
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCER REVIEW OF TWENTY SEVEN
NATIONAL MONUMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER TO REDUCE THEIR SIZE OR
ELIMINATE THE PROTECTED STATUS
THE LIST INCLUDES THE KARIZ
PLAIN NATIONAL MARIN MONUMENT IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO AND CURRENT
COUNTIES.
INTERIOR SECRETARY ZINC HE
RELEASED A REPORT IN DECEMBER
INCLUDING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLAN TO SHRINK BIG BEERS EARS
AND GRAND STAIRCASE ESCALANTE
NATIONAL MONUMENTS IN UTAH.
ALSO IN CALIFORNIA SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVE HAS CONSIDERED AT
LEAST THREE BILLS TO REMOVE
PROTECTIONS FOR PART OF THE
MERCED WILD RIVER. A FEDERALLY
PROTECTED RIVER TO ALLOW FOR
EXPANSION OF A RESERVOIR.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
WOULD ENSURE THAT FEDERALLY
PROTECTED REVERSING CALIFORNIA
WILL CONTINUE TO BE PROTECTED BY
CALIFORNIA LAW SHOULD THE LOOSER
FEDERAL STATUS.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPONENTS UNPLANNED AB LANGUAGE
REQUIREMENT AS A SECRETARY
CONSIDER THE REASON WHY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REMOVED THE
RIVER FROM THE FEDERAL SYSTEM.
AND THAT THEY ARE AN ADDITION TO
THE STATE SYSTEM WOULD NOT BE
AUTOMATIC BUT UP TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE SECRETARY.
IN FACT THE IDEA FOR MY BILL
CAME FROM SOME SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS OF MY THE LAST YEAR A.
B. NINE SEVENTY FIVE. THAT WOULD
HAVE MADE MINOR IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE STATE WILD AND SCENIC RIVERS
PROGRAM.
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO ANY
RIVERS THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
STUDIED FOR POSSIBLE INCLUSION
IN THE FEDERAL SYSTEM.
ONLY ONCE THE CURRENTLY ARE
LISTED MY OFFICE IS MET WITH
DIFFERENT COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY
WE BOTH BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
WILL NOT IMPACT THE PROPOSED
TEMPERANCE FLAT DAM. FRIEND DOES
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SPIN ADEN TO NINE
SEVEN FIVE IS STEVE EVANS WITH
FRIENDS OF THE RIVER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STEVE
EVANS ON BEHALF I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF FRIENDS OF THE RIVER
WHICH HAS BEEN WORKING TO
PROTECT STREAMS RIVERS AND
WATERSHEDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE.
FRIENDS OF THE RIVER HAS PLAYED
AN INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN THE
STATE AND FEDERAL DESIGNATION OF
EVERY WILD AND SCENIC RIVER IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR.
THE FEDERAL AND STATE WILD AND
SCENIC RIVER SYSTEMS ARE THE
PRIMARY RIVER CONSERVATION TOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA BOTH SYSTEMS
PROTECT THE FREE FLOWING
CHARACTER. AN EXTRAORDINARY OR
OUTSTANDING VALUES OF ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED MILES OF
SELECTED RIVER AND STREAM
SEGMENTS IN THE STATE. THAT'S
ABOUT TWO PERCENT OF THE NINETY
FOUR THOUSAND MILES OF RIVERS
STREAMS IN THE STATE.
THERE ARE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES OF RIVERS AND
STREAMS OF CALIFORNIA THERE
SOLELY PROTECTED THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM.
THIS INCLUDES SOME OF THE MOST
WELL KNOWN WILD AND SCENIC
RIVERS IN THE STATE.
INCLUDING SEGMENTS OF THE
TOILETTE ME IN MERCED RIVER'S
FLOWING FROM YOSEMITE NATIONAL
PARK.
THE KING'S RIVER FLOWING FROM
SEQUOIA KINGS RIVER CANYON
NATIONAL PARK.
THE KERN RIVER IN THE SOUTHERN
SIERRA AND EVEN RELATIVELY SMALL
BUT STILL MAGNIFICENT SAYS WALK
RIVER AND CSP CREEK IN THIS.
CENTRAL COAST REGION.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
PROVIDES A STATE SAFETY NET FOR
THESE EXISTING FEDERAL RIVERS
HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SIGNS IS
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER. OR CONGRESS
PASSES LEGISLATION TO REMOVE
FEDERAL PROTECTION FROM ALL OR
PART OF ANY OF THESE RIVERS WERE
WEAKENS THE PROVISION OF THE
FEDERAL LAW THAT ENSURES. THAT
THESE RIVER RIVERS REMAIN FREE
FLOWING FOR THE ENJOYMENT OF
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE DOES
NOT INCREASE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
RIVERS AND STREAMS PROTECTED IN
THE STATE.
IT'S SIMPLY INSURES THAT THE
STATE PROVIDE A SAFE HAVEN FOR
EXISTING FEDERAL WILD AND SCENIC
RIVERS. IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO LEGISLATION
PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE.
PROVIDING A STATE SAFETY NET IF
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR AND WATER
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND WORKER
SAFETY LAWS AND REGULATIONS WERE
TO BE WEAKENED.
FAR SIGHTED LEGISLATORS
PROTECTED OUR WILD AND SCENIC
RIVERS FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS TO ENJOY. LET'S
ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF THIS
LEGACY BYPASSING AB TWENTY SEP
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE.
FRIENDS OF THE RIVER IN MORE
THAN FORTY OTHER CONSERVATION
RECREATION AND NATIVE AMERICAN
GROUPS. MERGER AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KYLE JOHNSON
CYNICAL CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY FIVE IT'S PRACTICAL
APPROACH TO PREVENT ANY DAMAGE
TO OUR RIVER SYSTEMS THEIR RADIC
BEHAVIORS FROM DC. I'M YOUR
DRIVER TODAY THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON ON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTERS NOT A
WITH THE.
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND WILD AND
SCENIC RIVERS ARE BIG PART OF
OUR RECORD OUTDOOR RECREATION
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE WHICH IS A
NINETY BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
ON THIS IS SMART LEGISLATION
REALLY APPRECIATE IT ANTI AND
SUPPORT.
HELLO SEVERE AFRICA OR THE
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY
OF LIVING RIVERS.
HE COULD A KARATE WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIELLE AND ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S TROUT IN SUPPORT.
AND LISA PARA BEHALF DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT.
AND PAUL MASON WITH THE SUIT FOR
US TRUST ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ALEX BRING WITH FRESHWATER
THIRTY WERE TWEENER BUT WE
APPRECIATE.
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN STAFF ON THIS AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WATCH IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT ANYWAY FOR THE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
CHAIRMAN OTHER MEMBERS POLIO OR
SHUTTER INTO HIM HAVE THE FRESNO
COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISORS I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
COMMENTS AT THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
MADE.
AND ARE OPEN ABOUT TEMPERANCE
FLAT TEMPERANCE FLAT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. AND TO THE
ECONOMY.
AND THE HEALTH. OF A MAJOR SWATH
OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
IT CANNOT BE OBSTRUCTED BY WHAT
IS OTHERWISE A VERY WELL
INTENTIONED BILL I'M SURE AND
SO.
I THINK THIS MAY BE A SITUATION
WHERE BELT AND SUSPENDERS.
ARE IN ORDER IN TERMS THE
LANGUAGE DOWN THE ROAD AND WE
JUST WILL WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR INNER STAFF ON
THAT THANK YOU.
CLIFF MOYAMOYA HERE FOR THE
GLOCK A GROUP ON BEHALF OF KINGS
RIVER CONSERVATION DISTRICT
KINGS IN A RIVER.
SKIRT OF THE.
UNITED WATER CONSERVATION
DISTRICT AND THE KINGS WERE
WATER SOCIALIZATION APPRECIATE
THE.
OPENING COMMENTS ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SET UP WITH
AMENDMENTS TO LOOK AT NOT A DE
FACTO LISTENING PROCESS WE WANT
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR. THE
LOCALS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
INTERACTION NOT ONLY WITH THE
SECRETARY BUT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT REDUCED A
CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE CIRCUMVENTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE BY HAVING IT JUST BE
AN ACTION BY THE SECRETARY. OF
THE CURRENT PROCESS DOES ALLOW
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO DO THE
STATUTORILY SO WORK. HAVE
CONCERNS WITHOUT BUT APPRECIATE
THE WILLINGNESS FOR THE AUTHOR
TO THINK OF THE OTHER OPTIONS
FOR LIST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN JASON
OCCURRED WITH AT HOSTING GILBERT
RESTAURANTS MAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR. THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO MEET WITH US AND
TALK ABOUT OUR CONCERNS. WE HOPE
AND IF THE BILL'S TO MOVE
FORWARD WE HOPE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM. AND
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ALSO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN STAFF AND. WE ARE OPPOSE
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
ECHOING MR MY OMINOUS ASK
COMMENTS EARLIER THINK YOU.
MIKE MILLER THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WHITE GRAPE
GROWERS UP I THINK THE AUTHOR
STAFF WORKING WITH US WE TOWARD
WORKING WITH THEM BUT THE SNOW
BUT WE ARE STILL OPPOSED. HARM
HOPEFUL OF REACHING SOME
RESOLUTION.
BOTH.
ALLEN THERE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE STILL
OPPOSE BUT.
WE ALL LIKE TO BE HOPE NO ANY
ANY FURTHER I WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WE DO NOT HAVE A MUCH.
MOTIONS MADE AND SECONDED.
SOMERS FRIEDMAN.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
.
HI.
SUPPORT THE INTENT OF THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE YOU'RE. A
ANYTHING SIGNIFICANT.
.
RACES CONCERNS.
AND SO.
WE.
.
S. THE.
A NATURIST HORSES COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO BE KEPT IN THE
LOOP IN TERMS OF YOUR ONGOING
EFFORTS ON THIS BILL AND WEEZER
WE RESERVE THE RIGHT TO.
FOR THE BILL A BILL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AFTER A.
REVIEWING CHO.
FURTHER AMENDMENTS BUTTA.
.
AT THIS TIME THE.
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WHICH LIKE CLUBS.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR THE
LAST YEAR WITH THE OPPONENTS AND
AS HE SAID WE'RE GETTING CLOSER
AND CLOSER WE'RE PRETTY
CONFIDENT THAT. WE'LL BE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH LANGUAGE THAT WILL
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
ALRIGHT.
I BROKE UP IF I DON'T TRY FOR A
BETWEEN ANTHONY FIVE BY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
OR EFFORT APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
AYE MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA NO
ACOSTA NO BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMO.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
STONE.
SO I.
THREE TO NO FOUR TWO FOUR TWO
THE BILL'S UNCLE.
NEXT ITEM IS AB THIRTY TO THIRTY
TWO.
THANK YOU CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I LIKED TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FIVE THE OF THE ANALYSIS AS AN
AUTHORS AMENDMENT. A. B. THIRTY
TO THIRTY TWO REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
BUILDINGS IN LINE WITH OUR
STATES CLIMATE GOALS.
UNLIKE ELECTRICITY GENERATION
THERE ARE NO COMPREHENSIVE STATE
GOALS AIMED AT REDUCING THE
CARBON EMISSIONS FROM THE USE OF
FOSSIL FUELS IN NEW ARE FROM THE
MORE THAN THIRTEEN MILLION
EXISTING RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA.
DIRECT EMISSIONS FROM FOSSIL
FUEL USE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
BUILDINGS ARE ON PAR WITH
EMISSIONS FROM ALL IN STATE
POWER PLANTS.
MANY ESTIMATES SHOW THAT. OUR
BUILDINGS ADMIT ARE PROBABLY THE
THIRD LARGEST I'M EMITTER OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS OUR LOOK ELECTRICS
ELECTRICITY SUPPLY GETS CLEANER
THESE DIRECT EMISSIONS FROM THE
USE OF FOSSIL FUELS AND
BUILDINGS WILL BECOME ONE OF THE
TOP BARRIERS TO ACHIEVING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS.
SPECIFICALLY A. B. THIRTY TO
THIRTY TWO REQUIRES THE CDC TO
DEVELOP A PLAN BY TWENTY TWENTY
ON HOW TO ACHIEVE THE GOAL OF
NEW BUILDINGS BEING ZERO MISSION
BUILDINGS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
DEVELOPED A SECOND PLAN ON HOW
WE CAN GET A FIFTY PERCENT
REDUCTION IN THE EMISSIONS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES FROM THE SEATS
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK.
REPORTING FUTURE INTEGRATED
ENERGY POLICY REPORT SOME
PROGRESS TOWARDS BOTH SCHOOLS
ABOVE AND OPEN A PROCEEDING ON
ELECTRICAL LOAD MANAGEMENT TO
OPTIMIZE BUILDING USE AND
DECREASE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
I REALIZE THAT SOME PEOPLE OF
CONCERNED WITH A. B. THIRTY TWO
THIRTY TWO AND SEE THIS IS A
MANDATE FOR ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
ELECTRIFICATION OF BUILDINGS FOR
TWENTY THIRTY. THAT IS NOT OUR
INTENT.
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPONENTS ON LANGUAGE THAT
INCLUDES THE CONSIDERATION OF
MULTIPLE OPTIONS SUCH AS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY ELECTRICITY IN
RENEWABLE GAS STORAGE AND IS
SOLELY FOCUSED ON THE LEAST COST
STRATEGIES TO DE CARBONIZATION.
I'M ALSO WILLING TO REQUIRE THE
STUDIES OF THE GOALS TO CONSIDER
THE IMPACTS ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PYRITES INDUSTRIAL
BUILDINGS IN AGRICULTURE.
FURTHERMORE LANGUAGE WILL BE
ADDED TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE
CDC WOULD NOT BE SETTING RATES
FOR ANY POWER PROVIDER.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TO THIRTY
TWO IS PURE TO FORGE WITH AN RTC
CHARLIE CONWAY FROM EFFICIENCY
FIRST CALIFORNIA AND DOCTOR
ROBERT GOULD FROM PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY. THAT SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA CHAPTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
JOHN MEMBERS MY NAME IS GERALD
FORD WITH THE NATIONAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL. AND ALL THE
SEASON STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO.
THE BILLING SECTORS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
STATE'S CLIMATE EMISSIONS AND
SPACE HEATING AND WATER HEATING
OF THE TOP TWO EMISSIONS SOURCES
IN MOST BUILDINGS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE A RANGE
OF TECHNOLOGY IN EXISTENCE
TODAY.
THAT CAN CUT THOSE HEATING
EMISSIONS BY HALF OR MORE.
HOWEVER THE LACK OF POLICY GOALS
HAS LIMITED THE MARKET
DEVELOPMENT
OF KEEN HEATING SOLUTIONS MANY
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THEM. DISTRIBUTORS
OFTENTIMES TALK THEM.
SETTING LONG TERM GOALS IS KEY
TO DRIVE THE NECESSARY POLICY
PLANNING THAT'S NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE IS THAT THESE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER EVERYTHING
THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING AND
WOULD BENEFIT THE BUILDING
SECTOR FROM EFFICIENCY CAN
ELECTRICITY STORY FOR NOBLE GAS.
FIFTY PERCENT REDUCTION BY
TWENTY THIRTIES VERY REASONABLE
THE MEN GAP IS THE EMISSIONS
FROM SPACE HEATING AND WATER
HEATING.
GOAL SETTING HAS A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD FOR CUNANAN JIM
CALIFORNIA WHEN THE STATE SET
IT'S FIFTY PERCENT RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY GOAL IS SEEMED
AMBITIOUS.
BUT JUST A FEW YEARS LATER WE ON
TRACK TO ACHIEVING IT TEN YEARS
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
SO INDUSTRY NOW PROVIDES MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND JOB IN
CALIFORNIA SO THE COSTS HAVE
COME DOWN DRAMATICALLY THIS IS
EXACTLY THE OPTIONS YOU WHEN YOU
CHEN LOCK FOR CLEAN HEATING AND
BUILDINGS.
LET ME ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR
POSITIONS ARGUMENTS.
FIRST OF THIS IN THE NEXT
RESTRICT EQUIVOCATION MANDATE.
THIS IS NOT SUPPORTED BY FACTS
AND BY THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
NOTHING IN THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO
FAVORS ELECTRIFICATION. THE
BILL'S TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND
PERFORMANCE BASED
RENEWABLE GAS CAN COMPETE WITH
ELECTRIFICATION ON ITS MERITS
THE BILL DOESN'T PICK A WINNER
IN FACT WE WILL NEED AND ALL OF
THE ABOVE STRATEGY.
ANOTHER CLAIM IS THAT THIS BILL
WOULD REDUCE QUICK CUSTOMER
CHOICE THIS IS IRONIC.
CUSTOMERS DON'T COME WE HAVE A
REAL CHOICE WILL CLEANER AND
MORE AFFORDABLE HEATING OPTIONS.
GAS IS USING EIGHTY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA BUILDINGS IT'S A DE
FACTO MONOPOLY SITUATION.
AND THE MARKET FOR KEY NO TURN
DAVIS IS UNDER DEVELOPED.
THIS BILL WOULD SPUR INVESTMENT
INNOVATION AND MAKE IT
ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE.
LAST
WE HEAR CLAIMS THAT CLEAN
ELECTRIC HEATING WOULD INCREASED
CUSTOMER BILLS.
BIG DATA OUTDATED PERCEPTION
THAT ELECTRIC HEATING IS MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN GAS HEATING.
BUT THIS IS NO LONGER THE CASE
THIS WHAT THE CASE ONE VICTORY
RESISTANCE HEATING WAS USED NOW
WITH MODERN ELECTRIC HEATING
BASE AND HE PUMP TECHNOLOGY.
WHICH IS FIVE TO SIX TIMES AS
EFFICIENT AT BEST COMPRESSION
TECHNOLOGIES.
ELECTRIC HEATING IS ACTUALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE CUSTOM
BILLS
THAT IS CURRENTLY ONLY
ACCEPTABLE TO WESTERN
CALIFORNIANS AND THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
ENCOURAGING TO WRAP.
AB THIRTY FIFTH THIRTY TO THIRTY
TWO WOULD CUT CALIFORNIA WOULD
PUT CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TO
CLEANER HEALTHIER AND MORE
AFFORDABLE BUILDINGS. WE
HONESTLY I FELT
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A DOCTOR
ROBERT GOULD AND I'M UP HERE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY CISCO BAY AREA CHAPTER.
OF PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF WHICH I'M A
PRESIDENT. AND ALSO ON OUR
NATIONAL BOARD AND IN THIS
CAPACITY I'M REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF PHYSICIANS AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
SUPPORTING MEASURES SUCH AS A.
B. THIRTY TWO THIRTY TWO AIMED
AT ACHIEVING MAJOR REDUCTIONS IN
EMISSIONS FROM FOSSIL FUELS THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR GLOBAL
WARMING RELATED AIR POLLUTION.
AND THE MANIFOLD OF ASSOCIATED
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CONTINUED USE OF SUCH ENERGY
SOURCES.
WE KNOW THAT THE BUILDING SECTOR
CONTRIBUTES ABOUT A QUARTER OF
THE STATE'S CLIMATE EMISSIONS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE VOTING A
CONCRETE PLAN TO THE CARBON EYES
ARE BUILDING SECTORS AS
ENVISIONED BY A. B. THIRTY TO
THIRTY TWO. IS VERY SOUND PUBLIC
POLICY AND THROUGH SUCH A PLAN
WE COULD ACHIEVE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS IN EMISSIONS OF
NATURAL GAS THAT CONTRIBUTES
BOTH INDOOR AND OUTDOOR
POLLUTION.
WHICH I HAVE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
IMPACT PARTICULARLY AMONG OUR
MOST CHALLENGE COMMUNITIES
RECOGNIZING THAT MODERN
ELECTROCUTING COULD POTENTIALLY
CUT CO TWO EMISSIONS AND HALF
COMPARE WITH THE BEST GAS
COMBUSTION. HEATING SYSTEMS AND
IT EMISSIONS CAN DROP EVEN
FURTHER AS OUR GRID CONTINUE
SICK.
GET CLEANER WE BELIEVE THAT A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO LECTURE FIRE
BUILDING SECTOR CAN PROVIDE
ENORMOUS BENEFITS TOWARDS
MITIGATING THE UNFOLDING IMPACTS
OF GLOBAL WARMING. IN THIS
CONTEXT I BELIEVE THAT BILL
THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO REPRESENTS
AN IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO
REDUCE CLIMATE AND AIR POLLUTION
IN. CALIFORNIA AS IT AIMS TO
REDUCE THE EMISSIONS FROM FOSSIL
FUELS.
WE BOTH BELIEVE THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE
CLIMATE AND AIR POLLUTION ON
BEHALF OF THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WHO BROUGH SOME OF
THE MOST POLLUTD AIR IN THE
NATION WERE INCREASINGLY
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRES AND OTHER
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS?
I STRONGLY URGE YOU ALL AYE VOTE
IN AB THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DENISE
DEVILLE I AM WITH E. HDD
ARCHITECTS.
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING AN
INFORMAL GROUP OF ARCHITECTS AND
ENGINEERS IN THE COMMERCIAL AND
INSTITUTIONAL BUILT ENVIRONMENT.
WHO ARE ALREADY DOING THIS
AND WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT?
THIS THIS BILL TODAY.
.
WHERE A GROUP OF ARCHITECTS AND
ENGINEERS WHO ARE COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
WE'RE DOING THAT BY ELIMINATING
EMISSIONS AND BUILDINGS?
OUR BUILDINGS USE.
EMIT THE MOST THROUGH HEATING
UP THE SPACE AND WATER.
.
ARE FIRM IN PARTICULAR HAS BUILT
IN DESIGN DOZENS OF ZERO
EMISSION BUILDINGS AND THEY WORK
BEAUTIFULLY AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER THE PAST HALF A DOZEN YEARS
OR SO. IS GREAT IN THAT
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY SO
IT'S MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO
DO THESE BUILDINGS NOW IF YOU
START OUT WITH THAT DESIGN IN
MIND AT THE VERY BEGINNING. AND
A COMMITMENT TO REACH
ZERO EMISSIONS.
.
WE'VE DONE THIS FOR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES
OFFICE BUILDINGS AND A BIG FAN
FAVORITE AT THE EXPLORATORIUM
MIND PURE FIFTEEN.
SO WE KNOW IT CAN BE DONE.
OUR EMPHASIS IS IS REALLY IN
HELPING THIS INDUSTRY REALLY GET
BETTER AT IT WHAT WE SEEN AND
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES IN
COMPONENTS IN EQUIPMENT. IS THAT
YOU CAN BUY OFF THE SHELF NOW
MANUFACTURERS ARE COMING A LONG
WAY AND WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THEM. SO THEY'RE A CHEETAH
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE.
WITH THIS WE'VE ALSO SEEN.
AND WE KNOW FROM OUR GENERAL
CONTRACTORS
THAT IT'S NO LONGER MORE
EXPENSIVE TO DO THIS.
MANY TIMES.
WE'VE HEARD THAT IT IS THERE'S
A PREMIUM TO PAY BUT WERE
ACTUALLY SEEING IN FACT ON ONE
OF OUR UC SAN DIEGO PROJECTS
THERE'S GONNA BE AT ONE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLAR SAVINGS. BY
GOING THIS ROUTE BECAUSE IT IS
SO SENSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE RIGHT
NOW.
SO.
FOR THAT.
I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THING RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF FURTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NAME. AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION.
I MY NAME IS CHARLES CORPS MANY
I REPRESENT AND OF.
THEN EFFICIENCY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'M A EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HIS SINCE THE FIRST.
WHICH IS A TRADE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING CONTRACTORS IN THE
STATE. OF KEEP IT BRIEF I WANNA
SAY THAT WERE IN FAVOR THIS
BILL.
AND THAT THE GOALS OF ENERGY
REDUCTIONS EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
GOALS IN THIS BILL THIS BILL ARE
ACHIEVABLE. ACT BE DONE AT LOWER
NO COST COMPARED TO OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES EXIST TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL BEAR WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL THE REASONS SPOKEN BY DR.
GOULD'S AB ONE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
KYLE JONES IS HERE OF
CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT THANK
YOU.
TIFFANY FAN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL.
ERICA MARTINEZ SOME HALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TINA GALLIERA WITH POSSIBLE FREE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JUDY POPE THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
STRONG SUPPORT.
NOT SINCLAIR UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA OFFICE THE
PRESIDENT WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BILL
BUT IT IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
CARBON NEUTRALITY INITIATIVE.
GOAL FOR ALL UC CAMPUSES TO BE
CARBON NEUTRAL BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SINGING NUN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RIGHT
TUCCI AND MEMBERS NEED QUIRK
COALITION FOR AN OVER AFRICA
ASSN ACTUALLY HERE AS THAT
WIENER. AYE WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMENTS ON.
HER INTENT TO INCLUDE RENEWABLE
GAS IN THE BILL AYE BUT I'D
PROBABLY BE DOING MY MEMBERS AT
THIS SERVICE BY NOT COMMENTING
ON THE BILL AND PRINT. OUT WE
AGREE WITH AND APPRECIATE THE
INTENT LANGUAGE MAYBE THIRTY TO
THIRTY TWO. UP PAGE THREE LINE
SEVENTEEN THAT THE CARBON ISING
CALIFORNIA'S BUILDINGS IS
ESSENTIAL SERIES RICK TO ACHIEVE
THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS. AT THE
LOWEST POSSIBLE COST HOWEVER THE
POLICY IN THIS BILL IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THAT AND HAVE LANGUAGE
DOES EXACTLY THE. OPPOSITE UP TO
GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT CARBS
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN
IDENTIFIES THREE POTENTIAL
PATHWAYS TO BUILDING DE
CARBONIZATION. THOSE THREE
PATHWAYS ARE RENEWABLE GAS
SOLAR THERMAL AND
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE THREE IS
THE ONLY ONE THAT CARD CAUTIONS.
THAT COULD ACTUALLY CAUSE AN
INCREASE IN EMISSIONS IS
ELECTRIFICATION.
FURTHERMORE THIS STRATEGY HAS A
HIGH PURCHASE COST WITH HIGH
INSTALLATION COSTS HIGHER LONG
TERM OPERATING COSTS AND ALSO
CREATES MASSIVE NEW ELECTRICAL
DEMAND.
THE FORTHCOMING STUDY THAT WILL
BE CIRCULATED YOUR OFFICES FINDS
THAT THERE IS NO NEED TO
ELECTRIFY THE BUILDING SECTOR IN
ORDER TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. AND THAT REPLACING A
MERE SIXTEEN PERCENT OF GAS
SUPPLY WITH RENEWABLE GAS FROM
WAY STRINGS BY TWENTY THIRTY
WOULD ACHIEVE THE SAME OUTCOME
AT LESS COST THAN ELECTRIFYING
THE ENTIRE BUILDING SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
AT THE SAME TIME THIS WOULD
PROVIDE FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE
STATE'S FOR LIVE CLIMATE PRUDENT
PLAN WHICH IS A CRITICAL NEW
PART OF THE STATE'S CLIMATE
STRATEGY. THE PLAN REQUIRES US
TO CAPTURE FORTY PERCENT OF
METHANE FROM CALIFORNIA'S WASTE
STREAMS FROM SEWAGE TREATMENT
LANDFILLS AND AREAS. THE CAPTURE
OF THESE POLLUTANTS REPRESENT
THIRTY PERCENT OF ALL THE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS REQUIRED IN
THE SCOPING PLAN TO REACH OUR
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS.
SO AGAIN I WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE AS YOU MOVE FORWARD ON
YOUR BUILDING HE CARBONIZATION
POLICY TO REALLY CONSIDER THE
OPTION OF USING OUR NOBLE GAS.
AND WHETHER ELECTRIFICATION IS A
WELL THOUGHT OUT STRATEGY AT A
MINIMUM MOVING FORWARD WE ASK
THAT THIS BILL BE AMENDED TO
ENSURE. THAT THE MANDATE WILL
NOT UNINTENTIONALLY INCREASED
LIFECYCLE EMISSIONS AND ALSO
CONSIDER THE OPTION DE
CARBONIZATION THROUGH THE USE OF
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AS A CO
EQUAL STRATEGY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ON BOB BREMER SENIOR ENGINEER
WITH THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THE SEAT YOU SEE IN THE P.
YOU SEE ESTABLISH A POLICY GOAL
OF HAVING ALL NEW RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS ZERO NET ENERGY BY
TWENTY TWENTY AND ON THE
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS ANY BY
TWENTY THIRTY.
IN JUST TEN YEARS AGO IN THIS
PROCESS AB THIRTY TO THIRTY TO
WOULDSIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THIS
POLICY.
AB THIRTY TO THIRTY TWO WOULD
GIVE THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION JUST TWELVE MONTHS TO
DEVELOP A PLAN THAT WOULD
REQUIRE ALL NEW RESIDENTIAL AND
NON RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS. TO BE
ZERO EMISSION BUILDING STARTING
JANUARY TWENTY THIRTY THE CDC
WOULD ALSO BE GIVEN TWELVE
MONTHS TO ESTABLISH A POLICY
INTRODUCED BY FIFTY PERCENT THE
GHG EMISSIONS. FROM THE EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL AND NON RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING STOCK.
REGARDING THE CDC'S ENERGY
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES A CC TO ADOPT
WHATEVER POLICY CHANGES ARE
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE ALL THESE
GOALS BY TWENTY THIRTY. THIS
BILL WAS EFFECTIVELY DIRECTING
THE C. TEASED IS SUBSTANTIALLY
DREW'S OR PERHAPS ELIMINATE
NATURAL GAS USE IN NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED NATURAL GAS USE. IN VAST
EXISTING BUILDING STOCK.
THE FACT IS THE CDC IS ALREADY
TAKING MAJOR STEPS TO ACHIEVE
THE EXISTING Z. ANY POLICY GOAL.
THE CDC IS ALREADY ADOPTED HUGE
INCREASES IN STRINGENCY THEIR
ENERGY RAGS WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALL THREE OF
THESE WERE HISTORICALLY LARGE
INCREASES IN STRINGENCY.
WITHIN THE NEXT SIXTY DAYS THE
CDC WILL BE ADOPTING THE
NATION'S FIRST STATEWIDE MANDATE
FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR ON ALL NEW
HOMES AND APARTMENTS.
THIS QUANTUM LEAP IN BUILDING
STANDARDS WILL TAKE EFFECT IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY.
THE CDC IS DONE ALL THIS IN A
COLLABORATIVE MANNER IN HIS GAIN
THE SUPPORT OF BOTH INDUSTRY AND
THE ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY.
BUT THIS QUANTUM LEAP AND
BILLING STANDARDS NOT WITHOUT
CONTROVERSY YOUR CONCERN
STARTING IN TWENTY TWENTY WEEKS
WE WILL SIGNIFICANTLY SEE AN
INCREASING AMOUNT OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOING OUT INTO THE GRID
DURING THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY.
PRECISELY WHEN THE GRID DOES NOT
NEED IT OR CAN STORE IT TURNS
OUT THE GRID IS A VERY POOR
BATTERY.
AT THE SAME TIME ALL THIS IS
HAPPENING CALIFORNIA WILL SEE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON
THE ROAD. MOST ASKING TO WRAP OF
SIR.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS THE CDC
TO BASICALLY LOOK INTO THE GRID
RELIABILITY ISSUES AND THE GREAT
PROTECTIVE ISSUES ARE THAT THIS
IS GOING TO CREATE? A WE'RE
ADDING THIS ON TOP OF THE HUGE
INFLUX OF SOLAR ENERGY AND EVEY
CHARGING.
IN IN SIMPLE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T BREAK THE GRIP.
AND WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS FIND
OUT IF ALL THESE ISSUES CAN BE
ADDRESSED BEFORE WE ESTABLISH IN
THE STATE STATUTE THIS POLICY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR SHARE MEMBERS
DAWN KEPT KEY MCCUE KEPT UNISYS
IT'S A MAP THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. I CMT'S CONCERNS
JUST TO BE VERY BRIEF FOREVER
LATER TO AND THE FACT THAT SOME
INDUSTRIAL REPAIRS DO NOT HAVE
AN ELECTRIC EQUIVALENT
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE. THAT
ENABLES THEM TO MEET BUSINESS
NEEDS A CUSTOMER'S DEMANDS AND
IT IS UNCLEAR FROM THIS BILL
LANGUAGE HOW BROAD THE
APPLICATION WOULD BE. OF FURTHER
OUR CONCERN THAT CALIFORNIAN
DUST RA RATEPAYERS ALREADY PAY A
HEAVY PREMIUM OF ABOUT NINETY
FIVE PERCENT ABOVE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. SO THE CONCERN BEING
THAT INCREASING COST PRESSURES
WILL ADD TO THAT BURDEN AND MAKE
OUR STATE LESS COMPETITIVE
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES FROM
MANUFACTURING STANDPOINT. A SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON UNLESS I'M ON
BEHALF THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION ALSO AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION WPGA SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA AND ITS EFFORTS TO
REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS INCLUDING
FROM THE BUILDING SECTOR.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT
ESTABLISHING PRESCRIPTIVE
MEASURES THAT ELIMINATE CUSTOMER
CHOICE CREATE TECHNOLOGY
MANDATES AND INCREASE OUR
CUSTOMERS OUT OF LIVING AND.
COST OF LIVING AND COST OF DOING
BUSINESS ARE SHORT SIGHTED AND
UNNECESSARY.
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION MUST BE
CONSIDERED ALONG WITH OTHER
POTENTIAL GHG REDUCTION
ALTERNATIVES TO ENSURE THAT THE
AGGRESSIVE STATE CLIMATE GOALS
ARE ACHIEVED. BY INSTITUTING A
SINGLE ENERGY SOURCE MANDATE
FAILED TO RECOGNIZE THE GHG
BENEFITS OFFERED BY PROPANE.
TODAY'S PROPANE IS ONE OF THE
BEST JUDGES FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ACHIEVE ITS SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTION GOALS AND YET SHE
KNOCKS AND SOCKS REDUCTION
GOALS.
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AREAS OF
THE STATE. FURTHER JUST AS
ELECTRICITY IS EXPECTED TO BE A
CLEANER SOURCE IN THE FUTURE IT
SHOULD BE UNDERSTOOD THE PROPANE
THROUGH CONTINUAL TECHNOLOGY
INFILL PRODUCTION ADVANCEMENTS.
WILL CONTINUE ITS TRAJECTORY IN
PROVIDING COMPETITIVE CLEAN
ENERGY SOLUTIONS FOR DECADES TO
COME.
FURTHER WERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ENERGY COST TO
CUSTOMERS
PROPANE PROVIDES ENERGY USED FOR
HOME HEATING AND COOKING TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS. WPGA IS
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF OUR
HISTORY AND SERVING LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS A ONE
ENERGY SOURCE SOLUTION WOULD
INTRODUCE AN UNDUE FINANCIAL
BURDEN TO THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION. FOR GHG TARGET
ENERGY SOLUTION DIVERSITY ALONG
WITH THE OTHER REASONS STATED.
BY OUR FELLOW UP FELLOW
STAKEHOLDERS NOT POSITION WE
MUST OPPOSE AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY
TWO AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR NO VOTE THIS TIME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS.
TO NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM CARMICHAEL
REPRESENTING SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY AND SENATOR GAS
ELECTRIC. IN OPPOSITION WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S CHO
OPENING COMMENTS.
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT THANK YOU.
PATRICK WELL TO THE MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION WE HAVE NO
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT ONE I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR RESOLVING
AN INITIAL CONCERN ABOUT. AND.
DUPLICATIVE GHG.
ACCOUNTING THAT WERE IN THE
PREVIOUS VERSION THE BILL WE DO
HAVE SOME INITIAL CONCERNS
ABOUT.
THE NEW LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
ABOUT CC OVER CYPRUS HIT THE
COMMENTS TODAY WE LOOK FOR TO
WORK WITH AUTHOR MOVING FORWARD.
AT A RALLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE O. WERE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
TO THE USE OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEAN LUIS WITH THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ACROSS THE STATE ALSO
OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ON THE FLOOR
IT'S WITH THE VALLEY INCHING
CONGRESO FEES AND WE
RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSE THIS BILL ALTHOUGH WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND MITIGATING
COST TO CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
AND RESIDENTS THANK YOU.
MATTHEW HELLO THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VALERIE TRAIL OF LAJOS
WITH PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY. TESTIFYING TODAY AS A
TWEENER WITHOUT AN OFFICIAL
POSITION BUT I JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEGIN A DIALOGUE WITH
THE AUTHOR TO EXPRESSSOME OF
THE CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION
HAS EXPRESSED TODAY THANK YOU.
DAVE SHRIVER AMERICAN PUBLIC GAS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
HI MY NAME'S ALEX DOWN WITH MASS
ENERGY WORKS FOR THE.
LARGEST DEVELOPER OF.
DAIRY DIGEST VERSION THE
STATEMENT LIKE TO STAND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
WHICH CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON P. ANTHONY THOMAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. AND TAKE EXCEPTION WITH
THE COMMENT ABOUT CNETRIC AS
BEING A DEFECTIVE MORE.
MONOPOLY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ALRIGHT.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS EGGMAN THEM AS MELENDEZ.
I THINK YOU.
.
AND WE JUST MET BRIEFLY.
THIS MORNING AND I EXPRESSED.
SOME CONCERNS SO THE.
HOUSING RESIDENTIAL AND AND NON
RESIDENTIAL STE COMPRISE NINE
PERCENT.
OF THE JG AS A.
DIRECTOR MISSIONS NINE PERCENT.
FROM.
IN.
AND HAVE BEEN BETTER WHAT IS
WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THE MANDATE
RIGHT NOW TO TRY TO REDUCE IT
TO.
RIGHT NOW.
ITEM OF THE
THAT THERE IS A MANDATE WAS NO
MANDATE NO MEANT NOTHING TO THIS
WOULD BE THAT THIS TO BE THE
FIRST WELL THINGS TO BE CLEAR
THIS IS NOT A MANDATE THIS IS
THE PLAN. THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE.
WILL BE DEVELOPING PLANS
CORRECT SO THAT OVER TIME WE
COULD MEET THOSE GOALS CORRECT
BUT AS I READ THERE'S. IT'S IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S ALSO PLAN
IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE AS PLAN
AND THEN DIRECTION BASED ON PLAN
CORRECT.
WELL I MEAN ULTIMATELY THEY
WOULD IMPLEMENT THE PLANS.
BUT WE'RE NOT IMPLEMENTING ANY
PLANS IN THIS PARTICULAR PIECE
OF LEGISLATION.
PROVIDES A STANDARDS OPTED FOR
ELECT WILL LOAD MANAGEMENT
FREEZE UTILITY AND TO ENSURE SO
I THOUGHT I'D SAY THEY WOULD
LIKE WE WILL.
YEAH EVENTUALLY LIKE YOU WELL
OKAY WHAT BUT IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ALL PART OF THE SAME BILL.
WELL THIS BILL DOESN'T SAY WHAT
THE PLAN IS
NO I JUST HAS WHATEVER PLAN THAT
YOU COME UP WITH WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED.
RIGHT A PLAN WILL EVENTUALLY BE
IMPLEMENTED
OKAY.
BASED BASED ON THIS RIGHT TO
DISEASE NOT ACTIVITIES DOESN'T
COME BACK TO US AGAIN.
MY QUESTION.
RIGHT OKAY RIGHT WE JUST FELT
LIKE THEY DEVELOP THE PLAN AND
THEN THE IMPLEMENTED WITHOUT
COMING BACK TO THE BODY.
THAT'S CORRECT ASSEMBLY LANGUAGE
THINK.
ON.
SO CAN I HAVE I HAVE CONCERNS I
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT.
AND.
AND I'M ALSO SOMEBODY WHO HAS.
A PIECE OF PROPERTY THAT USE
PROPANE BUT WE ARE WAY OFF THE
GRID WE HAVE SOLAR THAT WORKS
WHEN IT'S AND CHENEY AND AT THE
TIME SO IT DOESN'T. A AND AND WE
USE PROPANE FOR FOR HEATING AND
COOKING. AND SO THAT IS A
CONCERN THAT.
ANOTHER CONCERN JUST AS I AM AND
WHY I HAVE MULTIPLE CONCERNED
BUT THAT ANOTHER ONE IS.
IN THE CITY OF STOCKTON WHERE
WE'VE TALKED A LOT IN THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS. AND WE HAVE A
BEGIN BUILDING HOUSING STOCK
CONSTRUCTING IT AGAIN RIGHT SO
WHILE. AND WE THERE WE THERE'S A
PENCIL OUT AT THIS
TIME AND SO WHEN WE CONTINUE TO
ADD MORE ONEROUS AND. STANDARDS
MAKES ME VERY NERVOUS THAT IT
WILL TAKE HOUSING
TYPE OF
REPEATING WOULD BE
YES AGAIN THIS IS NOT A BILL
ABOUT PURE ELECTRIFICATION. WE
FULLY EXPECT THAT RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS WILL BE RESPECTED IN
THESE PLANS AND WE UNDERSTAND IT
THEY'RE IMPORTANT PART OF
COMBATING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND GREAT MANAGEMENT WAS ALSO
BROUGHT UP AND THAT'S
SPECIFICALLY ALSO CALLED OUT A
IN THE BILL THAT WE WILL. I'M
INSTRUCTED GRID MANAGEMENT BE
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT BECAUSE
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT PARTOF
IT'S EMISSIONS IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE EMISSIONS FROM THE
ELECTRICITY USE FOR HEATING
WHICH IS ALSO. PART OF THE MIX
IN CALIFORNIA SO THE TOTAL
EMISSIONS FROM. JUST HEATING HOT
WATER AND SPACE ARE AT LEAST A
FIFTEEN PERCENT OFF A HIGHER.
AND FOLLOW THE STATE NATURAL GAS
IT'S ACTUALLY CHEAPER TO BUILD A
SINGLE FUEL HOME THAT A DOUBLE
KNIT YOU'LL SHOW HOME YOU SAVE
MONEY AND APPLIANCES YOU SAVE
MONEY OF PLUMBING UP CONNECTION
COST. DOESN'T MEAN THAT HAS TO
BE THAT WAY BUT UNLOCKING THE
SIZE OF ONE OPTION IS ACTUALLY
GONNA HELP MAKE BUILDING NEW
BUILDINGS MORE AFFORDABLE.
AND THE LAST POINT I WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT ON SOME GREATER
RELIABILITY WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF THE BE AYE A ON
CREDIBILITY FAIRLY MINOR.
AND NEW LOAD COMPARED TO
ATTRITIONAL VEHICLES AND AND
SORA SO IT'S NOT YOU KNOW I WE
DON'T THINK THERE'S AND MAJOR
ISSUE HERE THINGS SORTED BEEN
LOOKED AT AND THE AGENCIES WOULD
HAVE PROCESSES. LIKE OF THE
FIFTY%
THREE WHICH WOULD.
I CHALLENGE ANYBODY TO SHOW ME A
CURRENT ELECTRIC STOVE WITH FULL
ELECTRIC COMPONENTS THAT IS
GOING TO LAST ME THAT LONG.
THE WASTE THAT WE GENERATE FROM
NEW TECHNOLOGY CONTINUE TO COME
MAN AND THAT WE GET A NEW ONE
WOULD MAKE NEW MANDATES. IS
GOING TO OVERWHELM THIS PLANET
POTENTIALLY FASTER THAN SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE WORK ON.
AGREED FOCUSED ON PROVIDING
AFFORDABLE NATURAL GAS RELIABLY
TO THEIR SCHOOLS HOSPITALS
BUSINESSES.
NATURAL GAS CALIFORNIA IS
DELIVERED TO CONSUMERS ON A FULL
FUEL CYCLE BASIS WITH THREE
TIMES THE EFFICIENCY OF
ELECTRICITY AND ONE THIRD THE
COST.
THE AVERAGE ALL ELECTRIC HOME
BECAUSE ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR MORE THAN AT HOME
WITH NATURAL GAS APPLIANCES IN
IT. SO OUR MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT A MOVE FOR ELECTRIFICATION
A KNOW. IT BECOMES AT THIS IS
AND THAT IT THAT ONE WITNESS
SAID IT WAS. MOVED WAS
ELECTRIFICATION AND IMPACT IS
GOING TO HAVE A LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS.
THAT'S SO THAT CLEARS IT UP.
.
SO I.
I WERE I RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO.
BUT WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
ELECTRICITY BECAUSE PARTICULARLY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND HOW
HIGH THEY ARE NOW AND IN FACT I
THINK THEY'RE ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT
PERCENT HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
COMMENTS MADE BY.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
STOCKTON WITH A PREFERENCE TO.
ON WHAT TYPE OF THE PLANTS ONE
WOULD COOK ON IN THEIR HOME AND
HAVING THAT OPTION BEING TAKEN
AWAY.
.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
EVERY OTHER DAY OF SOLAR COMPANY
IS CALLING MY HOME TELLING ME
ABOUT THE GREAT DEALS THAT ARE
GOING ON THERE STATE SANCTIONED
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE THE.
FURTHER PROLIFERATION OF SOLAR
USE IN CALIFORNIA IT IS.
MORE WIDESPREAD CERTAINLY MORE
SO THAN OTHER STATES.
.
BUT I JUST SEE THE COST RISING
MORE AND MORE FOR HOMEOWNERS OR
POTENTIAL HOMEOWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WERE ALREADY HAD
A CRISIS.
CRISIS POINT IN CALIFORNIA WHEN
IT COMES TO HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
WHAT COMES TO HOMELESSNESS.
WE ARE THERE.
I I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT YOUR
BILL WOULD.
.
BE THEY THE SOLE REASON WHY THE
WHOLE HOUSE COMES FALLING DOWN
PARDON THE PUN.
BUT I AM SUGGESTING THAT THIS
CERTAINLY ISN'T GOING TO HELP
THAT WHEN WE CONTINUE TO PUT
MANDATES ON THAT HOMEBUILDING
INDUSTRY.
AND.
WE CONTINUE TO.
BECAUSE THE COST TO RISE FEWER
AND FEWER PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
AFFORD A HOME IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S RIGHT I
DON'T THINK THAT'S EVERYTHING
THEY DO AND I THINK THAT'S THE
WAY WE SOLVE THE PROBLEM WENT
WITH RESPECT TO ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS IN THE AND THE AND THE
HOUSING ISSUE THE AVERAGE HOME
PRICES IN THE BAY AREA'S IT
UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WHO CAN AFFORD THAT?
THAT PRICE IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO GO UP.
SO I
I WOULD.
BE HAPPY
TO SIT AND TALK MORE.
ABOUT THIS WITH YOU.
AND SEE IF THERE'S A WAY WE
COULD I'M SURE THERE'S SOME.
IDEAS THAT WE WOULD AGREE ON.
BUT THIS ONE LIKE I JUST CAN'T A
GRAND GIVEN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY HOME IN
CALIFORNIA GIVEN NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. WHO CAN AFFORD TO BUY
HOME TO KEEP FIND WHAT TO BUY
BECAUSE THEY JUST AREN'T
BUILDING THEM FAST ENOUGH SO AM
I APPRECIATE YOU BRING THE BILL
FOR THE BUT I'M NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT A TODAY?
MR ACOSTA THAN MR MCCARTY.
UP THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I I
THINK THAT'S A LAUDABLE GOAL.
I ECHO SOME OF THE SENTIMENTS
THAT THAT HAVE BEEN.
SHARED AYE I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS I MEAN I.
I KEEP HEARING THAT THIS IS
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL WHICH IT
APPEARS TO BE I'M FOR OWES VERY
CONCERNED BY SOME OF THE BACK
AND FORTH THOUGH ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION VERSES A STUDY.
CELEBRITY A STUDY BUT I'M GONNA
IMPLEMENT SAID STUDY WITHOUT IT
CAME BACK TO THIS THIS SAGA.
.
THIS BODY HAS COMMITTEE.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION THOUGH SO.
DO YOU DO YOU ENVISION WITH THIS
LEGISLATION IN THIS BILL. THAT
WE ARE GOING TO GET TO A
SITUATION WHERE IF I GO TO SELL
MY HOME I HAVE TO CHANGE OUT
APPLIANCES. OR RETRO FIT OR OR
OR ANY OF THAT IS THAT KIND OF
WHERE WE'RE GOING HERE IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT'S.
THE GOAL HERE.
FOR EXISTING EXISTING HOMES.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S THE
GOAL I DON'T I MEAN I DON'T KNOW
OF SOMETHING LIKE THAT WOULD END
UP BEING PART OF ANY PLAN. I
WOULD HOPE THAT.
WE DON'T PREMATURELY KIND OF TRY
TO SECOND GUESS WHAT'S GOING TO
BE IN THAT PLAN AFTER LENGTHY
PUBLIC HEARINGS AFTER OR. PEOPLE
WAY ON THE BEST AND MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAY. OF REACHING OUR
GOALS YOU KNOW AGAIN WE THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BEGIN
THE GOAL SETTING PROCESS AND TO
HAVE A TARGET.
AND WE SHOULDN'T BE SO AFRAID OF
WHAT MIGHT COME ALONG THE WAY
THAT WE'RE NOT EVEN WILLING.
I TRIED TO HAVE A GOAL OR TRY TO
HAVE A TARGET TO REDUCE WHAT'S
ONE OF OUR LARGEST SOURCES OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
SO UMBER.
IT I COULDN'T TELL YOU RIGHT
THIS MOMENT HOW THAT GOAL IS
GOING TO BE MET BUT WE HEARD
SOME IDEAS TODAY WE HEARD ABOUT
UTILIZATION OF RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS WHICH CAN ALSO POWER. THOSE
GAS STOVES EVERYBODY LOVES YOU
KNOW WE HEARD ABOUT YOU KNOW
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THE GOAL
PERHAPS BRINGING IN OTHER TYPES
OF FUEL SOURCES A GEOTHERMAL. OF
USING MORE SOLAR THERE'S A LOT
OF WAYS THAT THAT CAN BE DONE
AND.
OVER TIME A LOT OF HOMEOWNERS
CHOOSE TO PUT MORE AFFECTION
EFFICIENT PRODUCTS INTO THEIR
HOMES THEMSELVES BECAUSE THEY
GET REBATES SOMETIMES EMPOWER
UTILITIES BECAUSE THE OLD ONES.
WEAR OUT AND THEY DECIDE TO
REPLACE HIM AND BECAUSE NOW
THERE'S MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT
PRODUCTS ON THE MARKET. AND PART
OF THE IDEA OF SETTING THE GOAL
IS TO.
TO GIVE THAT MARKET SIGNAL TO
PEOPLE WHO DEVELOP TECHNOLOGY
WHO DEVELOP APPLIES TO SAY THIS
IS OUR GOAL.
KENMORE SEARS WE WANT YOU TO
START GOING OUT AND COMING UP
WITH REALLY GREAT APPLIANCES
THAT YOU THAT ARE.
ZERO EMISSIONS WITHOUT DOING
THAT WITHOUT HAVING THAT GOAL
IT'S HARD TO SEND THAT MARKETS
ARE GOING TO HOW TO IT'S HARD TO
HAVE THOSE CHOICES MAN. COME ON
THE SHELVES THE SAME WAY THAT
NOW WATER EFFICIENCY CHOICES OF
COME ON THE SHELVES.
SO IF YOU WOULD ASK ME TEN YEARS
AGO ABOUT THE DROUGHT NOT GONNA
WE ARE WIENER REQUIRE HOMEOWNERS
TO GO OUT AND. RETROFIT ALL OF
THEIR HOUSES WITH WATER SEEPING
WELL WE ENDED UP NOT GOING THERE
BECAUSE THE MARKET ITSELF ONCE
WE KEEP THAT SIGNAL PROVIDED
THOSE APPLIANCES AND MADE THOSE
CHOICES ATTRACTIVE TO CONSUMERS.
SO I THINK IS A LOT BETTER WAY
OF GOING ABOUT GETTING TO
EFFICIENCY.
AND I THINK THAT THE MARKET
WILL START DOING THAT ON THEIR
OWN ON ITS OWN ONCE WE SEND
THOSE SIGNALS DIFFERENT THINGS
TO ADD. BUT JUST OUT OF THAT YOU
KNOW BY PROVIDING THIS MONTH
THIS POLICY SIGNAL WILL DRIVE
INNOVATION INVESTMENTS AND JUST
LIKE WITH THAT BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE NOW HAVE THE OPTION OF
HAVING. CARS POWERED BY
ELECTRICITY HYBRIDS HYDROGEN
NATURAL GAS THAT HAS REPLACED
THE SINGLE CHOI HAD TO HAVE WITH
A DIFFICULT BUT NO A GASOLINE
COMBUSTION ENGINE BEFORE THIS OF
SAMETIME BILLS HOW DO WE MAKE
THESE OPTIONS. WHICH ARE CHEAPER
HEALTHIER CLEANER VENABLE TO THE
PLOT OF POPULATIONS HAVE JUST
THE WEALTHIER CALIFORNIA'S
TODAY.
HOW TO SAY AS WE JUST HEARD FROM
THE ARCHITECTS
THIS IS NOT GREENLEE THESE ARE
HOUSES GO
BACK THE NINETEEN TWENTIES THAT
BECAUSE THAT KIND OF MONEY IT'S
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF OTHER
FACTORS LIKE THE PRICE OF LAND?
AND OUT AND POPULATION GROWTH
SO.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE
CONNECTION IS YOU KNOW. QUITE
THAT CLEAR OBVIOUS.
WELL I I DO APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THAT WAS.
JUST STATED AS A LOT OF
INFORMATION HERE.
I.
FIND IT INTERESTING THAT WE JUST
HAD A BILL EARLIER REGARDING
SEQUEL.
I AM ONE OF MY COMMENTS ABOUT
SEQUEL WAS THAT OR ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR BILL WAS THAT.
WELL IT'S ONLY IF IT THAT'S NOT
ALL OF THAT THAT'S ONLY A PART
OF IT.
AND THEN HERE WE ARE.
EVEN SO SO GO AHEAD AND DON'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT SEQUEL AND THEN
OUR HERE AND WORK ADDING TO THE
COST OF. OF OF HOUSING STOCKS IN
CALIFORNIA POTENTIALLY.
BIG WITH THESE MANDATES I'M WE
CAN AGREE AND DISAGREE CAN CHECK
YOUR HAD THAT I THAT WITH ALL
RESPECT SIR. I FIND IT REALLY
DISCONCERTING WHEN YOU'RE
SHAKING YOUR HEAD IN THE FRONT
ROW FOR EVERYONE TO SEE.
DISAGREEING WITH THE FOLKS THAT
ARE UP HERE GIVING THEIR EXPERT
TESTIMONY.
I I REALLY RESENT THAT.
IS YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY EXPERT IN
THIS ROOM I GUARANTEE OF SIR.
SO I WOULD I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT WHEN I'M SPEAKING.
THAT YOU GIVE ME SOME COURTESY
AND NOT SHAKE YOUR HEAD ROLL
YOUR EYES AS YOU JUST DID.
PLEASE I DON'T I DON'T NEED A
COMMENT I JUST NEED YOU TO SIT
THERE AND NOT ROLL YOUR EYES AT
ME BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
DISRESPECTFUL.
OKAY.
SO.
I'M GONNA CONTINUE ON HERE AND
I'M.
WITHOUT LOSING MY TEMPER WITH
ONE OF THE WITNESSES.
.
SO WE HAVE THESE ISSUES GOING ON
CALIFORNIA WERE CALLING A
HOUSING CRISIS A CRISIS IF YOU
CRISIS THAT OUR COUNTRY
HAS.
HAS EVER IN OUR STATE HAS EVER
FACED.
WHERE WE ARE NOT ACTUALLY DOING
ANYTHING?
EXCEPT EXACERBATE SAID CRISIS.
WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING ON SECA WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ON ON.
I'M KEEPING THE COST AND COST
CONTAINMENT DOWN
WERE IT WE HAVE.
.
SOME TESTIMONY THAT SAYS THIS
WILL INCREASE COSTS WE WILL
ATTEST MY SAYS IT WON'T WE'RE
GONNA DO A PLAN WHICH I AM ALL
FOR STUDY BILL.
BUT THEN WE'RE GOING TO
IMPLEMENT THE PLAN WITHOUT
COMING BACK TO THIS PARTICULAR.
CHAMBER IN THIS COMMITTEE SO I
DON'T SEE HOW THIS IS GOING TO
HELP OUR HOUSING CRISIS I DON'T
REALLY SEE HOW.
WITHOUT MORE FACTS.
OTHER THAN THE LOT OF
SUPPOSITION.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET.
ANYWHERE WITHOUT ADDING A HUGE
COST IN A BURDEN TO NEW
HOMEOWNERS AS I MENTIONED PRIOR
OUR CHILDREN CANNOT AFFORD TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
FIFTH PERIOD UNLESS THEY'RE VERY
LUCKY AND GO TO WORK FOR A TECH
COMPANY OR SOME OTHER. YOU KNOW
GET GET IN THERE AND DIRT THE
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS FOR EXAMPLE
ARE BEING DRIVEN OUT AND THEIR
CURRENT BEING DRIVEN OUT OF THE
SUBURBS AND THEY WERE NOT
LETTING THE SUBURBS BUILT HOUSES
EITHER.
AND IT'S BILLS LIKE THIS THAT R.
STUNTING THAT GROWTH I'M I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE AND I WOULD
LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU ON A BILL
THAT DOESN'T IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION. BOB HARM WHAT WORKED
THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF TRYING TO
PRODUCE MORE HOUSING WHILE WE'RE
BEING CLEANER AND I THINK WE CAN
DO BOTH I DON'T THINK THIS IS
THE VEHICLE FOR IT I LOVE TO SEE
IT AS A STUDY BILL.
BUT AS OF RIGHT NOW I AM A VERY
FIRM NO ON THIS PARTICULAR
GOVERNOR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
REALLY APPRECIATED.
BUT.
THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL AS THIS
BILL BEEN MOVED.
HOW MOVE THAT THAT KNOWS?
BUT SYSTEM MADE.
SECOND OKAY AND THEN JUST JUST
SOME THOUGHTS ON THIS AND SO I I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE RIGHT I
NOTICE IT'S JUST THREE WORDS A
CAT TEMPERATE THE PLAN.
IT'S FIFTY PERCENT TWENTY THIRTY
IS A LOT OF VARIABLES TO
IMPLEMENT THIS.
I WILL KNOW THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE HOUSING STOCK EVEN NOT HOT
AREA LIKE SACRAMENTO.
NOW IN WHEN WE HAD THE LAST
HOUSING BOOM TEN YEARS AGO.
THESE NET ZERO ZERO EMISSION
HOMES FOR SALE THEIR THE HOT
SELLERS BECAUSE.
AS YOU NOTED SOME ARCHITECTS CAN
SAVE A CAN MAKE THESE RIGHT AT
THE COST MARGINS.
OF THE OTHER HOMES BUT SOMETIMES
EVEN A LITTLE BIT MORE THE
HOMEOWNER SEES WHAT THEY WILL
GET BACK IN THERE ENERGY SAVINGS
AND I DON'T THINK WE.
WE I. TALKED ENOUGH ABOUT THAT
TODAY AND SO. I THINK IT'S IT'S
CRITICAL THAT ELEMENT.
NOT TO NOT TO MENTION THAT I
THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO.
ADDRESS THAT CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
ENERGY COSTS ARE CRITICAL
COMPONENT AND.
THAT THIS IS A NEW HOMES ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT RETROFITTING A
NO THAT WAS DISCUSSED HERE BUT I
THINK THAT. THAT'S WHEN YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY I THINK THAT'S
WHERE AND.
YOU HAVE THE ECONOMIES OF SCALE
YOU COULD FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
IT RIGHT AND YOU CAN BRING THE
COST DOWN TO REALLY MAKE IT.
MANAGEABLE WORKABLE SO THANK YOU
FOR THIS MEASURE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MISS FRIEDMAN.
IDEA.
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THE CONCERN
RAISED ABOUT HOW.
THIS YOUR BILL.
REQUIRES THE CC TO DEVELOP A
PLAN.
WITHOUT THE PLAN COMING BACK.
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR. REVIEW.
WELL FIRST OF ALL.
ARE THERE ANY PENALTIES IN YOUR.
PROPOSED YOUR BILL.
FOR THE FAILURE TO ACHIEVE A
FIFTY PERCENT REDUCTION IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS NO.
SO I SEE ON THE BILL ANALYSES.
.
ON PAGE THREE ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
YOUR BILL REQUIRES THAT THE
PLAN AND STRATEGY DEVELOPED BY
THE C. C. INCLUDE THE ADOPTION
OF POLICY CHANGES NEEDED.
AND AS ENERGY EFFICIENCY
REGULATIONS TO CHEAP THE GOALS
OF THIS BILL.
DO YOU WELL. HAVE YOU
CONSIDERED.
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
REVIEW THESE POLICY CHANGES
BEFORE THEY'RE ADOPTED.
OR DE SEE.
THAT IS PART OF YOUR.
.
STRATEGY.
TO HAVE THE CC ADOPT THE
REGULATIONS WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
IT CERTAINLY DISCUSS THAT THIS
IS REALLY THE BEGINNING OF THE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THESE BILLS
ABOUT THIS BILL SO WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE. WITH A NEXT COMMITTEE
THAT'LL GO TO WHICH IS THE.
ENERGY AND UTILITIES COMMITTEE
AND WITH THE MY FELLOW MEMBERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS ALL
OF THESE CONCERNS.
SO THAT WE YOU KNOW WE ARE ABLE
TO DO SOMETHING THAT. PEOPLE
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH YES.
I THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
ALSO THE THE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST.
WELL I.
APPRECIATE YOUR.
YOUR BILL HERE AS A A BOLD STEP
FORWARD TO SET THE GOAL FOR THE.
FIFTY PERCENT REDUCTION IN THE
J. SHE EMISSIONS AND FOR THAT
REASON I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL.
.
BUT I A. I AM CONCERNED THAT YOU
KNOW.
WE'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE IN
CALIFORNIA WE LIKE TO.
TO LEAD.
AND.
THE FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ADDRESSING.
THE.
PERHAPS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF.
.
COSTS ON.
WEEKLY ON.
ARE LOW INCOME AND MIDDLE CLASS
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
SO.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN YOUR BILL
SPECIFICALLY I IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE CDC HAS.
.
LAWS AND REGULATIONS IN PLACE TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION. OF THE
COST IMPLICATIONS OF THEIR
POLICIES BUT IS THERE ANYTHING
SPECIFIC IN YOUR BILL THAT
ADDRESSES THESE COSTS ISSUES WE
ARE HAPPY TO LONG PUT LANGUAGE
INTO THE BILL THAT THE INSTRUCTS
THEM TO TAKE A COSTS
PARTICULARLY WITH LOW INCOME
WITH AGRICULTURE WITH A
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
INDUSTRIES. I'M INTO ACCOUNT
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WE HEAR
THOSE CONCERNS WE ARE YOU KNOW
WE APPRECIATE THEM AND.
OUR INTENT IS NOT TO STOP THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA BY ANY MEANS.
ALRIGHT.
WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
I JUST I KNOW THAT THIS IS ARM.
KIND OF BIG IDEA POLICY BUT I
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THOSE GOALS AND I WE HEAR
THE CONCERNS WE DON'T JUST
DISAGREE WITH A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT IS
THIS BILL PROGRESSES THAT THEY
ARE DRESSED SO THAT.
WE CAN TAKE THOSE INTO ACCOUNT
BUT WE ALSO FEEL THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AT THIS TIME THAT WE
TAKE A BOLD STEP. OF CHARTING TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS IN THE BUILDING
SECTOR AND THIS WILL BE THERE
REALLY THE FIRST STEP TO DO THAT
IN A VERY COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WAY
AND WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
IT BE DONE.
IT IN THAT KIND OF WITH THAT
KIND OF CONCERTED EFFORTS
WITHOUT I WILL ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION IS A TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO UTILITIES AND ENERGY.
AND WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
LOCAL.
I AM TWENTY SIX A. B. THIRTY TO
THIRTY TWO BY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MARTUCCI HIGH REFUGEE
AYE ACOSTA NO ACOSTA NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
INSIDE AT NEW.
EGGMAN AYE.
FLORIDA
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MELENDEZ LENDERS NO
STONE.
STONE I.
THREE BELLEZZA.
ALRIGHT MS CLAUDIA I SEE YOU'VE
BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING
.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS WIKIA.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
AB TWENTY THREE ONE. A BILL THAT
HELPS CALIFORNIA'S AIR RESOURCE
BOARD OR THE A ARE BE COMBAT
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY DESIGNED TO
EVADE. CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR
LAWS.
NEW MOTOR VEHICLES ARE SUBJECT
TO EMISSION TEST BY THE AIR BE
TO VERIFY COMPLIANCE WITH.
CALIFORNIA EMISSION LAWS HOWEVER
DEVICES EXIST THAT CAN ENABLE A
VEHICLE TO FOOL. ITS EMISSIONS
TESTING.
IN A PROMINENT EXAMPLE IT WAS
DISCOVERED THAT VOLKSWAGEN HAD
INSTALLED THIS THAT WOULD BE SO
CALLED DEFEAT DEVICES.
AND MANY OF THEIR CARS.
THESE DEVICES WERE DISCOVERED IN
PART DUE TO REAL WORLD TESTING
DATA THAT HELP DETECT THESE
DEVICES WHICH WERE PREVIOUSLY
UNDISCOVERED BOWL. AND
LABORATORY SETTINGS
THE AIR BE OPEN AN INVESTIGATION
AND FOUND THAT EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND VOLKSWAGEN DIESEL
VEHICLES REGISTERED IN
CALIFORNIA. ADMITTED EXCESSIVE
NEUTRALS OXIDE A TOXIC
POLLUTANTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN CLEANING UP THE AIR
AND FIGHTING AGAINST POLLUTANTS
BUT VOLKSWAGEN'S DECEPTION WAS
PARTICULARLY DAMAGING BECAUSE
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE STILL
EXPERIENCE. SOME OF THE WORST
AIR QUALITY IN THE NATION.
THIS FACT COUPLED WITH RECENT
ATTEMPTS BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO ROLLBACK
CALIFORNIA'S. NATION LEADING
CLEAN AIR LAWS MEANS THAT WE
MUST ACT TO UPHOLD THE
SAFEGUARDS OF FOR THE HEALTH OF
OUR STATE AND OUR RESIDENTS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE.
I WOULD PARTNER WITH A R. B.
WITH ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
LABORATORIES AND EXPERTS IN
ORDER TO ENHANCE THEIR NEW MOTOR
VEHICLE EMISSIONS TESTING
PROGRAM AND DISCOVER THESE
DEFEAT DEVICES. AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE WILL ALSO GIVE THE
AIR BE THE ABILITY TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO PERFORM
MORE INDEPENDENT TESTING IN
ORDER TO STAY AT THE FOREFRONT
OF PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S. AIR
FROM THOSE WHO WOULD VIOLATE OUR
LAWS POLLUTER ENVIRONMENT AND
HARM OUR RESIDENTS.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFIED IS
WILLIAM BARRETTE A SENIOR POLICY
ANALYST AT THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA.
LIKE YOU VERY MUCH HAVE HAPPY TO
BE HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
SOME THE MOST DIFFICULT AIR
POLLUTION CHALLENGES IN THE
UNITED STATES UNHEALTHY AIR
WHICH IS LARGELY DRIVEN IN OUR
STATE BY MOBILE SOURCES ARE
PASSENGER VEHICLES CARS TRUCKS.
AND BUSES.
AFFECTS THE LONG HEALTH IN MANY
FORMS INCLUDING. CAUSING ASTHMA
ATTACKS STARTED LONG LONG
DEVELOPMENT AND ONE FUNCTION IN
CHILDREN. LUNG CANCER AND
PREMATURE DEATHS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LUNG
ASSOCIATION PUBLISHED A REPORT
THAT FOUND FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN HEALTH.
I CLIMATE DAMAGES PER YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE PASSENGER
VEHICLE FLEET POLLUTION FROM OUR
CARS AND TRUCKS ON THE ROAD.
THIS IS WHY CALIFORNIA'S
STRONGER THE NATIONAL POLICIES
ARE SO IMPORTANT WHEN COMPLIED
WITH OUR STATES EMISSION RULES
ARE HAVING A DRAMATIC AFFECT ON
CLEAN UP BARRIER. AND LESSENING
THESE IMPACTS ON THE HEALTH OF
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE CLEARLY NEED GREATER
ASSURANCE THAT THESE RULES ARE
WORKING IN DELIVERING REAL WORLD
BENEFITS AND ARE NOT BEING
UNDERMINED BY VOLKSWAGENS OF THE
WORLD ARE OTHER MANUFACTURERS
DECEPTIONS. A OR OTHER FAILURES
TO POINT.
TO COMPLY WITH THE RULES FOR ANY
OTHER CAUSE.
AB TWENTY THIRTY EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY ONE I'M
SORRY WOULD ALLOW AIR BE TO
COLLECT FEES FOR MANUFACTURERS
TO ENHANCE MOTOR VEHICLE
EMISSION TESTING PROGRAMS. TO
ENSURE THAT THE COMPLIANCE
ACROSS IN USE.
ON ROAD ANOTHER REAL WORLD
DRIVING SETTINGS ARE DELIVERING
THOSE REAL WORLD WIENER BENEFITS
TO CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL
ADVANCES PUBLIC HEALTH AND CLEAN
AIR IN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARCHERS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
KYLE JOINS US HERE FOR
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SEEING.
NO OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
COMING FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES COMING
FORWARD TO A QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
MUCH HAS BEEN MADE AND SECONDED
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S GOT A WEIGHT WHICH LIKE
CLOSE.
GIVE US A CHAIRED MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARES
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS TO
TRANSPORTATION.
ROLL CALL PLEASE
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE BY MEMBER CARILLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MURATSUCHI AYE ROUTE TO GI
ACOSTA ON THE COAST I'VE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA KILEY MON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ LENDERS AYE
STONE. STONE AYE NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO CONGRATULATES THINK IT.
ALRIGHT MISTER CHIU.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING PATIENTLY.
AND THERE'S.
STRUCK NO YEAH I HAVE A VERY
VERY MUCH A MISTER CHAIRED BY
MEMBER. OF FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS STEP FOR A
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
I'LL LOOK I LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE A AN
AMENDMENT.
A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IS
WHO DISTRICT BAIL.
ADDRESSING THE LOCAL OLD OR IT
ISSUES THERE HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
FOR MY CONSTITUENT AND CAUSING
SCHOOL CLOSURES. IN MY AREA.
DISPELLED.
MY SOUND FAMILIAR FOR MANY OF
YOU HERE BECAUSE SEE THE A
SIMILAR BILLS. PASS ALL DOCTORS
COMEDIAN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
AT THE SAME TIME.
THE LOCAL. OPERATORS IN AND
STARTED OF THE STAKEHOLDERS.
OF THE A GROUP CALLED SALISBURY
OLDER TASK FORCE.
AND FOUND I WAS HOPEFUL.
THAT IT WILL SERVE AS A PLACE
FOR LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND CITIES HAVE FACILITIES.
THAT COULD BE A THE FIRST FORCES
SOLVE ORDERS TO WORK TOGETHER
AND I'M WORK ON REMEDIES.
AND I HAVE TO.
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION IN
PUBLIC.
FOR THOSE STAKEHOLDERS EFFORTS
SO FAR.
BUT NOT ORDER NOW ALL OF.
DE.
THE OPERATORS ARE.
REGULARLY A ATTENDING BECAUSE.
QUARTERLY MEETING.
SO WITHOUT HAVING ALL THE RIGHT
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM.
I FELT A GROUP CAN ONLY DO SO
MUCH.
AND AB NIGHT HINGED.
I CONSERVATIVE FIVE WILL BRING
ALL THIS THOSE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER.
PROMOTE CORPORATION WHO
COOPERATION AND FIND A SOLUTION.
TO SOLVE THE ISSUE DE HOUSE
BEING IMPACTING PEOPLE. LIVING
IN MY AREA AND LIVING AND
WORKING IN MY AREA I HELP HER
COMPLAIN FROM SENT DISK.
AND AND THEY WERE HAVING
DIFFICULTY TO RECRUIT WORKERS
BECAUSE.
ONE DAY PARK THEIR CARD IN FOND
IN FRONT OF THE YEAR FACILITY HE
SAID THE MANY PEOPLE CAME IMPAIR
TO SMILE.
OF OFTEN. IN THAT DISTRICT.
SO A.
A AGAIN.
THIS BILL. IS TO FORMALIZE A
CURRENT TASKFORCE.
YOU BRING STAKEHOLDERS TO BRING
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO
WORK ON THE SOLUTION.
AND YOU'RE NO ADDITIONAL
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS OR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS ATTACHED TO
THIS BILL.
AND THIS BILL.
IT'S NOT LOOKING TOO
SHUT DOWN ENDING A OPERATORS.
BUT JUST TO MAKE SURE OR DATA
YOU KNOW WE CAN ALL COEXIST IN
AND AND AND DOING VITAMIN.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
BAY AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT BOARD.
NOW OWNED CLARIFYING SOME
AMENDMENTS AND AND.
I'M HAPPY NOW WILL BE CONTINUE.
TO WORKING WITH THEM AS A BILL
MOVE FORWARD.
SO THAT WAS THAT ARE YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR OF.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHIU DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF.
THIS BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOM EDISON WITH
THE BAY AREA AIR DISTRICT. NOT
QUITE IN SUPPORT BUT WE'RE VERY
CLOSE WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE OFFERS OF WORK
WITH US TRYING TO GET TO
SOMETHING.
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
GENERALLY QUITE LIKE THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL ARE
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
THE ODORS I IN MILPITAS THEN
ADJACENT TOWNS IS.
APPROPRIATE.
SOUTH THEY ORDER STAKEHOLDERS
GROUP.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS HAS
BEEN HINDERED BY THE FACT THAT
NOT EVERYONE'S PARTICIPATING SO
WE THINK THAT THEY SHOULD HELP
OUT. AYE END GET US ARE
CONTINUING. ON THE ROADS ARE
LESS NOW.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FOR.
MISTER CHAIR JUST MALANA BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES VERY MUCH RELUCTANTLY
IN OPPOSITION.
AND THE ONLY REASON THE
OPPOSITE WE OPPOSING THIS BILL
IS NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T SUPPORT
WHAT IS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
THIS IS A LOCAL ISSUE.
AND EIGHT WE RARELY CON START
HAVING STATURE TREE OBLIGATIONS
ON LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
COORDINATE. THERE IS PLENTY OF
STATUTE IN PLACE
TO REQUIRE ADEQUATE OVERVIEW
THIS THAT.
TO IMPACT MANAGEMENT PLAN THAT
HAS TO BE APPROVED.
I'M SO RAW THEN LOAD UP MORE
LOW'S.
TO DEAL WITH LOCAL ISSUES THAT
SHOULD BE DONE.
CERTAINLY WITH IN THE CURRENT
LAW WE WOULD OFFERED DID LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO STEP IN
IF THEY HAVEN'T STEPPED IN. TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BUT WE
BELIEVE WE HAVE A PROCESS IN
PLACE MOVE REALLY DON'T SEE A
NEED FOR A BILL THANK YOU.
CARE MARTINSON ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I'M HERE BUT THE VERY
SIMILAR ARE GOOD ARGUMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE JUST IN MILAN. I JUST
LIKE TO ALSO POINT OUT THAT IN
ADDITION TO SETTING A PRECEDENT.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT ON SOME OF OUR
LARGER I SEE WHY POLICY GOALS.
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
SIX OUR COMMERCIAL ORGANICS
RECYCLING LAWS WERE ALSO IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING. A
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT S. B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY THREE WHICH READ
REQUIRE A SIGNIFICANT OUR
PRODUCTION OF METHANE EMISSIONS
FROM LANDFILLS AND US. A
SIGNIFICANT DIVERSION OF ORGANIC
MATERIAL WE I NEED ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MANAGE THIS
PORTION OF THE WASTE STREAM
WHICH WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE
SO.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT WITH THE
PRESIDENT LIKE THIS.
BUT WE COULD SEE POTENTIAL
POLICY IMPACTS ON SOME OF OUR
LARGER STATE RECALLS.
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IT'S YOUR
DESIRE TO ADDRESS THE
OTHER ISSUES IN THE CITY OF
MILPITAS.
TO CONTROL ORDER AT ITS FACILITY
REPUBLIC HAS INVESTED NEARLY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN.
OPERATIONAL ENHANCEMENTS AND
FACILITY IMPROVEMENTS
TO ENSURE THE POTENTIAL ORDER
IMPACTS ARE MINIMIZED AND
ELIMINATED ON SITE.
WE ARE CONCERNED HOWEVER THAT AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE CREATES A
DUKE DUPLICATIVE EXPENSIVE
COMPLEX
AND INEFFECTIVE PROCESS THAT
WILL NOT RESOLVE THE PROBLEM
THAT SEEKS TO RESOLVE.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS REFLECTS
THAT THERE IS ALREADY EXTENSIVE
REGULATION OF ORDER IT ISSUES BY
AIR DISTRICTS
FOR MOST OF THE ORDER SOURCES
AND CAL RECYCLING THE LA RAIL.
FOR COMPOST OPERATIONS.
FIRST THE RESULTS OF A RECENTLY
RELEASED ODOR A BRASS SOURCES
CHARACTERS ACTION
CHARACTERIZATION STUDY.
CONDUCTED AROUND THE CITY OF
MILPITAS.
SHOWS THAT NATURAL SOURCES THAT
IS THE EVAN FLOW OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY WATERS.
WHERE THE DOMINANT SOURCE OF
REGIONAL ODORS?
NEITHER SAYS SOURCES OF THESE
ODORS NOR THE VOTERS THEMSELVES
WILL GO AWAY.
WHILE BEING WELL AWARE OF THE
VOTER SOURCES IN THE AREA LAND
USE POLICIES WERE ADOPTED OVER
THE YEARS.
THAT AUTHORIZED HOUSING IN THE
CITY OF MILPITAS.
TO BE BUILT CLOSER TO THESE
NATURAL ODORS.
THESE NATURAL SOURCES OF MOTOR
FURTHER BIG EXACERBATING THE
PROBLEM.
THE NEWBIE ISLAND HAS UNDERGONE
AN EXTENSIVE LOCALLY AND USE
PROCESS
SOLID WASTE FACILITIES
PERMITTING PROCESS AND MANY OF
REPUBLICS OPERATIONS ALSO
REQUIRE WATER DISTRICT APPROVAL
AN AIR DISTRICT APPROVAL.
ALL OF THESE PROCESSES ARE
TRANSPARENT AND OPEN UP TO THE
PUBLIC.
THIS SOUTH BAY ORDER
STAKEHOLDERS GROUP THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REFERENCED WAS
FORMED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN.
ABC NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
REQUIRES A STATE A STATE TASK
FORCE THAT REPLICATES THE LOCAL
TASK FORCE.
I MIGHT ADD THAT THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE LOCAL TASK FORCE THAT
COMPELS PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE.
FURTHER THERE IS NOTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT WILL COMPEL ANYONE TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND THEREFORE I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE THE SAME OUTCOME.
THAT IS ANOTHER STATUTE
BUT THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE OUTCOME.
SO WITHOUT FURTHER MORE.
THE LOCAL ASK GET WORSE CANNOT A
MAP OF CANNOT BE ELIMINATED
BECAUSE IT'S A CONDITION OF OUR
PERMITS.
SO FOR ALL OF THE AFOREMENTIONED
REASONS WE BELIEVE THAT AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE. DESERVES
YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH
PANAY I'M BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING COUNCIL A
HUNDRED COMPANIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THAT DO THIS EXACT WORK
AND RUN INTO THESE LOCAL ISSUES.
AS A FORMER MEMBER OF THE CITY
COUNCIL HERE IN SACRAMENTO I
DEALT WITH THESE ISSUES
AND THEY'RE VERY DIFFICULT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THERE'S A
PROCESS IN PLACE.
THIS THIS AND ALL THE
FACILITIES EXCEPT FOR THE
NATURAL PROBLEM THAT OCCURS IN
THIS AREA WHICH THE STUDY FOUND
WAS THE PROBLEM. AYE YEAH.
IS AND PLACED THAT PROCESS IS A
GOOD PROCESS WE WOULD URGE YOU
OF RESPECTFULLY ASK TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL TO VOTE NO AND WE'VE
SPOKEN TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
ABOUT THIS AND OUR STATE WIDE
IMPLICATIONS TO IT. SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
OKAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KELLY
ASTRA BEHALF OF THE.
SEE LA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION SOLVE ASSOCIATION
ORANGE COUNTY IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE DISPOSAL ASSOCIATION ALL
THREE REGIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS.
REGRETTED THAT THERE NEED TO
OPPOSE THE BILL LARGELY BECAUSE
OF THE DISASTROUS IMPACTS SUCH.
BUT THE PRESIDENT HIS BILL WOULD
SET IN TERMS OF FACILITY OF
ELEMENTS SUSTAINED OPERATION
THEREBY HAMPERING OUR BILLION
OBTAIN THE ROOF RECYCLING GOALS
ARE IN LAW NOW THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEVE
CARLTON TO ATHENS SERVICES WHERE
LARGE SHOW SOLID WASTE RECYCLING
A. PROVIDER IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE MUST ALSO REGRETTABLY OPPOSE
THE BILL AS YOU WILL HEAR.
US TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF MR
MAIENSCHEIN BILL COMING UP THE
NEED FOR MORE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THIS STATE IS CRITICAL IT'S
BEYOND CRITICAL.
BUT ANYTHING PARTICULARLY A BILL
LIKE THIS WHICH IS NOT GONNA OF
NOT GOING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM BUT
CAN TO CREATE MORE. OF HIS
SPEECH IS THE. NOT WELL FOUNDED
WE WOULD HURT YOU A NO VOTE.
MARY PEDAL LIST PEARL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MS EGGMAN THEN MISTER SHOW.
I. THINK YOU THINK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR.
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
LIKE I STATED EARLIER WHEN
ANYTHING SYMBOL SHYNESS IS TRASH
AND WE CONTINUE TO MAKE POLICIES
THAT. MANDATE THAT WE RECYCLE
AND AND REDUCE LANDFILLS AND WE
A LOT OF THINGS THAT THAT
REQUIRE A LOT OF MONEY FROM
INDUSTRY.
AND THEN AND THEN WE GET
CONCERNED ABOUT SMELLS AND
THINGS.
THEN AGAIN AS STATED IN WHAT
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO ASCERTAIN
THERE'S ALREADY A PROCESS OF
PLACE THIS JUST KIND OF PUTS THE
ONUS BACK ONTO THAT THE LANDFILL
FOLKS WHO SEEM TO BE. HAVE BEEN
GOOD PARTNERS IN THIS HAVE BEEN
AT THE TABLE HAVE BEEN WORKING.
ASSEMBLY ABLE SUPPORT YOU BUILT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON.
IT DID I THINK YOU'RE SO.
TREMENDOUS IMPROVEMENT AFTER THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO A LOT OF.
A GROUP WAS SO ESTABLISHED
TWENTY FOURTEEN.
.
BUT AGAIN.
GOOD NOW ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
ARE PARTICIPATING.
AND IN THIS A A TASK FORCE.
SO I'M HOPING TO GIVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE CHEESE TO THIS TASK
FORCE.
TO ENCOURAGE.
ALL.
STAKEHOLDER TO PARTICIPATE TO
YOU DO ALL TO WORK TO
REPUBLICANS TO ONE THAT THAT WAS
REALLY THE FINAL GOAL.
AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
DEBT THEY COULD BE THAT GOOD
CORPORATE CITIZEN.
MP COLE EXIST WHISKEY EXISTING.
A COMMUNITY JUSTICE SERVED VERY
VERY DISTRICT BILL I APPRECIATE
THOSE PEOPLE. THAT FLYING UP
FROM LOS ANGELES OR OTHER PART
OF HIS ESTATE TO CAST UPON.
I WISH MY I'M A LITTLE BIT TO
MIDDLE CLASS SIR.
.
RESIDENTS IN MY DISTRIBUTIVE BE
HERE WAS ALL OF THOSE TO
TESTIFY.
BUT THEY DO REAL GOOD RIDLEY ARE
REALLY HAVE TO WORK WELL HAVE
RECEIVED. A LOT OF LETTERS AND
PHONE CALLS AND VOTE TO
SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
THIS IS SO UNIQUE SITUATION
HERE.
YOU KNOW THOSE LAND IS ON THE
MOORS TIP OF A FINGER.
ACTUALLY IN THE CHORE FOR THAT
PICTURE.
ALL FIRST CITY OFF SOME HOSTING
FOR THE RECORD YOUR INDEX
FINGER.
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT THERE THE HIP.
RYAN THAT PICKED OF THOSE OF SAN
JOSE.
BUT THERE IS NO A THIS HUMBLE TO
ADDRESS ADJOURNS.
GOD LOVE.
PROBABLY TEN TWENTY MILES AWAY
FROM THIS THAT LIVE FEEL.
HOWEVER.
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORS.
WHO THE COULD DECIDE SANTA CLARA
AND DECIDE MILPITAS?
HOUSE.
A LOT THE ADDRESS AT THE STATE.
HAVE NO WAY OF EVEN THE TO TO TO
HAVE CLEAR VOICE HEARD ABOUT
BUILT SAID BACK FEEL. HER OF ALL
THOSE WHO THAT WATER TREATMENT
PLANT AND OF A DOLPHIN LEAD TO
SOME ISSUE WITH. BUILD BETTER
PAY AND THAT'S WELL THAT'S WHAT
THIS TAX WILL JUST IMPORTANT.
SHOWED THE CITY OF SAN JOSE THE
LEADER TRUMP'S APPEAL FELL
HOPEFULLY. BE ABLE TO HEAR WHAT
THE WHAT THE RESIDENTS IN SANTA
CLARA AND MOVE PETER I HAVE TO
SAY WHEN THE CITY WHEN THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE'S MAKING THAT
DECISION.
QUOTE THAT THE FUTURE OF BILL
FLAK FEEL.
AND AGAIN.
.
REALLY A DIFFERENT BILL WOULD
TRYING TO.
.
PICKED A PALE HOPEFULLY BE ABLE
TO.
OPENED UP WILL WASH WOULD HAVE
LIKED TO. POTS SO PUBLIC.
PASSPORTS.
WILL BE MUCH MUCH MORE WELCOMING
TO THE REST OF IT BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW.
IN THE PUBLIC PUBLICLY OF PUBLIC
MEMBER.
TO.
PHARAOH WHO.
DISCOURAGE TUBES TO PARTICIPATE.
IN TO DISCUSS SALISBURY OLDER
PASSWORD.
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S REALLY A
CLOSE.
THE WAR YOU OVER YOU KNOW THE
FOOTPATH WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS.
GOOD ADAIR MEETING.
BUT I
SO ONCE WE BAKER OF PLOTS I
PUBLIC.
I THINK WE'LL BE WOULD LOVE
REALLY WELCOMING THE PUBLIC.
COMMENT.
TO SPEAK.
TWO VERY GOOD POST STAKEHOLDER.
SO.
FACT.
PRETTY MUCH DO THE REASON BEHIND
THIS BILL BUT YOU'RE MAKING
THEM.
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE POINT THAT
YOU THINK THE PROBLEM IS A
LANDFILL AND THE LANDFILL PEOPLE
ARE THE ONES WHO'VE BEEN AT THE
TABLE THE WHOLE TIME.
THERE TO.
THE DATE THAT DEFINITELY TED
LEFT TO GO.
TRUE BILL A BIT
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF DOING THAT
THAT THE PROBLEM.
AND THAT'S WHY ONCE WE HAVE THAT
THIS WILL PROTECT BOTH HOUSE
BUILDER TASK FORCE SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN.
KNOWN AND FIGURE A. THEY
TESTIFIED DIDN'T.
THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS DROPPED
SIGNIFICANT.
SO I DO BELIEVE THIS IS THE
OPERATIONAL ISSUE. DOUBLE CAN BE
ADDRESSED.
YOU KNOW AND I'M HOPING THAT WAS
TO TASK FORCE
WE CAN'T ADDRESS TO THE
OPERATIONAL ISSUE.
THIS IS NOT TRYING TO SHUT DOWN
INNING OF THE OTHER OPERATORS.
UNION AND SILICON VALLEY WE DEAL
WITH FILCH ISSUE BEFORE. IN THE
LATE SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
WOULD FIND OUT THAT THE FREE ON.
IS REALLY REALLY BY BAD FOR THE
OLD YOU KNOW THE DEPLETION OF
VOLUME BREATH WE DIDN'T FIT INTO
ALL OUT OF SANTA CLARA.
THE WE ASKED INTEL TO ADDRESS.
GOOD GOOD YOU SHOOT TO REDUCE TO
THE USAGE OFFERING ALL OR TO
REPLACE THE WITH SOME OTHER OF
SOLVING TO CLAIM THEIR THEIR
SUBTREES.
AND ND AND NOW YOU KNOW WOULD
WE COEXIST.
AND INTEL HAS BEING A WONDERFUL.
AND CORPORATE CITIZEN IN THE
DISTRICT AND TO SPILL WITH
PRETTY MUCH ASKING. GOES LIVE DO
DOES THE.
OF LACK FEEL TO TO DO THE SAME.
AND SPIN PROVEN GOT DATE WAS
VAGUE IMPROVE OF THEIR
OPERATION.
THE NUMBER OF TO COMPLAIN
DROPPED.
FROM BILL.
TWENTY THIRTY FORTY TWO A DAY TO
MAYBE A FEEL. IN THE MONTH SO WE
SHOULD KEEP.
GOING THAT DIRECTION.
MEASURES CHAU.
THANK YOU CRAP THE REPRESENTED
FROM THE AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT.
YOU'RE THE REGULATOR.
WE ARE THE REGULATOR ALTHOUGH
NOT FOR ALL ODORS.
HERE DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
USED TO REGULATE ALL ORDERS BUT
COMPOST VOTERS WERE REMOVED
FROM.
LOCAL AIR DISTRICT AUTHORITY
PERHAPS A DOZEN YEARS AGO.
SO WE DON'T REGULATE COMPOSTING
ORDERS THAT'S THAT.
A TASK THAT IS OWNED BY THE LA
AREA OTHER ORDERS I IN THE AREA.
WE RESPOND TO ABSOLUTE RIGHT NOT
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK.
OKAY BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT MADE I
WAS LOOKING FOR SOME WHO WAS THE
REGULATOR IN THIS.
TO TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK UP AND
YOU CAME FOR HIS HAIRDRESSER CAN
YOU SAID YOU LIKE THIS.
BY.
THAT THAT.
THE ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IS IS
REALLY THAT IF YOU'RE NOT THE
REGULATOR. AND YOU'RE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS THAN THAN
WHAT IS THEIR QUALITIES
DISTRICTS ROLE.
SO WE'RE IN CHARGE OF DEALING
WITH NUISANCE ODOR COMPLAINTS
FROM ALL SOURCES.
OTHER THAN COMPOSTING HERE THE
SOURCES OF ODOROUS IN.
IN THE AREA FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
AS THE REGULATORY BODY THAT MOST
DEALS WITH NEWS AND SENATORS.
THERE'S THE LANDFILL.
THERE'S THE COMPOSTING OPERATION
THERE'S THE SORTING OF
MATERIALS.
AT THAT FACILITY.
THERE IN FACT OR THE BAY LANDS
THEMSELVES AYE ANAEROBIC
BACTERIA UNDER ANAEROBIC
CONDITIONS NOW.
THERE IS ALSO Z. WED ZERO WAYS
DOT THERE'S ANY ANAEROBIC.
ORGANICS.
FACILITY MAKING.
YEAH ARE USING ORGANICS IN AN
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION PROCESS TO
MAKE NATURAL GAS.
THERE'S.
THE THE WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANT.
CITY OF SAN JOSE SANTA CLARA
MAJOR WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANT
FOR THE SOUTH DAY. THERE'S A
PUMPING STATION IN MILPITAS
THOSE ARE ALL SOURCES OF
NUISANCE VOTERS IN THE AREA.
DEPENDING ON THE DAY AND
DEPENDING WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING
EACH OF THOSE FACILITIES.
AND AND YOU'RE THE REGULATOR FOR
SOME.
PART OF THIS BUT NOT ALL.
THAT'S TRUE INDEED
OKAY HOW HOW WOULD YOU GO ABOUT
THIS IN HIS CREATE THIS CREATION
OF THE TASK FORCE.
AN APPROPRIATE STEP.
IT IS HARD TO GET THE PARTIES TO
THE TABLE.
A THAT'S ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE'VE GOT WE GOT A. SLP
ORDER STAKEHOLDERS GROUP NOW NOT
FRANKLY IS A VERY HELPFUL THING
NAM. AS THEY BOTH REPUBLIC IN
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NOTED. OF
THE SITUATION IS IMPROVING
THAT'S A GOOD THING WE'VE SEEN
PROGRESS PRIMARILY AS A RESULT I
WOULD SUGGEST OF OPERATIONAL.
.
STEPS THAT SOME OF THE DIFFERENT
SOURCES HAVE TAKEN STEPS THAT.
I WOULD SUGGEST HAVE LARGELY
BEEN DRIVEN BY THE REGULATOR IN
THIS CASE MY AGENCY.
SO WE'VE WORKED WITH THE ODOR
SOURCES TO CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR
IS TO CUT ODORS
THE PROBLEM HOUSING GONE AWAY.
YOU'VE GOT HOUSING.
IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT NOW.
TO A LANDFILL THAT HAS BEEN
THERE FOR NOT A HUNDRED YEARS
BUT GETTING CLOSE.
HOWEVER
LIKE TO GET TO THIS MONTH SAYS
YOU DO REPRESENT THAT. THE
ELEAZER IN THIS THE CENTER THE
REGULATORS.
I TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT PATH IS I DON'T SEE
THERE'S NO TEETH IN THIS.
IF THIS GETS MOVE FORWARD.
WE'VE GOT A SITUATION WHERE.
THE SADDEST CHO DOESN'T REALLY
CHANGE.
SO.
WHO'S IN CHARGE LISTA CHAIR
THROUGH YOU TO TO TRY TO RESPOND
TO IT. IT'S PROBABLY EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COSTA PASTA
BILL AND THAT ACTUALLY CLARIFIED
THAT THE PRIMACY AGENCY IS THE
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT AGENCY THE
SOLID IN THE SOLID WASTE.
MANAGEMENT AGENCY THE AMBER THE
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH FOLKS.
AND THE REASON THAT WAS DONE IS
BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY ISSUE THE
PERMIT.
AND WHAT HAPPENED IS CLEARLY
THERE HAVE BEEN OVER OTA
PROBLEMS OVER THE YEARS.
AS WITH ANYTHING AS WITH WASTE
WATER TREATMENT OR. ABATTOIR
UNITED SLAUGHTERHOUSES SOMETHING
THERE ARE OD ISSUES.
THE ISSUE WITH THE MOLE WAS THAT
THE ED DISTRICTS HAVE EXPLICIT
AUTHORITY.
TO ADDRESS ODORS
AND THEY HAVE FINES AND
PENALTIES AUTHORITY.
ALL CONCERN WAS THE LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ACTUALLY
ISSUE THE PERMITS
AND AT THAT TIME WE CREATED THIS
PROCESS SCHOOL O. TO IMPACT MATT
AND MITIGATION PROGRAM.
AND THAT PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO
MITIGATE TO THE MAXIMUM EXTENT
POSSIBLE THOSE OTIS WE CANNOT
ELIMINATE THEM.
SO THE ISSUE AS PRIMARILY ONE OF
LAND USE
NOT OF IN ADEQUATE REGULATION BY
THE NE A OR CALORIE CYCLE OR
ANYBODY ELSE YOU GO PEOPLE
MOVING INTO A NUISANCE.
AS YOU DO ALL THE TIME.
AS YOU SQUEEZE HOUSES RIGHT UP
TO THE AGE SO YOU HAD A PRE
EXISTING LAND FULL. NOW YOU
STILL HAVE SOME.
DOES IN THE LANDFILL BUT WE
HAVE THE PLAN IN PLACE.
OUR CONCERN AS OTHERS HAVE
ARTICULATED AS YOU TRY TO
ADDRESS RECYCLING IN THE STATE.
THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION IS
GOING TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
AND IT OBFUSCATE.
IN PROCESS.
BUT THAT ANSWERS MY QUESTION AND
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR A FURTHER
RESPONSE
IT'S JUST HARD TO KNOW WHAT TO
DO.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT CHANGES
ANYTHING ON THE GROUNDS AND
MISCHA I'M I'M PREPARED TO GIVE
YOU THE BENEFIT THAT OUT HERE.
IN THE U. GONNA REALLY STRUGGLE
WITH THIS ON THE FLOOR.
BECAUSE.
IT'S ITS A SOLUTION THAT MAY
SATISFY SOME FOLKS BUT. IT'S
REALLY HARD TO KNOW WHETHER THIS
IS JUST.
CUT A SPINNING O. WE'LL AND AND
ULTIMATELY NOT REALLY. GOING TO.
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM IT'S IT'S
UP TO LOCAL REGULATORS I DON'T
OF THE COW RECYCLE THIS THE
RIGHT. PARTY TO BE DOING THIS
NECESSARILY. AND.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS IS GOING
TO GET PAID FOR ULTIMATELY
BECAUSE YOU'RE CREATING.
A PROCESS AND AND HANDING IT TO.
THE STATE AGENCY THAT'S THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE EXPECTED TO
SPEND MONEY TO TO GO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM SO IT'S.
IT IT'S A BIT OF A PICKLE THAT
THAT I DON'T.
THEY SAID WHEN YOU GET A BENEFIT
OUT HERE IN SUPPORT IT.
BUT I'M NOT SURE.
THIS IS THE RIGHT SOLUTION OR
THIS IS THE RIGHT PLACE TO BE
DOING.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WHY I THINK A WHOLE LOT
HAS BEEN SAID MORE.
.
HAS IT BEEN MOVED.
SIR MOTION I MAKE A MOTION.
THEY'RE JUST I TO JUST A QUICK
COMMENT WAS JUST THERE AND I
KNOW WE SPEND A LOT TIME ON THIS
BUT THEM.
THAT I I REALIZE THE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO LIKE CAME FROM A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITH THE
PROBLEMATIC.
WASTE FACILITY GREENWAYS AND
WE'RE GONNA TALK NEXT ABOUT HOW
WE NEED TO PERMIT MORE THOSE BUT
A LOT OF WHAT CAME ABOUT THAT IS
IN PRACTICE IN MANAGEMENT SO.
ONE OF THE HOPES THAT I THINK
HAVING THIS.
TASK FORCE
UP IN IN PLACE OF FOR YOU DOWN
THERE. THIS INTERAGENCY STATE
TASK FORCES GET THE PARTIES
TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT HOW THEY
CAN BE A MITCHELL IN MITCHELL
EXISTENCE BECAUSE IT IS THERE
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS PEOPLE LIVE
THERE AND IN THE. IN THE THERE
IS A FOCUS ON. A CO EXISTENCE
SO.
MOTIONS BEEN MADE HAS HER
SECOND.
I'LL SECOND THE MOTION.
.
MISTER CHIU.
IT'S LIKE CLOTHES.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AGAIN.
IS A VERY UNIQUE SITUATION THIS
MEDIA DIFFERENT BILL.
VOTE WOULD TO HELP THE A WATER
IS A DETRIMENT WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANT.
AND AND AND THAT AREA AND AND
THE FACT THAT THE LAND OF
MILPITAS THIS LOWERED AND THE
WATER TREATMENT PLANT. WE HAVE A
SLEW OF PUMP TO HELP TO PUMP TO
GO TO WATER SO THERE'S SO LITTLE
OF MANY MANY. OF US FORCES
FORD FOR THE FOR THE OLDER AND
TOM WERE WE'RE JUST HOPING THAT
WE CAN GET. ALL THE STAKEHOLDER
TOGETHER WILL BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THE FLOORS. AND DUMB
YOU KNOW. REPRESENTING IN THE
HEART OF SILICON VALLEY. I HAVE
A VERY OF POSITIVE ATTITUDE THAT
WE CAN'T SOLVE TWO PROBLEMS AT
THAT WOULD DEFINITELY BE WILL
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
M. MAKE.
YOU KNOW ALL THOSE THE.
AS A STAKEHOLDER ALL THOSE A
ENTITY. BEING A CO EXIST WITH
THREE X. THAT COULD EXIST IN.
.
RESIDENT I DON'T AND I'M FROM
CONTINUE TALKING WITH THE.
DO WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANT
TO SEE THAT. THOUGH TWO IF THEY
WILL.
PUT ALL DID DRYING OFF THEIR
SLUDGE IN THE ENCLOSED
ENVIRONMENT AND AND.
WOOD WORKING WITH A PLAN TO TO
IMPLEMENT A SONG OFF THEIR.
THOSE SOLVE THIS SUGGESTION
DEAR SO IS THERE'S THERE'S THIS
SPRING.
OAK A GOOD RIGHT NOW AND I'M
KINDA HOPEFUL LEADER.
BE ABLE TO.
GIVE SOME MORE PEACE TO DIS
PASSPORTS WILL BE. ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH MORE.
FOR THE LOCAL RESIDENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I.
YEAH I I I DO SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BEING OF A
PRECEDENT.
BUT I'M GONNA RESPECT YOU'RE
FIGHTING FOR YOUR CONSTITUENTS
IS THAT DISTRICT BELL AND I WAS
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
MADAM
HER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SEVEN A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY MEMBER CHIU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS THROUGHOUT TO
IF YOU ARE ROUTES RICHIE I
ACOSTA.
NO
A CUSTOM NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAO.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NO FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
THE LENDERS KNOW STONE.
STONE I.
FORTY FOUR.
CLOSE.
ARTICLE.
I DON'T THINK YOU.
ALRIGHT MINISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
NEXT BATTER UP.
THIS IS THE AB NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY THINKING COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. A AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MENTIONED
IN THE ANALYSIS.
THE CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT.
REQUIRED THE STATE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO REDUCE THE
STATEWIDE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TO NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY.
AND ENSURE THAT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ARE REDUCED BUT TO AT
LEAST FORTY PERCENT BELOW THE
NINETEEN NINETY LEVEL BY TWENTY
THIRTY. ALTHOUGH THESE GOALS ARE
ACHIEVABLE UNNECESSARY
CALIFORNIA LACKS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MEET THIS
DEMAND
ACCORDING TO AN AIR RESOURCES
BOARD PROPOSAL PUBLISHED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE STATE WILL
NEED TO CONTINUE COORDINATING
AND UTILIZING FUNDING SOURCES.
HOW TO EXPAND CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA AB
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE WILL HELP
ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOCATE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS? FROM
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND AND CLARIFY THAT ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO IMPROVE WASTE DIVERSION
RECYCLING WILL INCLUDE.
FOOD RESCUE WASTE PREVENTION AND
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING.
TO MEET THESE GOALS IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DIGESTERS ARE
COMPOSTING FACILITIES WILL NEED
TO BE BELT WITHIN FIVE TO SEVEN
YEARS.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE FOR MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
TO STRENGTHEN EXPAND AND
REINFORCE INFRASTRUCTURE
ALLOWING CALIFORNIA TO REDUCE
ITS GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
MEET ITS CLIMATE PROTECTION
GOALS.
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME MOLESTA
ROMERO FROM CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE.
THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS MUSSER
AMERO WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
WE'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOCATE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE. GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND FOR COUNTER
SICKLES PROGRAMS RECYCLING IN
GENERAL IS A PROVEN AND COST
EFFECTIVE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION STRATEGY WITH THE
POTENTIAL TO MEET MULTI.
MULTIPLE POLICY OBJECTIVES AND
SUPPORT ECONOMIC GROWTH
CALLOUSLY GOES TO EUROPE PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO
BE BOTH INCREDIBLY COST
EFFECTIVE AND SIGNIFICANTLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED. AND WE HOPE THAT
FUNDING FOR TOWER CYCLES
PROGRAMS WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THE PROJECTS FUNDED UNDER COWER
PSYCHOSES EUROPE GRANT PROGRAMS
PROVIDE MEDICAL BENEFITS AND
REALLY HELP TO FURTHER OUR WASTE
REDUCTION AND RECYCLING GOALS.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BEFORE YOU GO FURTHER
I WOULD LIKE TO.
LEAD EVERYONE THE OBVIOUS KNOW
THAT NOT ONLY IS IT THAT MOTIONS
BEEN MADE AND SECONDED BUT THIS
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
AND THAT THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
YEAH. WAS THE CHECK JUST LOAN
FOR THE COMPASS COALITION IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WE OWE IT TO
AYE VOTE.
THE CHAIRMAN JOSH PINE AND THEY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA REFUSE
RECYCLING COUNCIL WE URGE YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STEEP CARLSON THREATEN
SERVICES ARE TONIGHT UP.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRITAIN
YANNI ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION PLASTICS RECYCLERS
AND BIODEGRADABLE. OF PRODUCTS
INSTITUTE IN SPORT THANK YOU.
MEANING QUIRK COALITION FOR ANY
OF OUR NATURAL GAS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KELLY ASTRO
BE HAVE THE INLAND EMPIRE
DISPOSAL ASSOCIATION THE SOLVE
ASSOCIATION ORANGE COUNTY. AND
THE LA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATIONS.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS AARON
EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
JUST CA.GOV WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MERCILESS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA AND
SUPPORT.
MARY PILLOW ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CHUCKLE GOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MR MCCARTY A MOVE THE
BILL.
MEDI SECONDED.
NO ACTUALLY I THINK OF WHAT HAS
A VERY DON'T BE IT OKAY WELL I'M
AN INSECT SUPPORT ALL MOVING
AGAIN.
YOU KNOW I'M A CO AUTHOR I THIS
IS THIS IS A BIG DEAL WHO WANT
TO DEAL WITH ORGANICS IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S A DAUNTING TASK
A COUPLE BILLION DOLLARS IS NOT
GOING TO PENCIL OUT.
BY ITSELF SO WE NEED SOME PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION SO THIS IS A GOOD
MEASURE.
YOU FOR THE COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MR MANSION WHICH LIKE AT A THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AND AT A REDUCED
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE.
RIGHT BROKE UP PLEASE.
I AM FOR AB NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE BY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA AYE AYE
CUSTOM AYE BLOOM.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE STONE.
STONE I.
SEVEN ZERO.
DOES THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
ALRIGHT SO WE ARE NOW I BELIEVE.
DONE WITH THE SIGN IN
PRESENTATIONS AND SO WE WILL
TURN TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I BELIEVE THAT'S A STONE IS THE
ELMINSTER ACOSTA IS HERE ALSO
MICHAEL.
WE OWE YES OKAY I WARY VOTER ON
THAT SO MUCH JOHN.
.
SO EGGMAN IS FIRST ON THE AGENDA
RIGHT.
WHERE IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A
MISTAKE?
ALRIGHT.
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVE WILL MOVE THIS BUILD RIGHT
ALONG AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY SIX
WILL ESTABLISH A FORCED RECORD
IN ADDITION TO OUR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS TO BE A NEW
CHAPTER THAT FOCUSES ON.
FORESTRY WILL HAVE NEW PEOPLE
GOING IN TO BE ABLE TO GET
EDUCATED TO DO THIS KIND OF WORK
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ALRIGHT.
AND WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI.
MERRILY ECKERD OF REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS. OF.
I WANT TO OFFER OUR SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS. WITH HER OFFICE
REGARDING PROVIDING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THE CERTIFIED
LOCAL CORES AND MARK WHERE
MEMBERS AS WELL.
PAUL MAKES IT PERFECT FOR US
TRUST
I'LL IN SUPPORT.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF FOCUS OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS ON JOB
TRAINING PREPAREDNESS FOR A LOT
OF THE OTHER WAYS WE'RE GONNA
BEGIN ON THE CLIMATE CRISIS
INSTALLING SOLAR PANELS AND
WHETHER IS A SIN. THE MISMATCH
BETWEEN THE SCALE OF FOREST
RESTORATION THAT WE NEED TO DO
AND THE JOB FORCE WE HAVE READY
TO DO IT. IS REALLY SERIOUS
OVERLY PLEASED TO SEE IF SOME OF
EGGMAN OPENS BILL THANK YOU.
DEAR MEMBERS MY DILLON
REPRESENTING THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION RUNS
A GREATER VALLEY CONSERVATION
CORPS. AND OR SUPPORT AND
CONCEPT OF THE PRO.
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS THANKS VERY
MUCH
ALRIGHT THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
MISTER BECAUSE TO THEM AS
MELENDEZ.
I THINK IT WAS CHAIR ALL KEEP IT
BRIEF BECAUSE
LAKE.
YEAH THAT THAT'S TRUE.
I IS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL AYE WHY ONE OF THE NEXT
PRESS MY SUPPORT IT'S IT'S GREAT
BILL AND. MOVED SOME THINGS IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTIONS OF THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT.
THIS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
I'LL ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE HERE IN IN THE WITNESS
WHO YOU CAME FOR A THINK REALLY
DESCRIBE IT SUCCINCTLY THAT
THERE IS A DISCONNECT. BETWEEN
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PREPARED IN
THE NEEDS THAT WE HAVE.
SO GOOD JOB I'M BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BE
ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU
DON'T MIND I APPRECIATE THAT AM.
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE THE
MOTION'S BEEN MADE US OUR
SECOND.
IN FACT MAKE UP ONE BRIEF POINT
DONE JUST TO WITH ITS PEOPLE
BROUGHT UP SO IT THAT STATE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS.
.
THIS IS ABOUT HOW WE DEFINE IT
BUT WE PUT A LOT A FEEDBACK THAT
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IT SHOULD BE THE STATE
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING THAT WORK
BUT FOR THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS A LOCALS WHO WERE ALREADY
TRAINED IN DOING THAT KIND OF
WORK SO OUR PLAN IS TO BE ABLE
TO AMEND IT TO BE ABLE TO
ENCOMPASS THOSE WHO ARE DOING
THE WORK. TIE RIGHT.
AND IF CHAU TAK TAKE ISAAC
CLOTHES THAT WOULD BE ALRIGHT.
MOST OF MADE AND SECONDED THE
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS THE APPROPRIATIONS.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I AM ELEVEN AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX REMEMBER EGGMAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS OUR EFFORT
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTAHIGH
FOSTER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIMON.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE STONE.
STONE I.
EIGHT ZERO.
PAGE ZERO BELLOWS OUT.
NUMBER THIRTEEN MR BLOOM MAYBE
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
NINE
.
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SO LET ME START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL. CLOTHING MADE
FROM SYNTHETIC FABRICS DOMINATE
CLOTHING INDUSTRY AND AS A
RESULT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
REGULARLY WASH CLOTHES MADE OF
SYNTHETIC MATERIAL.
SENSE IN FACT SIXTY PERCENT OF
FABRIC PRODUCED IN THE TEXTILE
INDUSTRY IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
CONTAINED POLYESTER ON IT NO
DOUBT IS ONLY GROWN SINCE THEN.
NOW A OF WHY IS IS A PROBLEM.
WILL LET'S USE POLYESTER FLEECE
IS AN EXAMPLE EVERY TIME A
FLEECE JACKET IS WASHED. IT
RELEASES HUNDREDS PERHAPS
THOUSANDS OF FIBERS INTO THE
WATER AND THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC
RELEASED BY THE LAUNDERING OF
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND FLEECE
JACKETS. IS EQUIVALENT TO UP TO.
ELEVEN THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
PLASTIC GROCERY BAGS ACCORDING
TO A STUDY FROM THE UC SANTA
BARBARA BRENT SCHOOL OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE AND
MANAGEMENT. THIS IS A STUDY THAT
WAS COMMISSIONED BY PATAGONIA IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
AND STANDARD WASHING MACHINES
DON'T HAVE FILTERS TO CATCH
THESE FIBERS.
AND SO ONCE THEY ESCAPE FROM OUR
LAUNDRY AT THE TINY MOBILE
THREADS WORK THEIR WAY INTO OUR
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS.
AND THE SCREENING IN THOSE
PLANTS IS TOO BIG TO CONTAIN
THEM AND SO THEY GO OUT INTO THE
OCEANS AND OUR WATER SUPPLY.
OTHER POLYESTER FABRICS HAVE
SIMILAR CHARACTERISTICS AND IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE UNIVERSITY
OF MICHIGAN LOOKED AT THE GREAT
LAKES ORIGINALLY FOR PLASTIC
MICROBEADS CONTAMINATION. BUT
FOUND THAT THE MAJORITY OF
MICHAEL PLASTICS RELEASED BY
TREATMENT PLANTS IN A WERE BEING
RELEASED BY TREATMENT PLANTS
INTO THE GREAT LAKES.
TRIBUTARIES.
AND OF THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
MICRO PLASTICS ARE PLASTIC
FIBERS FROM CLOTHING.
RIGHT NOW IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
SYNTHETIC FIBERS ARE BY COUNT
THE SINGLE LARGEST CONTRIBUTED A
WATERSHED PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
DEVELOPED COUNTRIES AND ACCOUNT
FOR A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
PLASTIC WASTE ENTERING THE
OCEAN.
WE DON'T KNOW YET THE EXTENT TO
WHICH MICROPOLITAN POLLUTION
MIGHT AFFECT HUMANS WE DO
HOWEVER KNOW THAT MANY ANIMALS
WITH THE IN. THE AQUATIC FOOD
CHAIN INGEST THESE PLASTICS AND
THE TOXICS THEY ABSORB FROM THE
WATER AROUND THEM. AND THIS CAN
TRANSFER TO THEIR TISSUE AND
BECAUSE GOD IMPACTION HORMONE
DISRUPTION AND LIVER DAMAGE
MEANING WE ARE ALSO INGESTING
PLASTIC MICRO FIBERS FROM THE
FOOD WE EAT. AND THE WATER WE
DRINK.
UC DAVIS SAMPLED FISH AND
SHELLFISH SOLD LOCAL CALIFORNIA
FISH MARKETS AND FOUND ONE
QUARTER OF THE FISH AND ONE
THIRD OF THE SHELLFISH. CONTAIN
PLASTIC DEBRIS.
INTERNALLY.
A MAJORITY OF THE PLASTIC DEBRIS
FOUND IN FISH SAMPLES.
WE'RE MICROFIBER.
WELL ALL PLASTIC DEBRIS FOUND IN
THE SHELLFISH
SAMPLED WERE WITH MICROFIBER SO.
WERE MICROFIBER.
SIMILARLY A SURVEY COMPARED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TAP WATER
SAMPLES FROM LOCATIONS IN FIVE
DIFFERENT CONTINENTS.
AND MICROPOLITAN FIBERS WERE
FOUND IN NEARLY EVERY SAMPLE.
THE SURVEY ALSO FOUND THAT
NINETY FOUR PERCENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WATER SAMPLES
CONTAIN PLASTIC MICRO FIBERS.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE STARTING TO
FIND EVEN BOTTLED WATER
CONTAMINATED WITH MICROFIBER IS.
AND THERE ARE STUDIES THAT ARE.
.
OF BEING RELEASED ON A REGULAR
BASIS NOW THEY'RE SHOWING EVEN
BROADER RELEASES A PLASTIC MICRO
FIBERS BECAUSE WERE REALLY JUST
STARTING TO LOOK CLOSELY AT THIS
ISSUE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE
REQUIRES THE CLOTHES.
REAL SHOULD BEAR TWO LABELS ONE
THAT ADDS INFORMATION ON THE
EXISTING CARE LABEL AND A CAN.
BANK ACCOUNT OR ANOTHER LABEL
THAT INCLUDES INFORMATION
REGARDING.
HOW TO WASH AND HAVE CARE FOR
THESE PRODUCTS?
THE LABEL WILL NOT REQUIRE A
MANUFACTURER TO INCLUDE ANY
INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE IN
CONFLICT WITH WHAT IS REQUIRED
BY FEDERAL LAW.
AND AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE
I SHOULD POINT OUT IS NOT A BAN.
IT'S SIMPLY AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP THAT HOLDS COUNTIES THE
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
WASTE THAT THEIR PRODUCTS
CREATE.
THAT EDUCATES THE PUBLIC AND
THAT KEEPS THE PRESSURE ON
MANUFACTURERS TO FIND WHAT WE
NEED TO HAVE AND THAT IS A
LASTING SOLUTION.
SO. THIS IS A PRAGMATIC APPROACH
TO TACKLING A COMPLICATED ISSUE.
AND I LEAVE YOU WITH THIS.
ACCORDING TO THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION FOR CONSERVATION OF
NATURE.
TWO THIRDS OF THE PLAT OF THE
MICRO PLASTIC RELEASED INTO THE
WORLD'S OCEANS.
ARE DUE TO THE WASHING OF
SYNTHETIC TEXTILES.
AND IF WE WAIT TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT WILL ONLY
GET WORSE.
WE THIS IS REALLY AN ISSUE WHERE
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE POLLUTION
AT THE SOURCE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE
EMPOWERS CONSUMER WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
HELP THEM TAKE RESPONSIBLE
ACTION AS INDIVIDUALS I HAVE
THREE WITNESSES WITH ME HERE. IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME ALL OF THEM
TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
AND I THANK YOU FOR
AND I VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MARTUCCI
HONORABLE MEMBERS
I AM SHALL BE CHAU TRAY
REPRESENTING THE BREAK FREE FROM
PLASTIC GLOBAL MOVEMENT. WE
REPRESENT ELEVEN HUNDRED NGOS
WORKING ACROSS THE GLOBE THAT
ARE COMMITTED TO STOPPING
PLASTIC POLLUTION FROM
EXTRACTION TO DISPOSAL.
THE MOVEMENT IS INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED WITH THE THREAT OF
MICRO PLASTIC POLLUTION
MICROFIBER IS ARE KNOWN TO BE
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION IN OUR
WATERWAYS.
THEY ARE IN THE FOOD WE EAT THE
AIR WE BREATHE. AND ACROSS THE
GLOBE.
WE KNOW FROM STUDIES CONDUCTED
BY THE CLOTHING INDUSTRY ITSELF
THAT SYNTHETIC FIBERS SHAD
PERSISTENT MATERIALS INTO OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
INDUSTRY ALSO ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THIS IS A PROBLEM. THE MOVEMENT
FEELS VERY SIR UP STRONGLY
ABOUT.
CITIZENS SHOULD BE INFORMED THAT
THE CLOTHING THEY BUY HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO POLLUTE OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
THE FIRST STEP IS KNOWLEDGE AB
TWO THREE SEVEN NINE DOES JUST
THAT.
SOME OF PROPOSED THAT WE FILTER
WASHING MACHINE AFFLUENT. THERE
ARE A HUNDRED IN THREE MILLION
WASHING MACHINES IN THE U. S.
THE SIMPLY WILL NOT WORK.
THE DISCUSSION SHOULD NOT BE HOW
MUCH OR HOW LITTLE A GIVEN
FABRIC FLUTES IT SHOULD BE ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO STOP IT.
ON BEHALF OF THE BREAK FREE FROM
PLASTIC GLOBAL MOVEMENT. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TWO THREE SEVEN NINE THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JUST
AGOG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES WE REPRESENT ALL THE
MAJOR WASTE WATER TREATMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY NINE.
A MICROFIBER AND MAKE A PLASTIC
POLLUTION IS A SUBJECT THAT'S
BEEN GENERATING.
SOME SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
INTEREST LATELY AND OUR MEMBERS
ARE PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION. AND
VARIOUS RESEARCH EFFORTS
RELATING TO MICRO PLASTICS HAVE
BEEN INDUCED INITIATED IN RECENT
YEARS INCLUDING.
SOME BEING DONE IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE WASTE WATER COMMUNITY
AND THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS FOR MICRO FIBERS TO
ENTER THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
WASHING MACHINE AFFLUENT IS.
A CLEARLY IDENTIFIABLE SOURCE.
OF TREATMENT PLANTS ARE JUST NOT
ALWAYS ABLE TO FILTER OUT MICRO
FIBERS AND IN CASES WHERE. THEY
CAN FILTER FOR MICRO FIBERS AND
THEY REALLY ARE JUST BEING
TRANSFERRED TO ADDRESS A
DIFFERENT WASTE STREAM THOUGH
THEY STILL TIMIDLY AND UP IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. SO FOR THESE
REASONS AND WE'VE BEEN ACTIVELY
ADVOCATING FOR SOURCE CONTROL
AS.
THE BEST SOLUTION FOR DEALING
WITH.
MAKER PLASTIC POLLUTION AND WE
THINK AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
NINE PROMOTE SOURCE CONTROL AND
CONSUMER AWARENESS OF THE ISSUE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD
URGE YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OR ITS ITCHY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CRAIG CADWALLADER AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION AND.
.
I AGREE WITH ALL THE STATEMENTS
MADE PREVIOUS TO US WE ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED WITH PLASTIC
CENTER IN ARENA OUR ENVIRONMENT
AND WE. THINK THE CORRECT
APPROACH TO THIS IS TO CONTROL
IT AT THAT SOURCE.
AND.
IF ANYONE'S IT YOU KNOW THAT MY
EXPERIENCE WITH DOING WELL
WATCHING OF THE. FABRICS IS YOU
KNOW STUFF IS GOING DOWN THE
DRAIN BUT.
YOU CAN TELL BY WHAT'S LEFT
OVER THAT SEE IN THE LENT
TRAPPED IN YOUR DRYER. SO THAT'S
AN INDICATION OF THE AMOUNT OF.
FIBERS THAT ARE GETTING OUT INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT WE WOULD HOPE
THAT WE COULD HELP EDUCATE THE
CONSUMERS AND.
CREATE A BETTER AWARENESS OF
THIS ISSUE MANY. FOLKS ARE NOT
AWARE OF THE ISSUE OF LE MICRO
FIBERS AND THAT IT'S GETTING
INTO OUR ENVIRONMENT IT'S
GETTING INTO WILDLIFE. AND
GETTING INTO US AND AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED IT'S AN TAP WATER IT'S
IN BOTTLED WATER IT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED BASICALLY JUST
VIRTUALLY EVERYWHERE SO WE WOULD
HOPE THAT. NO.
.
WE'RE ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS MATTER AND HOPE THAT WE
COULD HELP EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
AND BRING THEM ON. AS.
A POTENTIAL SOURCE TO HELP
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU MELISSA ROMERO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL AND JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK
ON THIS ISSUE.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION A COALITION OF ELEVEN
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
SURFRIDER AND HEAL THE BAY. WHO
ARE DEDICATED KEEPING PLASTIC
POLLUTION OUT OF OUR WATERWAYS
AND OCEANS AND STRONG SUPPORT
AND I WAS ASKED BY TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND TO? SEND THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL THINKING.
TERESA BURKETT PITCH ON BEHALF
OF HARD I'LL IN OYSTER FRIENDS.
I JUST WHEN DAD DIED THESE
MICRO FIBERS.
JEOPARDIZE A.
INDUSTRY THAT CONTRIBUTES
TWENTY THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
TO THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND
BECAUSE OF THIS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
AND ONLY SERVER O. DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
ONE OF THE MEAT ON ON BEHALF OF
LAWSUIT TRANSIT STRUCK SUPPORT.
DOW JONES WAS THERE COULD
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
I MEAN TO OUR BEHALF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO SUPPORT
THINKING.
I MISTER JAY WILL SEN.
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF FROM THE
STORY OF STUFF PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS.
JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN LONG FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY
WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT.
OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES.
AFTERNOON WHICH CARE MARGARET
LATCHING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE UP CHADLI IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S CONCERN.
AND THE ATTENTION HE'S
PROPOSITIONS. WE DON'T SEE
MANDATORY HANDWASHING LABELS AS
THE APPROPRIATE SOLUTION FIRST
AND FOREMOST WE THINK THAT
CONSUMERS WILL LARGELY IGNORED
THIS ADVICE.
BUSY WORKING FAMILIES ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE TIME TO HAND
WASH THEIR CHILDREN'S CLOTHES
THEIR WORK OUT WHERE. WERE.
THEIR UNIFORMS THAT THEY NEED
TO GO TO WORK PERHAPS AND
MEDICAL ENVIRONMENT OR SOME
OTHER PLACE WE JUST DON'T THINK
THAT'S A REALISTIC SOLUTION. OF
THIS COMMITTEE JUST SPENT A FEW
MINUTES DISCUSSING AN ODOR
PROBLEM WE THINK THIS MIGHT
CREATE ANOTHER ODOR PROBLEM IF
EVERYBODY WERE ACTUALLY HAND
WASHING.
I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT.
FROM AN ENVIRONMENTAL
PERSPECTIVE HE AND WASHING
ACTUALLY UTILIZES MORE WATER AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS COMMITTEE SPENDS
A LOT OF TIME ENERGY AND EFFORT
FOCUSING ON THE NEED TO PRESERVE
WATER AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO. MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE SO WE DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION FOR THAT
REASON ALSO.
I CALIFORNIA OVER ONLY LABEL
WILL DEFINITELY INCREASE COSTS
FOR MANUFACTURING.
BECAUSE WE'LL HAVE TO DO A
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC LABEL ON
THAT IN TURN WILL INCREASE THE
COST FOR FOR RETAILERS AND FOR
CONSUMERS WHO OFTEN CHOOSE
SYNTHETIC PRODUCTS BECAUSE THEY
ARE LESS EXPENSIVE. THAN WOOL
SILK OR COTTON AND THE CARE IS
ACTUALLY EASIER TO RETHINK
THAT'S ANOTHER BURDEN ON
CONSUMERS THAT THIS BILL PLACES.
FINALLY WE THINK THIS BILL IS
PREMATURE THE AUTHOR DID STATE
ONE STUDY FROM THE BURNS SCHOOL
OF ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCES AT YOU
SEE S. B. BUT WE ALSO KNOW OF
ANOTHER AND THE. DAY THAT BROWN
SCHOOL AND OCEAN CONSERVANCY
ESTABLISHED A MICROFIBER
LEADERSHIP SUMMIT LAST OCTOBER
THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
A VARIETY OF. KNOWLEDGE GAPS IN
TERMS OF WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
WHAT THE REAL SOURCES OF
MICROFIBER POLLUTION ARE THEY
POINTED TO TOILETRIES WHICH IS
COMMITTEE HAS. ADDRESSED TO SOME
EXTENT.
UPHOLSTERY CARPETING AND OTHER
CONTRIBUTORS AS PART OF THE
PROBLEM AND THEY ALSO IDENTIFIED
THAT THE SOLUTION. IS NOT KNOWN
AT THIS TIME BUT THEY'RE WORKING
ON IDENTIFYING THE SOLUTION AND
MAKING SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO WE CURRENTLY DON'T THINK THAT
HAND WASHING IS THE APPROPRIATE
SOLUTION AND.
THE LABELING PUTS A GREAT DEAL
OF BURDEN.
AND LIABILITY ON CALIFORNIA
RETAILER SO FOR THAT REASON WE
MUST OPPOSE.
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING US
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY ON
BILL TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE
MY NAME IS KRISTEN CURRENT I'M A
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE AMERICAN
APPAREL FOOTWEAR ASSOCIATION
WE'RE A TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING APPAREL AND
FOOTWEAR TRAVEL GOODS AND OTHER
SEWN PRODUCTS COMPANIES.
I AGREE WITH THE PREVIOUS
STATEMENTS AND I JUST WANNA ADD
ON LABELING AS A SOLUTION.
INDUSTRIES CURRENTLY ENGAGING
ON THIS ISSUE AND.
WE DON'T DISAGREE THAT
MICROFIBER POLLUTION.
DOES EXIST AND IS AN ISSUE IN
THIS COMMUNITY BUT WE. WANT TO
SPEAK TO LABELING. IS NOT THE
SOLUTION IN THIS CASE.
GARMENTS CONVEY AN EXTENSIVE
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION ALREADY
PER FEDERAL LAW.
ON FIBER CONTENT CARE
INSTRUCTIONS COUNTRY OF ORIGIN
AND NUMBER OF OTHER PIECES OF
INFORMATION SO. FURTHER LABELING
IN THIS CASE IS IT'S JUST
REDUNDANT.
AND REALLY WOULD BE LOST IN THE
INFORMATION THAT IT'S ALREADY
MANDATED ON THOSE LABELS SO AT
BEST CONSUMERS WOULD SIMPLY
IGNORE THE INFORMATION ON THE
LABEL AND AT WORST IT WOULD
CAUSE CONFUSION OR HARM IF
CONSUMERS AND IT UP CARING FOR
THEIR GARMENTS IN A WAY THAT
DAMAGED THEIR. CLOTHING.
MOREOVER BECAUSE FEDERAL CARE
INSTRUCTIONS EXPLICITLY REQUIRE
THE PROVISION OF THE BEST METHOD
OF REFERS BANISHMENT OF A
GOVERNMENT. THAT AVOID DAMAGE TO
THE GOVERNMENT A STATE BASED
CARE INSTRUCTION THAT LED TO
THIS OUTCOME. WOULD CONFLICT
WITH FEDERAL LAW AND FILL ON
FEDERAL PREEMPTION GROUNDS
SO ADDITIONALLY WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE.
AND SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH ON
SOLUTIONS TO MICRO FIBER
POLLUTION A PRESCRIBED LABEL OR
SIMILAR REGULATORY OUTCOME.
WOULDN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND
AN ABSENCE OF THIS DATA THE
MANDATED LABELING ALMOST SURELY
FAILS THEM COMPELLED SPEECH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
ON CAP KEY MCCUE CAPTAINED
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
REGRETFULLY OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE.
ULTIMATELY I SEEM CA REALLY
CLEARLY.
NOTES THAT THE REAL QUESTION IS
WHETHER REQUIRING A LABEL ON THE
SYNTHETIC FABRICS I AM
ULTIMATELY IS A REASONABLE AND
EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
MICROFIBER IS ENTERING. INTO
AQUATIC ENVIRONMENT AND WHETHER
CONSUMERS WILL OF ACTUALLY ABIDE
BY LABELS TO THAT AND.
RELATIVE TO THE CONVENIENCE
FACTOR THAT MANY CONSUMERS ARE
REALLY FAST FOCUSED ON FOR THEIR
BUSY LIVES.
NOTABLY VIRTUALLY ALL FABRIC
SYNTHETIC OR NATIONAL TO SHED IN
SOME LEVEL AND THE APPROACH
ADDRESSING MICRO FIBERS IN
TRAINING ENVIRONMENT AS PROPOSED
BY AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE.
IS NOT WITHOUT ITS TRADE OFFS AS
WAS MENTIONED BY MY PRIOR I'D HA
OPPONENT COLLEAGUES RELATIVE TO
HAND WASHING. NOT SPECIFICALLY
ELIMINATING MICRO FIBERS IN LAW
THE WATERWAYS NOT TO MENTION
ABOUT TIED THE ISSUES AROUND
WATER EFFICIENCY AND THE FACT
THAT MACHINE WASHING IS ACTUALLY
MUCH MORE EFFICIENT WHEN IT
COMES TO. A WASHINGTON ARTICLES
OF CLOTHING FOR WATER I HAD
EFFICIENCY PURPOSES ON AND AS
WAS NOTED BRIEFLY AYE RELATIVE
TO CONCERNS ABOUT. A
PROFESSIONALS LIKE LAW
ENFORCEMENT MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WHO WEAR UNIFORMS THAT
ARE MADE A VERY DURABLE
SYNTHETIC FABRICS AND THE
CONCERN ABOUT WHETHER HAND
WASHING IS SUFFICIENT TO REMOVE.
THOSE AYE SOILED AYE INCOME AND
ARE PIECES OF FABRIC FURTHER FOR
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS WHETHER
THAT SUFFICIENT IN HAND WASHING
TO SUFFICIENTLY SANITIZE THOSE
ARTICLES OF CLOTHING AS WELL IN
THOSE ENVIRONMENTS.
AND FINALLY IN IN THE INTEREST
OF SUSTAINABILITY AND CRADLE TO
CRADLE PRACTICES MANY CLOTHING
MANUFACTURERS ARE USING
UTILIZING MORE AND MORE RECYCLED
FABRICS LIKE POLYESTER IN THEIR
CLOSING CLOTHING MANUFACTURING.
SUCH EFFORTS FROM C. MTA'S
PERSPECTIVE SHOULD BE LAUDED NOT
CONSTRICTED WITH ADDITIONAL
BURDENS AND BACKLASH AS LIKE
LABELING REQUIREMENTS ON
MANUFACTURES THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL NOT SERVE THE INTENDED AND
AND.
PURPOSE OF THE BILL SO FOR
THESE REASONS UNFORTUNATELY WE
DO OPPOSE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY NINE I REALLY WOULD
ENCOURAGE US SO I TO TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT SOME OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES BEING DEVELOPED.
OTHER WOULD ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE
SITUATION AND AND HELP US GET US
FURTHER ALONG IN TERMS OF
MICHAEL FIBERS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THESE REASONS
WERE POSTING HERE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU BEFORE WE.
GET TO MS EDMUNDS QUESTION IF WE
CAN JUST OKAY.
.
FOR THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MADISON
Y. ON BEHALF THE RETAIL INDUSTRY
LEADERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ADAM RIGHTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS JOE ACT LEARNED
BEHALF THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THOSE.
ALRIGHT MS EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
COMMISSION BLOOM FOR FOR THIS
BILL.
.
I'M I'VE BEEN CALLING A
DELIBERATE AGAINST BILL.
WHERE THAT WE ONLY HAVE NATURAL
FIBERS?
?
SO AYE SO YOU AND I AND MR STONE
AND MISS MELINDA'S I THINK WERE
SOME OF THE FIRST PEOPLE WHO GOT
HERE IN THIS THIS NEW CLASS OF
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND IF
THERE'S ONE THING WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF TIMES IT'S THINGS ON
SCOPE. AND THINGS ON LABELING
REPEATEDLY.
I THINK ARTIE SHAW I WON'T BE
ABLE SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY FOR
THAT ONE OF THOSE VERY RECENT
ONE I DON'T THINK WE HAVE THAT
THE DATA YET. I THINK IS A LOT
OF THINGS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS.
I REPRESENT WITH A VERY POOR
ECONOMY AND A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD. PURE SILK PURE COTTON OR
PURE.
WALL ME SO THAT'S AN ISSUE. SO
THEM WERE ALSO TELLING PEOPLE IS
WHAT WE PUT ON THE LABELS
DOESN'T REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE WE WE VERY. VERY CAREFUL
BUT WE PUT ON LABELS AND WHEN WE
PUT SOMETHING ON LABELS. WE'RE
BASICALLY TELLING PEOPLE TO HAND
OR SOMETHING AND WE KNOW THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO DO IT BECAUSE
SOMEDAY WITH BY PIDS. IS NED
POTTER DOESN'T HAVE THE SPACE TO
BUILD A HAND WASH EVERYBODY'S
CLOTHES.
ESPECIALLY IF WE DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
AND THEN FINALLY ASSEMBLY WHO
REPRESENTS THE DELTA AREA AND AS
WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH NOT
HAVING ENOUGH WATER.
AND UC SANTA BARBARA STUDY
CLEARLY SAYS WASHING THINGS BY
HAND TAKES A LOT MORE WATER THAN
THE WASHING MACHINES SO I THINK
YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING REALLY
INTERESTING.
BUT I DON'T THINK WE'RE THAT
WHITE BOY I DON'T THINK I KNOW
I'M NOT THERE YET. TOM KNOWS WE
BEFORE IT'LL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW THE SOLUTIONS THAT YOU
COME UP WITH THANK YOU.
NEAR THERE A.
COMMENTS MUSLIM THANK YOU. I
THINK YOU I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND I TOO
AM VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE BRAND
SCHOOL ON THE WORK THAT THE
DEAL.
AND AND A LITTLE SLIGHTLY TRUST
ACTUALLY WASH A LOT OF THINGS
AND HAND WASH.
BECAUSE THE LABEL SAYS TO AND
SO I PAY ATTENTION TO THE LABEL.
AND IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME AND
I THINK MY CONCERN IS THE IS THE
LONG TERM. AND THE A OF AND
KNOWING THAT IT'S NOT AS WATER
EFFICIENT THAT TOO. AT WASH
THINGS BY HAND BUT I DO THINK
THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND I THINK THAT
THIS.
IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR OUR WATER SOURCES.
AND HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS TO S.
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
I AGES.
I WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE BRANDS REPORT AND STUDY IS
SOMETHING THAT I IS. INTERESTING
TO ME IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M
PAYING ATTENTION TO YOU AND I'M
TRYING TO GRAPPLE BETWEEN THE
INTERSECTION OF DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT.
YOU KNOW FOR THE WATER IN
TAKING THESE MEGA FARMERS OUT OR
REDUCING NOT TAKEN OUT REDUCING
THEM I'M FROM GOING INTO THE
WATER WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE ONE
ALTERNATIVE THAT WE SEE RIGHT
NOW. IS NOT.
IT HAS A DIFFERENT KIND OF I'M.
IMPACT ON THE NEED LIKE TO SEE
IT BUT I DO THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO
AFFORD.
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU UP TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND IN
WITH ALL RESPECT I WILL BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL EITHER A BUT
I I THINK.
MUCH ALONG THE SAME LINES.
HE AYE AYE AND REALLY STRUGGLING
WITH.
THE NARRATIVE IN HERE IN THE
COMMENTS THAT ARE YOU KNOW KIND
OF FRIGHTENING IN ORDER WERE ALL
JESSE PLASTICS ALL THE SAME I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND. AND EVEN IF
I AGREE WITH THAT. I'M JUST NOT
SURE OF HOW PRACTICAL.
THIS IS GOING TO BE ON A DAILY
THEY BASIS FOR. THE YOU KNOW THE
AVERAGE.
YOU KNOW THE WORKING FAMILY
COMMUTERS
IN MY DISTRICT
WHO RUSH HOME FROM SOCCER
PRACTICE AND BOTH PARENTS
WORKING AND RUN AND. AND I JUST.
AS AN ASIDE ARE.
THIRTY YEAR OLD.
SUPER DEPENDABLE TOP LOADING.
ONE NAME THE BRAND BUT IT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER.
FINALLY DIED TOP LOADING
WASHING MACHINE AND I WENT OUT
AND AND I'M LOOKING IT CAN GET
ALL THESE REPORTS AND RATINGS
AND.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALL A JILLION
DOLLARS RIGHT AND I ENDED UP
WITH THIS VERY.
CAN HIGH AND ON SALE. PRETTY
IN A GOOD WITH THAT.
.
WELL A VERY ENERGY EFFICIENT AND
VERY LOW WATER USAGE
WHAT TOP LOADING WASHING MACHINE
I MEAN IT USES LIKE THIS MUCH
WATER AND WATER FALLS IN ALL
THIS GREAT STUFF. AND YOU DON'T
EVEN THINK IT'S WORKING.
UNTIL YEAR CLOSE OUT BECAUSE YOU
CAN HEAR IT IN ITS TURN ALL THIS
CRAZY STUFF. AND HAS A HAND
WASHING FUNCTION ON THEIR.
AND THAT AND I THINK
I WONDER FREELY CONFUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WITH NO HAND WASH ONLY
GONNA PUSH THE HAND WASHING BUT
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO BE CUTE I
I JUST. DON'T SEE PEOPLE BRING
IT THE BEING THAT PRACTICAL
ALONG WITH ALL THE OTHER THINGS.
THE PRACTICAL SIDE OF THINGS IS
IS IT GONNA RUN AFOUL OF FEDERAL
LAW AND I AND I REALLY AM
CONCERNED WITH IT LIVING IN AN
AREA AS WE DO IT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THE WATER EVEN IF WE
DID IT.
I'M JUST A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT THE ALL RESPECT I I THINK.
TO THEM.
HIT ME ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
EGGMAN'S POINT HERE ON THE
SOMETHING I JUST THINK WE NEED
TO FLUSH A SUBTLE ABOUT MORBID
BUT THANK YOU FOR BERGEN THE
BILL.
SO MISTER BLOOM BY.
.
APPRECIATE. YOUR GOAL OF OF OF
YOUR BILL I MEAN CLEARLY PLUS
THE POLLUTION IS A CRISIS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU RAISE THE
IMPORTANT POINTS ABOUT HOW THESE
MICRO FIBERS ARE ENDING UP IN
OUR WATER SUPPLY IN OUR FOOD
SUPPLY.
.
AND.
THE PUBLIC NEEDS TO BE EDUCATED
I HAD TO BE EDUCATED. ABOUT THE.
MEGA FIBERS AND DATA AND EXTENT
OF THE PROBLEM AND SO. I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL I WILL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL.
.
AND.
YES WHICH LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR.
.
COMMENTS.
A THIS IS CLEARLY A PROBLEM
STUDIES ARE A CONSISTENT IN
IDENTIFYING PLASTIC MICRO FIBERS
IN THE WATER SUPPLY AS A AS A
PROBLEM. IT'S A PROBLEM THAT'S
GOING TO BE COME CRISIS IF IT
GOES UNADDRESSED.
AND.
WE ARE SIMPLY TALKING ABOUT
LABELS HERE AND PIECES OF PAPER
THAT WILL INFORM THE PUBLIC
ABOUT AN ISSUE AND GIVE THEM
OPTIONS.
DOESN'T MANDATE ANYBODY TO DO
ANYTHING.
I.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT.
HOW OFTEN WE WASH CLOTHES WELL
AND AND DEREK AND USING TOO MUCH
WATER THAT'S A PERFECTLY GOOD
EXAMPLE BECAUSE I THINK IN MANY
INSTANCES WE PROBABLY ALREADY
WASHED THINGS TOO FREQUENTLY?
MANY OF THE FLEECE GARMENTS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR OUTER
GARMENTS THAT AT LEAST IN MY
EXPERIENCE AND I DON'T SMELL
RELEASED I HAVEN'T HAD
COMPLAINTS ABOUT IT. UP I DON'T
I DON'T WASH THEM EVERY TIME I I
WEAR THEM.
I WEAR A JACKET I TAKE IT OFF I
HANG IT IN THE CLOSET AND I YOU
KNOW EVERY FEW WARING'S THAT'S
WHEN IT GETS WASHED.
OF THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
PUBLIC DESERVES TO KNOW ABOUT.
AND NEEDS TO KNOW ABOUT SO THAT
WE CAN BEGIN TO ADAPT OUR
BEHAVIOR TO THE REALITY OF THIS
KIND OF PLASTIC POLLUTION.
OF THERE'S A LOT MORE WE COULD
BE TALKING ABOUT ON THIS ISSUE
AND IT IS A CONVERSATION THAT
NEEDS TO MOVE FORWARD IT NEEDS
TO BE HELD PUBLICLY I THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO DISCUSS IT HERE THIS EVENING
BUT I KNOW THE HOURS RUNNING
LATE AND SO I WILL SIMPLY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DERIVA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
WELL ACTUALLY I.
IS OUR MOTION FOR.
THE BILL.
THEN MOVED.
SECOND.
BROKE UP.
I AM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY NINE BY MEMBERS BLOOM
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THEM VERY MENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS SMART SEARCHING AYE
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NO BLOOM. BY BLOOM I'VE
CHILD.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NO FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
NO STONE.
STONE I.
FIVE FOUR.
BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
MS WE MARIN.
YOU HAVE.
TWO BILLS.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB NINETEEN
FIFTY SIX.
AND.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR
.
I THINK YOU. MISS.
SO YOU THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT I WANTED TO START
OFF BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
AND THINKING.
YOU IS A CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING HARD
ON ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE SEASON WAS THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND COSTLY AND
RECORD.
WHETHER SCIENTISTS HAVE WARNED
THAT THE INCREASED FREQUENCY AND
INTENSITY OF LARGE WILDFIRES IS
DUE TO THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. EXCESSIVE WILDFIRES
DESTROYS HOMES EXPOSES SLOPES TO
EROSION AND LAND LANDSLIDES
THREATENS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CAUSES ECONOMIC DOC DAMAGE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX DIRECTS
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE THE SCALE
AND PACE OF FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES TO ENSURE THOSE
ACTIVITIES HAPPEN YEAR ROUND THE
BILL ALSO RE ESTABLISHES A FIRE
PREVENTION WORKING GROUP. AND
CREATE A ROBUST YEAR ROUND FIRE
PREVENTION LOCAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT PROGRAM AB NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX IS NEEDED TO RE ORIENT
CALIFORNIA TO THE REALITY OF THE
YEAR ROUND FIRE SEASON AND TO
MAKE TARGETED INVESTMENTS INTO
LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN PREVENTING FUTURE FIRES
SINCE. I'M FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THE RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT TO AND THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TERRY HEARTY
AND THE ACTING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE LITTLE COOPER
COMMISSION A BIPARTISAN
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT AGENCY
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME TALK TO
YOU ABOUT THIS CRITICAL TOPIC.
IN FEBRUARY ARE COMMISSION
ISSUED A REPORT CALLING FOR THE
DRAMATIC CULTURE CHANGE IN THE
WAY FORESTS ARE MANAGED IN ORDER
TO PROTECT OUR AIR. OUR WATER
AND COOK THE CATASTROPHIC CYCLE
OF DEVASTATING WILD WILD FIRES
AND TREAT DEATHS.
OUR REPORT THINKS NINE
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDING THE
NEED FOR COLLABORATION.
UTILIZING PRESCRIBED FIRE.
DEALING WITH DEAD TREES IN A WAY
THAT PROMOTES ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND EDUCATING PUBLIC REPUBLICAN
WHY FORCE MATTER.
DURING OUR SITE VISITS WE'VE
LEARNED THAT A REGIONAL APPROACH
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT ALONG WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL APPROACHES.
AND WE ALSO SAW THAT EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN ORDER. TO BRING IN
BY AND ON THESE FORCE MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE REALLY.
CRUCIAL FOR OUR STATE.
SO BECAUSE A. B..
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
HELPS IMPLEMENT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION RECOMMENDS AND
I FELT.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ
FORCED BURKE AND I AM ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS IN
POLICY THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
WE ARE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX.
WE WOULD LIKE WITH A FAKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE MOAN AND HER
STAFF ON THEIR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BILL.
INTO DOESN'T SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE THE WORST
WILDFIRES IN ITS HISTORY.
WITH THE TRAGIC LOSS OF LIFE AND
DEVASTATION TO COMMUNITIES IT
WAS ALSO THE MOST EXPENSIVE FIRE
SEASON YET.
WILDFIRES CONTINUE TO GET LARGER
HOTTER AND MORE DESTRUCTIVE
THREATENING NOT ONLY LIVES IN
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO SERIOUSLY
DAMAGING AIR QUALITY. WATER
QUALITY AND RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES WHAT THE SAME TIME
RELEASING ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES.
MORE RESEARCH IS NEEDED TO
INCREASE FIRE PREVENTION.
WHEN FIRE PREVENTION WORK IS PUT
ON HOLD THE RISK OF MADE UP
BUYERS INCREASES AND ONE MEGA
FIRES HAPPENED MORE MONEY MUST
BE SPENT TO FIGHT THEM CREATING
A VICIOUS CYCLE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY SIX DIRECTS
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE THE PACE
AND SCALE FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES AND SURE THEY HAVE
BEEN YOUR ROUTE.
FIRE PREVENTION OF THE BILL.
BECAUSE TO BE.
WE HAVE LOTS TO SUPPORT
BIPARTISAN.
WE ARE AT YOUR SUPPORT OF THE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MARK FENCE TO MAKE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
FIFTY SIX FOR THE REASONS
ALREADY GIVEN. BUDGETS QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHT THAT MANY OF THE OUR
CD'S THROUGHOUT THE STATE ENGAGE
THE COMMUNITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO DO PLANNING.
MOST IMPORTANTLY AS WE'VE SEEN
THIS PAST YEAR ON MAKING SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS EVACUATION
ROUTES WHEN THERE ARE WILD FIRES
GOING ON. ALSO ON DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENTS HOME
HARDENING UPGRADES IT CETERA
THAT THE GRANT PROGRAM WOULD
HELP FACILITATE GOING FORWARD
FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
IF YOU.
FOR THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON PAUL MAY SPECIFIC
FOREST TRUST ALSO IN SUPPORT WE
THINK THIS BILL PARA FEELING
NICELY WITH ASSEMBLYMAN WOODS
EFFORT TWENTY FIVE FIFTY ONE.
WHICH ADDRESSES MORROW MORE
GUIDANCE FOR THE.
MORE DISTANT FORESTED AREAS IN
THE WATERSHEDS AS OPPOSED TO
MORE COMMUNITY FIRE PREVENTION
AND HIS LOAN SPELL THANK YOU.
STING A GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
KIM'S I AM PERHAPS THE PENINSULA
OPEN SPACE TRUST BOLSA CHICA
LAND TRUST AND SAY THAT I WAS
LEAGUE AND STRONG SUPPORT THINK
ISABEL EVANS OZ POTTER ON BEHALF
OF CINEMA COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
PRESERVATION IN OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT THE WILDLINGS
CONSERVANCY AND THE CALIFORNIA
TO HOLD ITS OWN SUPPORT BEGIN.
THE BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
WHOSE LOBBYIST HADLEY EARLY.
STARSKY RISK ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES ORANGE COUNTY
WHO COULD NOT LEAVE EARLY IN
SUPPORT.
IRATE.
ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MOTION MADE AND
SECONDED.
CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION DO PASSED
WITH AMENDMENTS YOU DID TO
INDICATE THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING
THE TAX ON THEM AND LOOK.
I WOULD LIKE CLOTHES EXACTLY
ASPIRIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MS LIMO WE WE KNOW WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A
HUGE ISSUE IN YOUR DISTRICT
PARTICULAR AS WELL AS. STATEWIDE
FOR THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR A ROLL CALL.
I DON'T SIX A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX BY A MEMBER OF THE MOMENT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED A
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MERIT TO CHIEF
AYE FLATS RICHIE AYE ACOSTA AYE
AYE ACOSTA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE AYE AYE LOAN
AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
AYE STONE. SONAE NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO.
BILLS OUT A LOT YOU.
YES NEXT ITEM IS.
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY EIGHT
SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN VERS THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL ACT EMPOWERS
THE COMMISSION TO PROTECT
MAINTAIN WERE FEASIBLE ENHANCE
AND RESTORE THE OVERALL QUALITY
OF THE COASTAL ZONE ENVIRONMENT
AND IT'S NATURAL AND ARTIFICIAL
RESOURCES.
IN LINE WITH THAT MISSION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR WOULD ALLOW THE STATES TO
COASTAL MANAGEMENT AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL TECHNICAL
JURISDICTIONAL AND RESOURCE
ASSESSMENT ASSISTANCE TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT. PROCESS IN THE EVENT
OF AN OIL SPILL.
BRINGING THE COMMISSION'S
EXPERTISE TO BEAR WOULD ENSURE
THAT DAMAGES CAUSED BY OIL
SPILLS ARE EVALUATED RECOVERED
AND RESTORED TO THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL.
IT WOULD ALSO HAVE THE ADDED
BENEFIT STREAMLINING APPROVALS
FOR COASTAL MITIGATION PROJECTS.
THE RECENTLY PROPOSED FEDERAL
PLAN TAKES AN OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COAST STRENGTHENS THE CASE FOR
INCLUDING THE COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION IS FEDERAL
JURISDICTION AND REGULATORY
AUTHORITY HAVE LED TO IT IT HAVE
LED IT TO BECOME THE STATE
EXPERTS ON EVALUATING AND
QUANTIFYING COASTAL NATURAL
RESOURCES DAMAGES AND
RESTORATION.
I WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
AMENDED AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR.
THE CONSULTATION ROLE PAPA THAT
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO
CONTRIBUTE ITS PARTICULAR
EXPERTISE TO AN RDA. IN A WAY
THAT SUPPLEMENTS BUT DOES NOT
SUPPLANT THE ESTABLISHED PROCESS
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION AS THE BILL
PROGRESSES.
TODAY I HAVE I'M WITH ME AND
SOME SUPPORTERS AND I WHO WILL
TESTIFY.
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING PILE JONES A CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT TODAY.
.
AS WE'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY IF WE ARE CONTINUING TO
PRODUCE OF OFFSHORE OIL
RESOURCES THERE WILL BE
ACCIDENTS THERE WILL BE MORE
SPELLS UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S JUST
THE TRUTH AND WE'RE FACING
REALITY WHERE THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
INCREASE THIS DEVELOPMENT.
DESPITE THE WISHES OF THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
I AND SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT IF THERE ARE FOR
FUTURE SPILLS THAT. THAT THAT WE
COMPLETELY HOLD.
FOLKS RESPONSIBLE ACCOUNTABLE
AND THAT THEY MITIGATE THEIR
ACTIONS.
AND AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES BY ALLOWING FOR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION AND THE BEAT
THAT. THE CDC.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE.
NATURAL RESOURCES DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS WERE REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE AGENCIES
WHO KNOW PASSED THE COAST AND
IT'S COASTAL RESOURCES ARE THERE
TO ACCOUNT FOR. OUT WHAT
RESOURCES BEEN DAMAGED FIGURE
OUT THE BEST PATH FORWARD TO.
RESTORE WHAT WE CAN RESTORE AND
REALLY HOLD THOSE ACCOUNTABLE
AYE IT'S IMPORTANT IN THIS
FUTURE THAT WE HAVE MOVE THIS
BILL FOR TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
SIR CHRISSY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THECALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION.
I WANT TO START OUT BY SAYING
THAT THE COMMISSION HASN'T HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION YET ON THE
AMENDED BILL. BUT THEY DO HAVE A
STAFF ANALYSIS IN FRONT OF THEM
RECOMMENDING A SUPPORT POSITION
AND THEY WILL BE VOTING ON THAT
BILL LATER THIS WEEK SO I'VE
BEEN AUTHORIZED TO COME AND
TESTIFY THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
BASED ON THE.
THE REASONS FOR THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THE NINETEEN SIXTY NINE SANTA
BARBARA OIL SPILL WAS ONE OF THE
IMPETUS REASONS FOR THE COASTAL
ACT BEING PASSED.
AND SINCE THAT TIME.
SINCE THE PASSED THE ACT WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
THE COMMISSION HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO PRESERVING AND
PROTECTING COASTAL RESOURCES AND
OUR OCEAN. THERE HAVE BEEN
EIGHTEEN OIL SPILL SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE FOR WHICH
THE STATE HAS PREPARED A NATURAL
RESOURCES DAMAGE ASSESSMENT. FOR
REASONS NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR TO US
THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAS NOT
BEEN INVOLVED IN ANY OF THOSE
AND RDAS.
HOWEVER.
WE THINK THIS BILL OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COMMISSION
TO BRING SOME ADDITIONAL
EXPERTISE AND PERSPECTIVE TO THE
PROCESS WE WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE OF THE OF THE OFFICE OF
SPILL PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
AND DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND OTHER STATE
AGENCIES. PARTICIPATING AND RDAS
IT'S BEEN A STEEP LEARNING CURVE
FOR US LEARNING WHAT GOES INTO.
ONE OF THESE PLANS BUT WE'RE
GAME TO PARTICIPATE AND TO HELP
PROTECT A CALIFORNIA'S COAST IN
OCEAN RESOURCES I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
THANK YOU.
HELLO JENNIFER SAVAGE FROM THE
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION WE HAVE
DUBBED EIGHTY CHAPTERS IN THE
COUNTRY AND WE HAVE TWENTY
CHAPTERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE LONG BEEN DEDICATED TO HELP
THE BEACHES AND CLEAN WATER.
WE'VE BEEN ON THE GROUND THE
NUMBER OF OIL SPILLS IT HAPPENED
OF INDIANA COAST UNFORTUNATELY
SO OUR MEMBERSHIP IS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THE. THREATS AND
THE CONSEQUENCES THAT HAPPEN AS
MY COLLEAGUE ACCOUNT THAT FROM
THE SIERRA CLUB. IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF IF IT'S A QUESTION
OF WHEN WE KNOW THAT THERE WILL
BE MORE OIL SPILLS. WE KNOW THAT
RIGHT NOW THERE IS.
AND ATTEMPT TO EXPAND OFFSHORE
OIL DRILLING AND EVEN IF THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
THE ECONOMIC DEPENDENCE THAT WE
HAVE ON OUR COAST. DESERVE THE
MOST PROTECTION THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC.
IS ABLE TO BE PROTECTED IN THE
WAY THAT THEY DID DESERVE AND
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD INNINGS TURN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND FOR A LOT OF ON THE
ON BEHALF OF US SOON IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE FIVE TEARS INSTITUTE SEVENTH
GENERATION ADVISORS PLASTIC
POLLUTION COALITION AND THE
CENTER FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION ALL IN
SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT ONE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THREE SEPARATE RICH ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAY IN SUPPORT.
JUSTIN ALONE FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
CRAIG CADWALLADER SURFRIDER
SOUTH BAY IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
FOR
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WE
SUCH AS WITH THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION I GIVEN
THE RECENT CONVERSATIONS AND
EVERYTHING AMENDMENTS ARE FROM
THE AUTHORS OFFICE. OUT WE ARE
NOT OPPOSED LESS AMENDED
POSITION TO.
TO EIGHT SIX FOUR.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE.
OFFICE OF US FOR PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE HOW THE FLEXIBILITY TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION. OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE FOR BY THE
COMMISSION SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE OF THE
BILL FLAT MOVES FOR TODAY.
THINKS.
CAPITALIST CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS GOOD EVENING OUTFITS
APF A THOMAS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
SOLUTION.
.
WHEN WE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
MEMBERS OFFICE WE WERE INFORMED
THAT.
ONLY MADE THE SUGGESTION THAT
THE COAST COMMISSION BE.
AN ADVISORY CAPACITY.
THAT WAS ACCEPTABLE AND THAT
WAS ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHORS
OFFICE.
UNFORTUNATELY.
WHEN THE AMENDMENT CAME OUT IT
DIDN'T NECESSARILY LOOK LIKE BUT
WE HAVE DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY.
SO LET ME BE CLEAR WE AGREE THAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE AN ADVISORY
POSITION
DO WE BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE IN
STATURE THAT THEIR OPINION
SHOULD WEIGH MORE THAN OTHERS
NOW. DO WE BELIEVE THAT THEIR
OPINION IN FACT SHOULD COME OUT
WAY HOSPERS NO. BUT SHOULD BE
UNDER ADVISEMENT YES WE BELIEVE
THAT SHOULD BE UNDER ADVISEMENT
BUT THE PLACEMENT STATUTE INDIAN
PROVIDE THEM WITH A LITTLE MORE.
AS YOU MAY SAY SWAY THAN OTHER.
ENTITIES THAT ARE ACTUALLY TASK
TO DO THIS ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS
WE DISAGREE SO WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AS AMENDED AGAIN FROM THE
STANDPOINT MEMBERS OF THE
COASTAL COMMISSION BEING IN AN
ADVISORY CAPACITY. WE HAVE NO
PROBLEMS WITH THAT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
AFFORD.
ADAM RIGHTLY ON BEHALF OF THAT
CALIBER COMMERCE WERE ALSO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
DON CAPTAIN MCCUE CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES THE
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSE ENLISTMENT AT THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING.
WE HAVE. WE DO NOT MOTION
SECOND.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT.
.
AGAIN THANK YOU MS LIMON FOR.
FIGHTING FOR YOUR DISTRICT.
THIS.
TO ADDRESS.
THE CONSEQUENCES FROM OFFSHORE
OIL DRILLING.
SANTA BARBARA IS WHERE IT ALL
STARTED AND. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CHAMPION IN THIS ISSUE.
.
CHARLES RECOMMENDATION TO DO
PASSED TO CORPORATIONS.
WHICH I CLOSE ESPECIALLY
ASPIRIN I HAVE A.
THANK YOU VOCAL PLEASE I DON'T
WANT TO AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR BY THE MOAN TO PASS AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
AYE REFUGEE AYE ACOSTA NO COST
AND NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAU EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA KNOWN LIMON AYE LIMON AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
NO STONE.
STONE I.
IT'S THREE.
THOSE OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT MR STONE.
LAST THREE BILLS.
STONE YOU HAVE.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY NINE AND ITEM TWENTY AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN NINE THAT'S
ROADSTER WITH THE TWENTY FIVE
FORTY NINE.
AND THIS IS A SIMPLE
STREAMLINING BILL WITH RESPECT
TO HOW THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION DOES.
LAND EXCHANGES WE HAD AN EXAMPLE
THIS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY THERE
WAS A LAND EXCHANGE THAT PASSED
THROUGH ON. CONSENT.
INSTEAD OF BRINGING ALL OF THESE
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE AS IS
THE CURRENT PRACTICE IT JUST
SEEMS A LOT MORE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE TO LATE GIVEAWAY AND
COMMISSION AUTHORITY TO DO THESE
CONVEYANCES. AS LONG AS WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS TRANSPARENT AND
THAT THEY ARE REPORTING THESE
CONVEYANCES SO THAT.
THE PUBLIC AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
WHERE THE CONVEYANCE ARE THIS IS
A NORMAL PART OF THEIR.
THEIR BUSINESS AND WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTES AND I DO HAVE
JERRY PEMBERTON WITH THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION. AS A WITNESS.
THANK YOU SHERRY PEMBERTON ON
BEHALF FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION HAS SPONSORING
THIS LEGISLATION IT IS AS I THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID OVERLY
SIMPLE STRAIGHT FORWARD BELL TO.
MAKE OUR LAND EXCHANGE PROCESSES
MORE EFFICIENT AS SAVE MONEY AND
RESOURCES THE COMMISSION DOES
LAND EXCHANGES FROM TIME TO TIME
AND IT'S. A LENGTHY CUMBERSOME
PROCESS WITH A LOT OF LEVELS OF
SCRUTINY SO THAT FINAL STEP OF
GRANTING THE LAND THAT THE
STATE.
TAKES INTO THE TRUST BACK TO A
LOCAL JURISDICTION IS.
FAIRLY MINISTERIAL AND SO THIS
BILL WILL HELP US DO THAT A MORE
EFFICIENTLY.
.
MOVE THE BILL.
OPPOSITION.
THE MOVE THE SECOND INNING
COMEBACK.
I ASK HER ABOUT.
I AM SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY NINE BY MEMBERS STONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAU. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LIVE ALONE.
LEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ LINDA'S NO
STONE BY.
STONE I.
TO.
SIX TWO.
PULLS OUT.
AND OUR TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY I'M
STUMPED THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND. MY JOINT AUTHOR
MISTER CALDERON AT LIKE TWO
PRESENTS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY NINE HAD
THIS IS A SIMPLE MEASURE THAT
WOULD REQUIRE SINGLE USE PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS TAP TEIR
CAPS TETHERED. THIS COMMITTEE
SAW. THE BILL IN JANUARY AND
PASS OUT OF THIS.
COMMITTEE AT THE ONE CHANGE IN
THIS BILL IS THAT WE HAVE IN
FACT REMOVED THE DATE THAT WAS A
POINT OF CONTENTION.
WITH UP.
THAT THE CASE FOR THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY FAIRLY CLEAR AND WAS
MADE LAST JANUARY THAT BOTTLE
CAPS ARE A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION. THERE
CONSISTENTLY AMONG THE TOP FIVE
CURRENTLY THE TOP THREE MOST
UBIQUITOUS ITEM THAT IS FOUND IN
CLEAN UP SEN THROUGHOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE EFFORTS TO
RE ASK THAT. BOTTLES COME BACK
WITH THE CAPS
STILL NOT WORKING.
AT BY THE EVIDENCE OF HOW MANY
BOTTLE CAPS ARE FOUND OUT IN THE
ENVIRONMENT SIMPLY TETHERING.
THAT CAP TO THE BOTTLE AND THIS
BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY ANY
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE
NUMBER OF THEM. AND DEPENDING
ON.
THE WHETHER IT'S A CARBONATED
BOTTLED HOT SO CALLED FILL OUR
WATER THERE ARE DIFFERENT.
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT IS POSSIBLE
IN FACT MOST THE BY THE
COMPANIES WE'VE TALKED TO
SUGGEST THAT THEY AREN'T MOVING
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
AND IN LOOKING AT. THE VARIOUS
OPTIONS THEIR NUMBER DIFFERENT
EXAMPLES WHERE THESE BOTTLES ARE
ALREADY OUT IN THE MARKETPLACE.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE BOTTLING
INDUSTRY. AND SEE IF THERE ARE
WAYS THAT WE CAN HELP FACILITATE
AND PUSH THEM. TO.
ENSURE THAT THE CAPS COME BACK
WITH THE BOTTLES THEMSELVES AND
IT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH.
PULL TABS ON ALUMINUM CANS THAT
WAS LEGISLATIVE ACTION THAT THAT
PUSHED THAT CHANGE SO THAT THERE
WASN'T THAT LITTLE BIT OF.
ALUMINUM THAT WAS PRETTY PRETTY
PERVASIVE IN THE ENVIRONMENT THE
TIME NOW THEY MOSTLY COME BACK
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVEN'T.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO.
NOW YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT COMMITTEES.
THANK YOU CHAIR MERITS TO CARRY
ON MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CRAIG CADWALLADER AND
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
SURFRIDER IN APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY PERCENT OF MARINE
PLASTICS COME FROM TRASH IN
URBAN RUNOFF AND IF WE DON'T
REDUCE PLASTICS ENTERING THE
OCEAN. THEY'LL BE MORE PLASTIC
THAN TISH IN THE OCEAN BY TWENTY
FIFTY.
BOTTLE CAPS ARE THE THIRD MOST
COMMON ITEM FOUND ON THE BEACH
IS WORLDWIDE. ACCORDING TO THE
INTERNATIONAL COASTAL CLEANUP
DATE DATA.
THEY ARE A COMMON FORM OF ST
LITTER POLLUTING OUR COMMUNITIES
THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND HUMAN
HEALTH IMPACTS ARE WIDE RANGING.
NINETY PERCENT OF SEA BIRDS HAVE
INGESTED PLASTICS MANY DIE OF
STARVATION WAS STOMACHS FULL OF
PLASTIC CAPS AND OTHER PLASTICS
MISTAKE PER FOOD.
NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED MARINE
SPECIES ARE IMPACTED.
YEAH PLASTICS BREAKDOWN INTO
MICRO PLASTICS IN THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT AND ALSO ACCUMULATE
POLLUTANTS FROM SEA WATER.
MICRO PLASTICS ARE PRESENT IN
OUR SEAFOOD SALT HONEY BEAR AND
DRINKING WATER RECENT RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT PEOPLE WHO EAT
SHELLFISH RATE REALLY CAN BE
EATING UP TO ELEVEN THOUSAND
PIECES. OF MICRO PLASTIC PER
YEAR.
CONNECTING THE CAPS IS ONE
SIMPLE WAY TO DECREASE PLASTIC
POLLUTION RECENT RESEARCH FOUND
THAT U. S. ON AUSTRALIAN STATES
WITH BOTTLE DEPOSITS.
THIS CHARGE SIXTY PERCENT FEWER
PLASTIC BOTTLES TO COASTAL
WATERS THAN NON BOTTLE DEPOSIT
STATES YET THE CAPS WERE
CONNECTED THERE WOULD BE LESS
CAP POLLUTION. COMING FROM
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THE BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY ADDRESSED LETTER FROM
ALUMINUM CAN PULL TABS IS
CREATED AS. WAS PREVIOUSLY
STATED.
YEAH THE LEGISLATION IS OVERLY
ALREADY CONSIDERED THE BILL BUT
THIS ISN'T ROCKET SCIENTISTS
IT'S TIME TO FORCE.
A DECISION TO FIGURE THIS OUT
SURFRIDER IS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR SO MEMBERS
SUPPORTERS AND ACTIVISTS
ENCOUNTER BOTTLE CAPS AND OTHER
PLASTIC POLLUTION. WITH
INCREASING FREQUENCIES AS A
MATTER OF FACT JUST YESTERDAY I
WAS DOING WATER SAMPLES IN THE
BIO WETLANDS. WHICH WAS A TEAM
WITH WILDLIFE AND I PICKED UP A
BOTTLE CAPS REGULARLY THERE AND
THEY WERE EVERYWHERE SO WE THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MISSION.
GOOD EVENING SHARON MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
ATTENTION. KELLY MIGHT BE WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO REALLY SUPPORT FOR
UPSTREAM.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE CONSUME
ELEVEN AND A HALF BILLION
PLASTIC WATER BOTTLES EVERY
YEAR.
NO DESPITE OUR HIGH RECYCLING
RATE FOR THESE BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS WE KNOW THAT AT LEAST
FIVE BILLION AND UP TO TEN
BILLION OF THE CAPS THAT BELONG
TO THOSE. BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
ARE NOT RECYCLED AND IN FACT AND
UP IN OUR LANDFILLS AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
BETWEEN THIRTEEN AND TWENTY SIX
MILLION OF THESE PLASTIC BOTTLE
CAPS.
BEING DISCARDED EVERYDAY.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ONE OF THE
TOP THREE ITEMS FOUND DURING
CALIFORNIA BEACH CLEANUPS.
THESE PLASTIC BOTTLE CAPS
SIGNIFICANTLY IT POLLUTES OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND CONTRIBUTE
TO BLIGHT AS MENTIONED IN THE
ANALYSIS. AT TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AN RTC STUDY FOUND THAT
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPALITIES ARE
SPENDING CLOSE TO HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
TO PREVENT TRASH FROM ENTERING
THEIR STREETS PARKS AND STORM
DRAINS AND WE KNOW THAT THESE
COSTS ARE ONLY GOING TO RISE AS
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY ENACTED
REGULATIONS. REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IVAN.
AND TO FURTHER REDUCE THE TRASH
LOW TO THE STORM DRAINS.
NAVY TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY NINE
DOES NOT MANDATE A PARTICULAR
TECHNOLOGY TO ACHIEVE CONNECTED
CAPS BUT RATHER IT PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY TO BEVERAGE
COMPANIES TO DETERMINE THE
DESIGN AND TECHNOLOGY THAT WORKS
BEST FOR THEIR PRODUCT. AND
CUSTOMER BASE AND WE KNOW THAT
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE READILY
AVAILABLE.
CRYSTAL GEYSER SPRINGWATER
OPERATING RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY TETHERING
CAPS ON ONE OF THEIR. WATER
LINES.
I NOT ONLY PROTECTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT BUT REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF OVERALL PLASTIC THEY
USE AND EVEN SAVING MONEY ON
THEIR PRODUCTION OF THIS LINE IN
THE PROCESS.
SEVERAL EUROPEAN COMPANIES HAVE
INVESTED IN SIMILAR TECHNOLOGIES
FOR JUICE AND SPORTS DRINKS
BEVERAGES AND PROTOTYPES
AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET RIGHT
NOW. HAVE DEMONSTRATED THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS IN USE FOR HOT
FILL AND CARBONATED BEVERAGES.
IN A FINAL POINT RECYCLERS WANT
TO CAPTURE THE PLASTIC FROM
THESE CAPS RECYCLING EQUIPMENT
IS ALREADY DESIGNED TO HANDLE.
AYE THESE CAPS AND TO ATTACK
THEIR TOP WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW
RECYCLERS.
CAPTURE MORE OF THIS MATERIAL.
I AND TO SELL A GREATER QUANTITY
OF IT INTERN.
IN CLOSING A TETHER TOP IS A WIN
WIN SOLUTION FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT
FOR RECYCLERS AND FOR OUR
PERSONAL CONVENIENCE.
IT IS THE ONLY SOLUTION THAT
WILL PREVENT A HUNDRED PERCENT
OF ALL CAPS FROM BECOMING BLADES
AND OUR COMMUNITIES AND PLASTIC
POLLUTION AND OUR OCEANS. AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA TO
LEAD THE WAY AYE ARCHER AYE
ABOUT THINKING.
ANY WITNESS FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND ONLY SERVER WITH DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT THINK
YOU.
QUALIFY ME DONNA WITHOUT OF ON
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TERESA BURKE* ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAY IN SUPPORT.
LUCAS FRERICHS THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION UPSTREAM POLICY CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND AND SUPPORT AND I
JUST WANNA ECHO THAT A LOT OF
THE. TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE USE THE SAME OR LESS
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC AND SO THUS
DON'T COST ANY.
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO
MANUFACTURERS.
JUST KNOWN FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY ECHO CA WC EXCELLENT
TESTIMONY.
BOTH OF THEM ON BEHALF OF
STUDENTS FROM SUPPORT.
I MEAN TAR WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO SUPPORT
THINKING.
FILE JONES CIRCLE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
RUN STRUCK FRIENDS OF THE RIVER
IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR UP
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD
.
FOUR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MONIES MIKE VARNEY I'M
FROM A VERY BROTHERS BOTTLING WE
DO OR SEVEN UP INDEPENDENT
BOTTLER IN MODESTO.
ON THE PRESIDENT AND OUR
FAMILIES RUN THE BUSINESS FOR
EIGHTY YEARS AND MODESTO WE'VE.
WE PRODUCE AND WE DISTRIBUTE.
BROUGHT BRANDS THE A FOR MERCED
COUNTY ALWAYS SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND FROM THE FOOTHILLS TO.
OTHER BILLS SO WE.
KINDA ARE FAMILIAR WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PACKAGING TECHNIQUES
WE KIND OF FEEL THAT OVER THE
YEARS WE'VE KINDA.
.
BEEN THE LEADER IN PACKAGING WE
DID A LOT OF STUFF WITH CANS WAY
BEFORE CANS WERE.
IN A TWELVE PACK CARTONS AND
DIFFERENT TYPES.
BUT WE FEEL THAT THIS.
BEING LED TO. A BUT.
ENCLOSURE FOR A BOTTLE. THAT
WILL STAY TETHERED
IT'S GONNA BE VERY HARD FOR US
TO MANAGE.
.
I SPOKE WITH A FEW OF OUR
MACHINERY COMPANIES THAT WE DO
THAT WE USE FOR OUR
MANUFACTURING PROCESS TO PUT THE
CAP ON TWO BOTTLES.
THEY.
HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
CARBONATED SOFT DRINKS WITH THE
A FLIP TOP CAP.
YOU KNOW BOTTLE WATER IS LOT LOT
EASIER TO PUT A CAP ON THAT ARE
TWO OTHER IT AND PUT SUPPORT CAP
ON. BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A
CARBONATED SOFT DRINK WITH HIGH
PRESSURE ITEM AND WHEN YOU GO ON
A HOT FEEL. THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES WITH THAT.
EVEN WITH THE SPORT CAP.
THE TECHNOLOGY IN THE SPORT CAP
LIKE THIS WHEN I HEAR. IS A KIND
OF LIKE THE HIGH END THIS
WORKOUT THERE'S ALSO THERE'S ALL
ALWAYS GOING TO BEA. BILL FOR
BRING ON THE SAME.
TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM OPENING A
MINUTE STORES TAMPERING WITH
THEM.
AND THAT PILFERING ONCE PULLED
OFF.
GETS DISCARDED.
USUALLY AT HIGHER HIGHER RATE
THAN WITH THE CAP.
SO THIS RING COMES OFF AND YOU
DO HAVE THIS PIECE OF PLASTIC.
THAT.
MAJORITY TIMES. TOSSED BECAUSE
IT'S
LEFT OVER.
A SECOND THING THAT PEOPLE DO
WITH WORKSHOPS IS THEY'VE.
TAKE OFF LIKE THIS
AND DRINK FROM IT.
SO YOU HAVE A CAP THAT IS NOW
REMOVED FROM THE BOTTLE.
YOU KNOW I PUT MY CAPS BACK ON.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
DON'T.
SO THAT'S AN ISSUE THERE.
.
WE JUST FEEL THAT.
YOU KNOW WITH WITH THAT WITH THE
KEEP THE CAP ON CAMPAIGN THAT'S
RUNNING HOPEFULLY THAT'LL HELP
EDUCATE PEOPLE ON TRYING TO KEEP
THE CAPS ON THE ON BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS.
BUT WE FEEL THAT.
HAVING BE MANDATED TO HAVE A
TETHERED CAP OR SPORT CAP ON ALL
OUR BEVERAGES IS.
CAN BE VERY EXPENSIVE FOR US.
EMPLOYEE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE PEOPLE IN MODESTO
AREA. AND WE FEEL IF WE HAVE TO
SPEND.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON SOME
MACHINERY IT'S IT'S GONNA HIT
OUR BOTTOM LINE PRETTY HARD.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KELLY FOX I AM THE REGIONAL
ACCOUNT EXECUTIVE FOR A SMALL
BEVERAGE COMPANY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CALLED NARROW. WE ARE
PRIVATELY OWNED COMPANY.
MY BUSINESS HERE IS OBVIOUSLY
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SMALL
BEVERAGE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOK AT THIS
BILL IN THE THINK.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IS FROM COKE
OR PEPSI OR DR PEPPER SNAPPLE
AND HAS UNLIMITED RESOURCES.
AT ABILITIES TO INVESTIGATE
THIS KIND OF TECHNOLOGY.
I'M STANDING HERE SAYING WE
HAVE EIGHTY EMPLOYEES AND THAT
IS A NATIONAL GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT WORK FOR THIS BRAND.
I'VE BEEN HERE SIX YEARS.
OUR BRAND IS OUR BOTTLES THAT IS
OUR CONDUCT RECOGNITION THAT IS
WHAT WE HOLD CLOSE TO US AS A
COMPANY.
AND TO PURSUE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS WHERE THE TECHNOLOGY DOES
NOT EXIST RIGHT NOW AT LEAST FOR
OUR BRAND FOR OUR PACKAGING FOR
OUR PRODUCT.
WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC FOR US AS
A COMPANY.
WE'RE LOOKING AT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ALONE JUST
TO DESIGN A PRODUCT OR A MACHINE
THAT DOESN'T EXIST YET.
AND REALISTICALLY FOR US WE
DON'T KNOW IF IT COULD EXIST WE
DON'T KNOW IF WE COULD KEEP THIS
BOTTLES INTEGRITY.
WHEN WE DID A TEST STUDY IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WITH BRAND
AWARENESS CAME BACK THAT SEVENTY
NINE PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE WERE TEST
MARKETING. KNEW OUR BOTTLES
BASED ON THE SHAPE OF OUR
BOTTLES
NOW YOU KNOW THE DISCUSSION CAN
BE THAT YES WE WANT PEOPLE TO
KEEP THE CAPLAN'S WE WE WANT
THEM TO BE EDUCATED OUR BOTTLES
ARE HUNDRED PERCENT RECYCLABLE.
ON THAT IS ON OUR BOTTLES THAT
IS BRANDED AS FOR PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO BE EDUCATED IF WE'RE
GOING TO GO INTO SOMETHING WHERE
WE HAVE TO TETHER.
ON A STATIC LEVEL I PERSON WHO
YOU DON'T WANT THIS IN MY FACE
WHEN I'M DRINKING MY PRODUCTS.
THAT'S NOT LOOKING AFTER OUR
CONSUMER AND THAT'S ALSO FORCING
US TO GO INTO MORE PRODUCTION
SLOWER PRODUCTION WERE SMALL
COMPANY PRODUCTION IS A VERY BIG
THING TO US AND HOW WE CAN KEEP
UP WITH OTHER PEOPLE AND
DEMANDS.
AS WELL AS THAT BUILDS ON TO
TO INCLUDE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN OUT
THERE LIKE SPORTS CAPS ARE THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PLASTIC
ALONE.
OMINOUS A COMPANY WE TRIED TO
REDUCE OUR PLASTIC IMPRINT.
AN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN STRIVING TO DO SO THIS IS
JUST GOING TO OUTSIDE. TO
MATERIALS BEING DRIVEN OUT
THAT'S GONNA BECAUSE THE COST OF
OUR PRODUCT TO BE DRIVEN UP.
AND IT'S REALLY FOR SMALL
COMPANIES LIKE OURS GOING TO
PROBABLY PUT US OUT OF BUSINESS.
LET ALONE THE FACT THAT OUR
PRODUCTS CAN BE BOUGHT ON STE
ECOMMERCE SITES LIKE AMAZON. NO
PRODUCTS CAN BE BOUGHT ONLINE
AND SHIPPED INTO CALIFORNIA.
LIKE INTRIGUED AS THE
PARLIAMENT.
YOU KNOW SO SO THAT WHOLE A
LIMITS TO IT THE TETHERING IS
WELL WE DON'T WANT POLLUTION WE
WANT TO EDUCATE CONSUMERS TO
KEEP THAT CAP ON THE BOTTLE IT
IS ALL RECYCLABLE. ON THE
DISAPPEAR AND SAY THAT WE ALL
HAVE TO TETHER ON WE'VE THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PRODUCTS WE
CARBONATED LIGHTLY CARBONATED
AND FAST YOU DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
SO JUST FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
SMALL BEVERAGE WE ASK THAT YOU
GUYS VOTE IN OPPOSITION AND VOTE
AND NO ON THIS BILL ON IN PLEASE
KEEP THE SMALLER COMPANIES IN
MIND THIS IS COULD BE
CATASTROPHIC FOR CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME THANK.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE.
IT TO SAY GOOD EVENING I'LL BE
BRIEF.
MY NAME IS GRANT DEARIE WHEN
NOR CAL BEVERAGE COMPANY IT WAS
SACRAMENTO WE ARE A FAMILY OWNED
BOTTLER.
WILL BE.
SOBRINA EIGHTIETH YEAR.
THIS YEAR.
AND WE ARE A MAJOR CONTRACT
PACKED
PACKING MANUFACTURE THE BEVERAGE
INDUSTRY.
AND WE HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT OUR BOTTOM LINE AND
SYSTEMS WE HAVE A PLAN HERE. WAS
SACKED A WOMAN IN A TIME.
WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN NINE BECAUSE
TETHERING WE WE SEE.
THE INDUSTRY IS WITH US ALWAYS
BEEN VERY INNOVATIVE AND OVER
TIME I AM SURE THAT WILL COME UP
WITH A VIABLE SOLUTION
TO.
THE THE LETTER ISSUE.
THAT MAY INCLUDE A SOLUTION
TETHER AND ONE OF OUR ISSUES
CONCERNS IS OBVIOUSLY ALL THE
CAMPING EQUIPMENT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO MODIFY.
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS INVESTMENT
IN THE MILLIONS.
TO ARE ALSO TO OUR BOTTOM LINE
AS A COMPANY.
WE ARE ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDS AS
A COMPANY WE ARE VERY
ENVIRONMENT CONSCIOUS.
THE TAMPA BAY AND.
EVIDENCE OF TAMPERING WITH WITH.
ENCLOSURES.
AND LOSING THAT FUNCTIONALITY
WITH POTENTIALLY WITH
NOTHINGNESS DEVELOPED QUITE YET.
SATISFY.
.
YOU KNOW PEACE OF MIND IN THE
HOLE TETHERING OR A YOU KNOW
TAMPERING.
AND QUALITY CONTROL CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE MAJOR
LIABILITY ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
THAT'S A MAJOR CONCERN.
SO WE ARE WE BELIEVE THE
INDUSTRY THE CAPPING CLOSURE
INDUSTRY THE BEVERAGE INDUSTRY
WILL WILL CONTINUE TO LOOK AT.
YOU KNOW INNOVATIVE APPROACHES
TO THIS ISSUE.
WE DON'T THINK THAT IT IS
NECESSARY FOR THE STATE TO
MANDATE FORCE THIS ACTION.
UPON THE BOTTLING INDUSTRY THE
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY AND THAT IT
WILL HAPPEN OVER TIME AND THAT.
FOR THAT REASON WE ASPIRIN
ABOUT.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS KEEP
BELT CAPITAL ADVOCACY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AUTOMATIC VENDORS
COUNCIL BE VERY BRIEF.
WHAT WE SUPPORT INCREASING
RECYCLING AND?
REDUCING LITTER WE DON'T THINK
THAT MANDATING CAPS ON ALL
MODELS REALLY FEASIBLE FOR THE
INDUSTRY.
IN IT AS FOLKS OF MENTIONS
ACTUALLY DOES INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTIC IS BEING USED
IN THE CAPS WHEN YOU TETHER
THEM.
SO WE UNDERSTAND FROM SOME
MANUFACTURERS THAT THERE'S NO
REAL DATE WE APPRECIATE THAT
THERE'S NO DATE IN THE BILL BUT
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND FOR
MANUFACTURERS AS NO REAL DATE
THAT CAN WORK ACROSS ALL PRODUCT
NOT LINES RIGHT NOW. AND FOR THE
CARBONATED HOT FILTER MAY NOT BE
A DATE THAT COULD ACTUALLY WORK.
SO RETAILERS CAN'T SELL THE
PRODUCTS CAN IMPACT OUR
BUSINESSES JOBS AND OVERALL
ECONOMY FOR OUR INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
DENNIS ALBION A ON BEHALF OF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE.
ARMANDO FLOORS OF THE VALLEY
MISSION COMES SO HE'S
ASSOCIATION ARE WE OPPOSE.
MADISON DIE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
JERRY MCKEE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THIRTY YEARS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION.
AT A RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN A
POSITION.
A JOE ACCURATELY HIT THE
PLASTICS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
POST.
THERE ARE THOMAS ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERNATIONAL BOTTLED WATER
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
BAR WATER CESSATION OPPOSITION.
DON KEPT KEY ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
POST.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MINISTER FLOOR.
IT'S VERY THANK YOU FOR COMING
TO SACRAMENTO I. APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE. BUT JUST A QUICK
QUESTION TO THE OUT HAS ANYTHING
BEEN DONE TO TO ADDRESS THE HOT
FILLED OR CARBONATED.
PART OF THIS BILL HE DONE TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AT ALL.
WELL THIS THIS BILL HAS
ESSENTIALLY BEEN IN PRINT FOR A
LITTLE OVER A YEAR NOW.
AND WE'VE HAD A COUPLE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I'VE BEEN VERY
VERY CLEAR. THAT WE'RE WILLING
TO WORK ON A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS AND SO FAR. WE'VE
BEEN PRETTY MUCH IGNORED OR COR
JUST TOLD NO.
WE'VE BROUGHT AROUND TO MOST OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS EXAMPLES I
LIKE SPORTS CAPS EITHER THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
WE BROUGHT READ TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND ANYBODY'S INTERESTED
SOME EXAMPLES OF WHERE THIS
ACTUALLY WORKS POTENTIALLY COULD
WORK WITH EXISTING MACHINERY.
BUT YET I'M NOT TRYING TO SELL
ANY PARTICULAR IDEA OR ANY
PARTICULAR SOLUTION. THE MAJOR
BOTTLERS TALK TO US ABOUT THAT
THAT THEY ARE WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE IN FACT SOME BOTTLED
WATER.
DISTRIBUTORS CRYSTALLIZE OR
BROUGHT IN SOME EXAMPLES WHERE
THEY ARE CURRENTLY DISTRIBUTING
ONE OF THE FLIP TOP I WOULD NOT
EVER SUGGEST PUTTING A FLIP TOP
ON.
A.
.
ON A A. BE PRESSURIZED BOTTLE
LET THAT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE BUT SOME OF THE OTHER
SOLUTIONS. DO ATTACK RELEASE THE
GAS DO IN FACT HAVE THE SAME
INTEGRITY THE CAP.
PHYSICALLY FIT THE SAME
DIMENSIONS AS EXISTING BOTTLE
CAPS IN REALLY HAVE NO MORE
PLASTIC MAN I'M NOT. TRYING TO
PROMOTE ANY ONE PARTICULAR
SOLUTION NOT JUST ASK THE
INDUSTRY TO CONTINUE WHAT. WITH
RESPECT TO THE SMALL BOTTLERS
AND DEAL OF SYMPATHY FOR.
THE SITUATION IS MORE BOTTLER
HAS FOUND THEM THEMSELVES IN THE
EASY SOLUTION FOR THEM TO
SUCCUMB ASK WOULD WE BE WILLING
TO PUT. A.
A CAP ON THIS OR SAY ONLY FOR
LARGE BOTTLERS NOT FOR SMALL
BOTTLERS LET'S TALK ABOUT IT
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET A REAL
CONVERSATION.
ABOUT THIS BILL FOR OVER A YEAR
NOW. AND PARTLY. THAT THE REASON
WHY I THINK THIS IS I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN PASS THIS THROUGH.
IF WE CAN SHOW THAT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE THIS AND THIS IS ONE THE
REASONS MISTER CALDERON CAME ON
BOARD BECAUSE HE'S VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT PLASTIC
POLLUTION THE AMOUNT OF CLASSICS
THAT WE FIND IN OUR ENVIRONMENT.
BOTTLE CAPS IS ONE NAY V. MOST
SIGNIFICANT IN UBIQUITOUS PIECES
OF TRASH THAT'S OUT THERE.
WE CAN ALWAYS SAY WELL THE
LETTERING ISSUE LET'S JUST DO A
CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE PEOPLE THAT
HAS.
NEVER WORKED IN THE PAST I DON'T
KNOW WHY IT WOULD WORK NOW.
SO CREATING A REALISTIC
STRUCTURE FOR DATES A REALISTIC
STRUCTURE FOR THE KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGIES A WHICH BOTTLES
WERE TALKING ABOUT. BROKE INTO
THAT THEM SPEAKING ABOUT BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND MISTER CALDERON
BECAUSE WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
BUT HE WAS LIKE OUTSIDE THE
COMPANY SIDE THE BOTTLERS. WE'RE
OPEN TO THAT.
MAKE IS ENOUGH.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT
A SIMPLE NO WE'RE DONE WITH THE
NOW.
AND I'M HOPING THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE OF OUR
WILLINGNESS TO DEAL IN OUR
WILLINGNESS TO TALK THROUGH THE
ISSUES.
AND REALLY LOOK FOR A SOLUTION
SET UP A REALISTIC TIME LINE
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING TO BE
AFRAID OF HERE.
WE CAN SAY NO WE'RE GOOD THAT WE
KNOW HOW TO SHUT THINGS DOWN.
SINGLE BIGGEST COMPLAINT I GET
BUT ABOUT THIS BILL IN MY
DISTRICT IS WHY DON'T I JUST
BANNED SINGLE USE PLASTIC
BOTTLES.
THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF
JURISDICTIONS ARE TALK ABOUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT HERE BECAUSE I'D RATHER.
TAKE THE STEP TO TRY AND WORK
WITH THE INDUSTRY.
TO MODIFY THE PRODUCTS
MAKE THE PRODUCT LESS HARMFUL
FOR THE VERY SPECIFIC REASONS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND SEE IF THERE'S A WAY
FORWARD.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING AT THIS
POINT SO FOR THIS COMMITTEE WERE
ASKING TO MOVE THE BILL.
AND CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS
THE NEXT HURDLE OBVIOUSLY WILL
BE THE FLOOR WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
A BIG CONVERSATION. AND I'M OPEN
THAT MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE WILL
LOOK AT THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE.
LOOK AT THE GOOD FAITH WE'VE
ENTERED INTO AND LOOK AT THE
ABSENCE ON THE OTHER SIDE AND
SAY.
BUT.
COME TO THE TABLE
SO WE'RE ASKING COME TO THE
TABLE.
WELL THERE'S ANYTHING I CAN DO
TO FACILITATE THOSE MEETINGS TO
GET US TO A PLACE OF SUPPORT
I'M.
I'M YOURS SECRETARY I'LL TAKE
YOU UP ON THAT PROCEED YES BUT
WOULD HELP.
YEAH.
MS EGGMAN THAN THIS LONDON'S.
AND THANK YOU MISTER STONE. I'M.
MCCURRY I MISS THE SAME WATER
BOTTLE I'VE HAD FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS AND EVERY COMMITTEE HAVE
SAT ON AND THE. YES I HAVE A
LITTLE OCD AS WELL.
BUT PERSONALLY I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA.
I WILL SAY DO THE SAME THING I
SAID TO YOU IN JANUARY.
GET THE INDUSTRY TO THE TABLE.
OR IF WE CAN GET SOME KIND OF
DEAL I WON'T BE ABLE TO BE WITH
YOU ON THE FLOOR. BUT I HAVE A
LOT OF SYMPATHY FOR SOME OF THE
SMALLER BOTTLERS AND AND JUST
ABOUT ME THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES
AS YOU CLEARLY KNOW AND YOU
CLEARLY ACKNOWLEDGE. THERE'S
THIS IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
AND IT CANNOT BE A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL AND THIS IS SOMETHING I
THINK WE NEED TO DO A LITTLE
TEENY BITES. NOT BIG GIANT
CHUNKS
ON SO AGAIN I WILL BE WITH YOU
TODAY AND THEN WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE GET TO THE FLOOR
THANK YOU AND I HEARD YOU LOUD
AND CLEAR. WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
SEE WHAT WHAT BITES ARE POSSIBLE
AND GETTING SILENCE.
MS MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
SO.
YOU'RE SAYING THAT YOU HAVE
INVITED TO THE TABLE THE SMALLER
BOTTLERS AND THEY HAVE REFUSED
YOUR OFFER. IS THAT CORRECT I
HAVE INVITED ANYBODY WHO'S COME
TO TALK TO US ARE WILLING TO
TALK TO US A BEEN VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT. THE LAST YEAR. MY
DOORS OPEN.
SO YOU HAVE INVITED SMALL
BOTTLERS AND THEY HAVE REFUSED
TO COME I HAVE INVITED ANYBODY
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND SO
FAR.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO'VE COME ARE
TO TELL ME THAT THERE'S THEY
HAVE NOTHING TO OFFER.
WELL FOR A BILL OF THIS
IMPORTANCE CONSIDERING IT HAVE
SUCH AN ENORMOUS EFFECT
ON THIS INDUSTRY.
I COULD.
I FEEL LIKE THAT ONUS IS ON YOU.
THE AUTHOR TO BRING EVERYBODY TO
THE TABLE TO WORK THROUGH THIS
SO THAT WE'RE NOT ON NECESSARILY
HARMING. AN INDUSTRY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF WAYS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE SOME LIKE WITH THIS BOTTLE
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE A LITTLE MORE
DIFFICULT WITH THE WATER BOTTLES
I THINK IT IS EASIER. AND I DID
SEE THE EXAMPLES THAT WERE
BROUGHT BY THE OFFICES.
BUT FOR OTHER BEVERAGES IT'S
NOT A SIMPLE AND I JUST I'M
ASTOUNDED THAT.
YOUR ATTITUDE IS.
THE IF YOU DON'T GIVE ME THIS
SOLUTION I WANT THAT WE'RE JUST
NOT GOING TO TALK THAT'S HOW
IT'S COMING ACROSS THE OF NO
IT'S IT'S IT'S REALLY THE OTHER
WAY AROUND.
BECAUSE BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
THIS PLACE.
AND WHAT I WANNA DO IS REDUCE
PLASTIC POLLUTION AND REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF. BOTTLE CAPS THAT WE
FIND OUT.
IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO I PROPOSE A SOLUTION AND I'VE
BEEN VERY OPEN AND OF INVITING
ANYBODY WANTS TO COME TALK TO
ME.
I CAN'T MAKE THEM COME TALK TO
SO WE'RE AT THE POINT RIGHT NOW
I'M JUST BEING VERY I'M TO TRY
TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT.
THE SITUATION I FIND MYSELF I
THINK IT'S COMPELLING POLICY.
AND I THINK IT'S WORTH HAVING A
CONVERSATION.
THE OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW KNOWS
THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO KILL THIS
BILL ANY POINT IN TIME SO IT'S
NOT WORTH THEIR TIME. TO COME
TALK TO ME.
I'M TRYING TO.
IF I COULD MOVE THE BILL ENOUGH.
TO GET THEM TO THE TABLE TO
TALK.
AND I'VE BAXI BEEN VERY CLEAR
ABOUT AREAS THAT I'M WILLING
MISTER CALDERON ARE WILLING TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND MOVE IT
FORWARD.
I CAN ACCESS.
I CAN INVITE.
AND TALK ABOUT IT.
BUT THERE'S ONLY.
SHE GOT A SUGGESTION.
I'M ALL EARS.
WELL.
AGAIN I JUST THINK.
THIS IS OMETHING.
JUST SENDING OUT IN IN AN
INVITATION YOU KNOW VIA EMAIL OR
A PHONE CALL SAYING.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO COME
TALK PLEASE COME BY I THINK YOU
MIGHT NEED TO BE A LITTLE MORE
AGGRESSIVE FRANKLY ON YOUR AND
TO GET EVERYBODY TO THE TABLE.
INCOME BUT BUT THE TWO OTHER
THINGS THAT I JUST WANNA MENTION
NUMBER ONE IS MY KIDS WE SAVE
ALL YOU KNOW ANY BOTTLES WATER
BOTTLES JUICE BOTTLES THINGS
LIKE THAT. WHENEVER WE TAKE THEM
TO THE RECYCLING CENTER THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO REMOVE THE CAP AND
THROW IT AWAY YOU CAN'T TAKE THE
CAP IN THERE SO I JUST. I'M
LOOKING AT THIS THINKING OKAY
WHILE.
THEY'RE GONNA MAKE TETHERED
CAPS WHICH ARE THEN GOING TO
HAVE TO BE RIPPED OFF THE BOTTLE
EITHER AT HOME OR AT THE
RECYCLING CENTER YOU'RE SHAKING
YOUR HEAD NO BUT I AM TELLING
YOU. AS SURE AS I SIT IN FRONT
OF YOU MY KIDS HAVE TO TAKE
THOSE BOTTLE CAPS ARE THE THE
BOUGHT THE LID OFF OF THOSE
BODIES AND THOSE ARE GOING TO
END UP. I'M NOT DOUBTING YOU IN
TEN YEARS AGO THAT USED TO BE
THE THING BECAUSE RECYCLERS DID
KNOW WHAT TO DO THEIR DIFFERENT
LAST.
NOW THEY DO.
AND THE RECYCLING INDUSTRY IS IT
IS TAKE MAYBE YEARS ISN'T THERE
DOING IT IF I I'M I'M NOT LEARN
MAYBE THEY ARE. AND THEY'RE NOT
ONLY DO THEY ARE NOT IN MORE
PLACES THAN JUST IN MY DISTRICT
IS IS YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING.
.
I JUST.
I.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE PLASTIC OUT
THERE EITHER YOU KNOW AND I'VE
BEEN TO YOUR DISTRICT I USED TO
LIVE FRANKLY IN YOUR DISTRICT
WHEN I WAS THAT.
ATTENDING UNIVERSITY UP THERE
AND I CAN CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU LOOKING AT THAT PRISTINE
COAST
DON'T YOU KNOW MONEY DO
EVERYTHING YOU POSSIBLY CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T SEE
GARBAGE.
FLOATING IN THE WATER I REALLY
DO.
BUT.
THIS IS ALL WHOLESALE CHANGE IN
AN INDUSTRY THAT IS GOING TO
HAVE AN EFFECT ON NOT JUST THE
BIG GUYS WHO MIGHT BE ABLE TO
ABSORB THAT COST BUT THE LITTLE
GUYS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IN THE NAME OF.
REMOVING THE PLASTICS WIPING
SOME BUSINESS
BUSINESS IS COMPLETELY OFF THE
MAP AND I JUST I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S A REASONABLE WERE
APPROPRIATE APPROACH AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT. THIS COMMITTEE
IS CONTINUES TO PASS BILLS WHERE
MEMBERS SAY WELL WE DON'T THINK
IT'S QUITE COULD JET BUT WILL
MOVE THE LINE.
THAT'S NOT OUR JOB HERE IS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE JOB IS TO
MAKE SURE THE BILLS ARE CUT.
AND.
THIS ONE IT SEEMS LIKE THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE WHO FEEL LIKE WE'RE
NOT QUITE THERE YET BUT THERE IS
NO.
THERE'S NO PUSHED BACK TO SAY NO
YOU NEED TO GET BACK TO THE
TABLE NEED TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND COME TO SOME SORT
OF RESOLUTION.
AND AND I AND I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT IS IT'S AS
THOUGH THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
DECIDE WELL WE'LL LET THE
GOVERNOR DEAL WITH THAT JUST LET
HIM VETO IT AND WILL KEEP ALL
OUR COLLEAGUES HAPPY AND VOTE
FOR THEIR BILL AND MOVE ALONG.
AND IT'S A WIN WIN AND NOT DUTCH
JUST IRRESPONSIBLE AND
LEGISLATING IN MY OPINION.
BUT.
WELL TELL HAVE SAY ABOUT ANY
RESPONDENT DOES I DON'T IS
COOKED THIS THIS IS A LEGITIMATE
POLICY THAT STANDS ON ITS OWN
WITHOUT AMEND YOU CAN AGREE. YOU
CAN DISAGREE.
THE OTHER THING THAT I'M
OFFERING IS TO.
TAKE AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL.
SEE IF THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO
GO ABOUT THIS BECAUSE BOTH
MISTER CALDERON AYE ARE OPEN TO
BETTER WAYS BUG. GOING
THROUGH THIS.
THE PART THAT'S NOT COOKED IS
THE DAY.
WE LEFT THAT OPEN ON THIS ONE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT I DID THAT WAS
A SIGNIFICANT POINT OF
CONTENTION.
AND MAYBE THERE'S A TIMELINE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE PREVIOUS BILL
TIMELINE WAS TWENTY TWENTY.
THOSE DEFECTS.
I ADMIT WAY TOO FAST
SO LET'S LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
AND WHAT AN APPROPRIATE DATE IS
THE DATE A VERY EASY THING TO TO
TO PUT IN THERE. AND THIS
LEGISLATURE COULD MOVE THIS BILL
AS IT IS.
WE COULD PUT THE DATE IN THERE
AND REQUIRE ALL BOTTLES TO HAVE
THE TETHER CAP.
BY WHATEVER THAT DATE IS THAT'S
THE PART THAT'S.
THE PURVIEW OF THIS LEGISLATURE
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT IT'S GOOD
POLICY THAT STANDS ON ITS UP.
I'M OFFERING.
ALTERNATIVES.
IF
WE CAN GET SOME INPUT ON WHAT
THOSE ALTERNATIVES ARE.
I CAN STEP IN HERE I MEAN MS
MELENDEZ ANOTHER POINT TO KEEP
IN MIND IS THAT THIS DISCUSSION
HAS BEEN TAKING PLACE FOR.
FOR OVER A YEAR NOW AND AND THIS
COMMITTEE HAS DISCUSSED THIS A.
THE SAME PROPOSAL LAST YEAR AND
SO I I THINK I THINK WE HAVE.
.
HAD A VERY EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS AND THAT
THE FACT THAT MRS JONES LEAVING.
THE.
.
THE DATE OUT IS I I BELIEVE.
HIS.
GOOD FAITH.
EFFORT TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY.
RATHER THAN PUTTING SOMETHING
FOR JUST IMPOSING SOMETHING THAT
IS UNWORKABLE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IS.
SCHOOL.
LAWMAKER.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OUT AND COMMENTS FROM
THE.
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
.
MISTER STONE WHICH YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BY ASKING ABOUT.-WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECOND.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I AM TWENTY AB.
I DON'T TWENTY AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY NINE BY STONE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS.
MEMBERS MURATSUCHI AND I
MURATSUCHI AYE ACOSTA NO ACOSTA
NO BLOOM. I'VE BLOOM AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ BELINDA'S
NO STONE.
STONE I.
SEVEN THREE.
ALRIGHT BILL ITSELF.
LAST BILL.
YOU'RE OPPOSED.
FOR THE LAST.
A SURE. YOU WANT.
ON.
OKAY.
MISTER MONEY TO SEE.
MISTER JERRY WE SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE.
ANYTIME YOU'RE A SORT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BY CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I AM PRESENTING AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO DEFEND
CALIFORNIA'S COAST.
FROM THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO RENEW OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING OFF OF CALIFORNIA'S
COAST.
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED
THEIR INTENT.
TO READ NEW RE OPEN. NEW.
LEASES
FOR OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING BOTH
ON THE WEST COAST AS WELL AS THE
EAST COAST.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
FROM BOTH COASTS HAVE OPPOSED
THIS PROPOSAL.
IN FACT THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
.
LODGED HIS OBJECTION TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ITS
OBJECTION TO.
DUE THE OBJECTED TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO RE
OPEN OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING.
ON THE BASIS THAT IT WOULD
DAMAGE THEIR.
TOURISM ECONOMY
THOSE SAME ARGUMENTS APPLY TO
OUR BEAUTIFUL COAST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES WE HAVE
HAD A BIPARTISAN.
AGREEMENT AND BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
TWO OPPOSE OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING
A TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S COAST.
THIS BILL.
PROHIBITS THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
OR A LOCAL TRUSTEE FROM ENTERING
INTO ANY NEW LEADS
NOT AFFECTING ANY EXISTING
LEASES BUT TO.
PROHIBIT ANY NEW LEASE OR TO.
PROHIBIT ANY NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
PIPELINES.
AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT.
THE INCREASE IN OIL AND NATURAL
GAS PRODUCTION.
.
TO.
BASICALLY CUT OFF.
ANY NEW OIL OR NATURAL GAS
COMING FROM FEDERAL WATERS INTO
THE THREE MILE.
STATE WATERS CONTROLLED.
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
THIS IS CLEARLY A BILL.
DESIGNED TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR COAST AS WELL AS
OUR ONE POINT SEVEN TRILLION
DOLLAR.
ECONOMY COASTAL ECONOMY.
THAT.
ARE CALIFORNIA COAST DEPENDS
UPON.
AS STATED IN.
ONE OF THE EARLIER
PRESENTATIONS WHENEVER THERE IS
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES THERE ARE ACCIDENTS
WE'VE SEEN IT IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE IN SANTA BARBARA. WE'VE
SEEN IT A MORE RECENTLY IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN. ARE ALSO AND THE
SANTA BARBARA AREA. AND I'M VERY
PROUD TO BE HERE WITH A JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
OUR REPRESENTATIVE FROM SANTA
BARBARA MISS LIMO.
THANK YOU AND CHAIR THANK YOU
VICE CHAIR AND I AM PROUD TO
STAND WITH CHAIR MURATSUCHI AS A
JOINT AUTHORED FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
JUST LAST MONTH THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A BIPARTISAN ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION EXPRESSING OUR
STRONG AND UNEQUIVOCAL
OPPOSITION TO THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION'S DRAFT A PLAN.
TO OPEN ALL THREE REGION OF
CALIFORNIA'S COAST TO OFFSHORE
OIL AND GAS LEASING TODAY. IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO PUT THAT
RESOLUTION INTO ACTION
CALIFORNIANS KNOW THE COST OF
OIL FROM THE LARGEST SPILLING
CALIFORNIA HISTORY NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE IN SANTA BARBARA TO
THE MOST RECENT RIFFLE HE OIL
SPILL. MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE
PAID THE PRICE
INCLUDING OUR COASTAL ECONOMY
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT TO OUR
STATE.
FOR NEARLY THREE DECADES WE HAVE
HAD AT BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT THAT
WOULD NOT EXPAND. OIL DRILLING
OFF THE CALIFORNIA COAST
THIS IS ABOUT STICKING TO THAT
AGREEMENT AND ENSURING THAT WE
DON'T EX
SPANS OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING. I
URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND STAND
STRONG AGAINST BIG OF SHORT
SIGHTED PROPOSAL. BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
A GOOD EVENING KYLE JOHNSON
CIRCLE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
AT A TIME WHEN ALL OF US KNOW
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING WHAT WE
CAN TO REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCE ON
FOSSIL FUELS A KEY MARKET ON THE
GROUND.
THE FOLKS IN DC HAVE DECIDED TO
INCREASE THAT EFFORT I'D DESPITE
THE WILL OF CALIFORNIANS IN FACT
THIS WAS ANNOUNCED ON JANUARY
FOURTH. WE HAD ONLY ONE PUBLIC
MEETING UP ON THIS PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND OFFSHORE DRILLING A
CALIFORNIA IN SACRAMENTO. OUT
WHICH IS NOT EXACTLY COASTAL.
DESPITE THAT LIMITED ACCESS.
ARE HUNDREDS OF OF FOLKS WERE
ABLE TO COME UP HERE FROM AS FAR
AWAY AS SANTA BARBARA AS FAR
AWAY AS ORANGE COUNTY. TO
EXPRESS THEIR DISPLEASURE WITH
THE PROPOSAL GOING FORWARD.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THOUSANDS
OF COMMENTS WERE FILED IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT PROPOSAL.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THERE WILL
BE PROBLEMS WITH INCREASED
HARDER FOR US TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE CALLS.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WILL
LET THE ADMINISTRATION KNOW THAT
IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO IGNORE THE
WILL THE PUBLIC AND DRIVE WHICH
IS OUT WE CAN RESPOND IN KIND.
AND PREVENT THIS PLAN FROM
WORKING ON THE GROUND AYE BY
LIMITING KNEW.
INFRASTRUCTURE ONLY OUT WE WILL
NOT BE S. ALLOW FOR ANY INCREASE
ACTIVITY TO HAPPEN AND WE CAN
THEN PROTECT OUR COAST IN LINE
WITH THE PUBLIC WANTS OUTLIER
DRIVE OUT TODAY THINKING.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS I'M AARON
EVANS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES OVER
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS MEASURE.
.
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WORK TO PRESERVE THE
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE FOR
NUMEROUS PURPOSES INCLUDING
RECREATION AND ENJOYMENT OF THE
PUBLIC. THIS INCLUDE SIXTY ONE
CITIES ALONG CALIFORNIA'S COAST.
THE LEAGUE HAS LONGSTANDING
POLICY THAT SUPPORTS PROHIBITING
OFFSHORE DEVELOPMENT. BUT DUE TO
POTENTIAL ON SHORE IMPACTS.
AS WE CONSIDERED THIS MEASURE WE
RECONSIDER THAT POLICY AND
AFFIRMED IT AS WELL UP FOR THESE
REASONS THE LEAGUE SUPPORTS US
MEASURE AND URGES ARE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INDEED.
WHEN ISN'T SUPPORTER ALREADY
MAKING. ITS CHAIR MEMBERS THE
BIG WITH THEIR GREATNESS HAS
HITS FOR THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM AND THE RESOURCES
LEGACY FUND IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL LYNCH ON BEHALF
OF THE OCEAN CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT.
AND ONLY SERVE ARROW ON BEHALF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
QUINN ULTIMATE ANO ON BEHALF A
LOT ON CALIFORNIA HE INCREMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
JERRY SPRINGER* ON THE HAVE
TO FEEL THE BAY AND SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING OF THE OTHER OF ON
THE ON BEHALF OF US TOOL AND THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITIONS ELEVEN ORGANIZATIONS
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
OR SEMI ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
PERMANENTLY HILLS IT'S PART.
DAVID JONES OF HALF THE CITIES
OF MARIN AND SPORT.
JENNIFER SAVAGE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION NATIONAL IN SUPPORT.
ADDING TO OUR FOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CRAIG HAD WELDER SURFRIDER SOUTH
BAY ANTI MIGHT TAKE A MOMENT I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT.
IF WE LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED AT
HERMOSA BEACH TO SHUT DOWN THAT
OIL PROJECT I PERSONALLY PUT IN
OVER FOUR THOUSAND HOURS ON THIS
ON PAID AND. WE FOUGHT THERE IS
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT TURNOUT AND
SEVENTY NINE AND HAVE PERCENT NO
VOTE THINK WE'D LIKE THIS HELP
SUPPORT THAT SO THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES COME UP.
SAME RULES THREE PEOPLE TWO
MINUTES EACH OF US ALL KNOW THE
DRILL.
SOME WITH DINNER.
CHAIR MEMBERS WITH SUCH AS WITH
WITH SPOT WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB. SEVENTY FIVE AYE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WILL TAKE AWAY
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
PRODUCE ITS OWN ENERGY
RESOURCES.
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL BY TAKE THAT IT WILL TAKE
EXISTING AUTHORITY AWAY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
TO ISSUE RENEW MODIFY EXTEND
ELISE ARE CONVEYANCE FOR OIL AND
NATURAL GAS PRODUCTION IF THE
LEASE WILL RESULT IN AN INCREASE
OF ALL PRODUCTION FROM FEDERAL
WATERS.
AND IN FACT.
.
THE COMMISSION HAS ALREADY SENT
A LETTER EARLIER THIS YEAR TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CONDEMNING. THAT THE OFFER
LEASES AND HAS ALSO ADOPTED
RESOLUTIONS.
OPPOSING THE PROPOSED FEDERAL
ACTION.
IN ADDITION THE BILL IN OUR
INTERPRETATION.
EVEN AS AMENDED.
STILL CONTAINS UNDEFINED OVERLY
BROAD LANGUAGE THAT THAT WOULD
ALSO CAPTURE IN OUR VIEW
EXISTING PRODUCTION AND
ULTIMATELY AND IT. FOR EXAMPLE
IT IS UNCLEAR AS TO WHAT
INCREASE MEANS OR HOW THE
PRODUCTION WOULD BE MEASURED.
BUT DOES THE PROHIBITION ALSO
APPLY TO EXISTING FEDERAL LEASES
AS WELL.
ON ON THAT POINT I DO WHAT I
THINK THE AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR MEETING WITH US ON
THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. ON HOW
THE BILL AS WRITTEN COULD AFFECT
EXISTING PRODUCTION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. THAT
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE THAT WE'VE
HAD OF THE BILL MOVES TODAY.
AND THAT'S THERE IS ALREADY AN
EXISTING REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
WITHIN THE COMMISSION THAT
PROVIDES THE FLEXIBILITY AND
DISCRETION NEEDED. FOR CURRENT
AND FUTURE OF.
EXCUSE ME DEVELOPMENT OF
DOMESTIC ENERGY SUPPLIES THAT
ARE IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
STATE SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED TO. AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE ENERGY ABOUT NO
THANK YOU.
DO YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF P. ANTHONY THOMAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION CEPA. AND THE
CALIFORNIAN AFTER GAS PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO THANK. MY
COUNTERPART IT WAS BEFORE AS
OUTLINED IN HIS DESCRIPTION.
A SOME OF OUR CONCERNS ONE A
SLIGHTLY EXPAND ON A COUPLE AND
PROVIDES A MONETARY CONSEQUENCES
WITHIN THE TIME ALLOTTED.
IF THE AUTHORS AND SUPPORTERS
OF SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WERE
LOOKING TO HALT PRODUCTION
CALIFORNIA.
BUT TO LOOK INTO HOW PRODUCTION
CALIFORNIA THIS IS YOUR FOR.
THIS IS YOUR BILL.
NOW HOWEVER IF YOU'RE NOT
LOOKING HOW PRODUCTION IN STATE
THE CALIFORNIA IN THE BIN THEN
THE BILL SHOULD REFLECT EXPANDED
PRODUCTION. SHOULD NOT REFLECTED
TO MEET SAID NOT REFLECT.
SPEND IT PRODUCTION.
WHICH IMPACTS CURRENT
PRODUCTION.
LET ME REPEAT THAT
IF YOUR GOAL IS NOT TO HALT
PRODUCTION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL SHOULD NOT REFLECT
EXPANDED PRODUCTION.
IMPACTS
CURRENT PRODUCTION
PAGE TWO SECTION ONE LINE TEN TO
THIRTEEN IS NOT CLEAR NOR IT'S
PAGE THREE SAME SECTION SMALL BE
LINE EIGHT THROUGH TWELVE. THIS
IS AMBIGUITY AT ITS FINEST
MEMBERS
SO WE WOULD ASK IF THIS IS NOT
YOUR INTENTION TO HALT
PRODUCTION AUTHORS THAT WE WOULD
ASK THAT CORRECTION BE MADE. IN
ITS PRESENT FORM SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE RESULT IN A LOSS
PRODUCTION IN OUR STATE.
IF IT'S SUCCESSFUL.
THEN DEMAND WILL STILL BE IN OUR
STATE.
HALF A MILLION BARRELS OF FUEL
FOR OUR CARS TRUCKS PLANES
ANOTHER MOLD TO TRANSPORTATION
IT WILL NOT CEASE.
THE PRODUCTION VERSES USE
DEFICIT WILL INCREASE NOW AND IN
THE FUTURE IF THIS BILL PASSES
IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
HOWEVER TRANSPORTATION FUEL FROM
BARGES
TRANSPORTATION FROM TANKERS
WILL INCREASE
SPEWING THE EMISSIONS THAT
SUPPORTERS OF ALLEGEDLY
ATTEMPTING TO PREVENT.
VIA OTHER SOURCES
SUCH AS CAP AND TRADE.
S. B. THIRTY TWO AND OTHERS
BILL SUCH AS THIS MEMBERS WILL
ALSO IMPACT MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN
THIS INDUSTRY.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
THAT'S AS MUCH.
S. AS MANY AS MANY EMPLOYEES AT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES.
I FOUND IT INTERESTING THAT
PROPONENTS AND SUPPORTERS OF
MEASURE SUCH A SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE. ALL WASTE FRONT LOW THEIR
POLICY PROPOSALS.
HALT THIS BAND THAT.
A MORATORIUM ON X. REEXAMINE
ISSUES AND SO ON AND SO FORTH
HOWEVER.
RARELY IF AT ANYTIME DUE TO
PROPONENTS CRAFTER HAVE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE IMPACTS
TO THE HUMAN CAPITAL THAT WE SIT
HERE AND ATTEMPTED TO FAN ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
AS I CLOSE MEMBERS IT'S
TROUBLING IN A BIT DISTURBING
THAT SUPPORTERS SUCH AS THOSE OF
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE WHO'VE
SPOKEN. AND ARE IN SUPPORT OF IT
TAKE THE POSITION OF THE MORE
SIPS MORAL SUPERIORITY WHEN IT
COMES ANY POLICY RELATING TO
GAS.
AND OIL.
IF THE BILL NEEDS MENDING LET'S
AMENDED MEMBERS.
THEN LET'S THAT'S AGREED TO MOVE
FORWARD LET'S NOT PLACE.
A BILL THAT IS ON COOKING
UNPREPARED TO GO TO THE POLICY
PROCESS BECAUSE THE COMPLICIT
POSSIBLY COMPLICIT.
PRESS INTO COMPLICITY MIDI.
SAYS THAT IT'S OKAY ALL WE WOULD
ASK THAT.
YOU PROVIDE A FAIR BALANCE
POLICY ARGUMENT WITH THIS LEAVE
IT HERE WERE GLAD TO WORK ON IT
TO WORK ON ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED IN THE MOVE ON UNTIL
THEN WE STAND OPPOSED.
THANK YOU I ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE AUDIENCE IN OPPOSITION I'M
SHE'S MEAN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME UP.
WE JUST STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION YOUR POST.
ADAM READILY WITH THE CAL
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP BRING
BACK TO THE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS.
MS MONEY.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIRMAN.
SO.
IS THAT THE POINT OF THE BILL TO
HALT PRODUCTION COMPLETELY IN
CALIFORNIA.
NO IT IS NOT A FACT.
THAT IS SPELLED OUT IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
ON PAGE TWO.
SECTION TWO.
UNDER THIS BILL SPECIFIES THAT
THE PROHIBITION DOES NOT APPLY
TO EXISTING OIL AND GAS PRODUCED
FROM STATE WATERS. AND THAT'S
ALSO REFLECTED IN THE. THE BILL
LANGUAGE ON ON PAGE TWO.
.
SO IF.
BECAUSE THE BILL CONTEMPLATES
THE INCREASE IN PRODUCTION YES
SO IF YOU HAVE WELL AS OUT THERE
THAT CURRENTLY AREN'T.
YOU NOT DRAWING THIS FUEL FROM.
AND THEN YOU DO AT A LATER DATE
DOES THAT CONSTITUTE AN INCREASE
IN PRODUCTION UNDER THE TERMS OF
THIS LEGISLATION WENT WITH THIS
BILL FOCUSES ON IS.
BE
S. A PROHIBITION ON ANY NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD EXPAND
THE CAPACITY IS SO FOR EXAMPLE
AT AGAIN AS POINTED OUT IN IN
THE STAFF ANALYSIS. IF EXISTING
PIPELINES AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD SUPPORT
INCREASED OIL OR GAS PRODUCTION
FROM EXISTING LEASES.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL WOULD
AFFECT THAT.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL.
.
CALLS FOR IS PROHIBITING THE
LANCE COMMISSION FROM ALLOWING
ANY NEW INFRASTRUCTURE BEYOND
WHAT EXISTS CURRENTLY THAT
WOULD.
ALLOW AN INCREASE IN OIL OR NAT.
NATURAL GAS PRODUCTION SO ANY
CHANGE AT ALL TO THE STRUCTURE
OUT THERE WOULD BE CONSIDERED.
.
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AS FAR
AS THIS BILL IT AS FAR AS BEING
ABLE TO INCREASE THE CAPACITY I
MEAN I'M JUST I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF YOU'VE GOT?
IF YOU'VE GOT A WELL THAT THE
HASN'T BEEN USED AND YOU MAKE
SOME MINOR CHANGES OUT THERE
DOES THAT MEAN. LONG NOW YOU'VE
DONE SOMETHING TO IT TO INCREASE
CAN PASS CAPACITY THEREFORE. WE
CAN'T ALLOW THAT I'M JUST I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO WORK YOU USE THE
KEYWORD EXISTING IF IT EXISTS
NOW IT'S ALLOWED NOTHING IN THIS
BILL. AFFECTS ITS EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHAT THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO
IS TO? IS TO.
IS TO PROHIBIT ANY NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR INCREASED
OIL OR NATURAL GAS PRETTY.
SO.
.
FROM.
I KNOW THERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT WANT US TO AS A COUNTRY NOT
AS BEING HONEST RELEASED A STATE
BUT TO ACHIEVE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WHICH.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL EVER HAPPEN
COMPLETELY ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE ALTHOUGH I
DO THINK WE CAN MAKE SOME MORE
STRIDES TOWARD BECOMING MORE
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES HERE THAT WE CAN TAP
INTO AS OPPOSED TO GETTING THOSE
RESOURCES FROM COUNTRIES THAT
DON'T SHARE OUR VALUES CERTAINLY
DON'T SHARE CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
WHEN IT COMES TO THE LGBT
COMMUNITY WHEN IT COMES TO HOW
WOMEN ARE TREATED WHEN IT COMES
TO. HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES.
THEY DO NOT THEY ARE THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
HOW CALIFORNIA FEELS IN AMERICA
FEELS SO WHEN I SEE BILLS LIKE
THIS AYE I THINK WHAT GOSH THESE
ARE MY CHOICES HE NOW GO WITH
THIS BILL OR OR YOU?
OR ARE GO WITH.
TAKING FUEL FROM COUNTRIES THAT
DO HORRIBLE THINGS TO FELLOW
HUMAN BEINGS.
SOME OF WHICH ARE OWNED FITNESS.
AND THAT'S JUST NOT A CHOICE
THAT I THINK IS FAIR TO ASK US
TO MAKE I'M.
I WISH THAT THERE WAS THERE WAS
MORE OF AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN YOU
AND THE OPPOSITION TO FIGURE OUT
YOU KNOW HOW YOU COULD SOME HOW
MEET IN THE MIDDLE AND EAST COME
A LITTLE BIT CLOSER.
BUT I WOULD BET THAT IF I ASKED
THE TWO OPPONENTS TO COME UP
HERE AND RESPOND TO YOU SAYING
THAT NO IT DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO DO WITH THEM.
AT A IF THEIR EXISTING WHILE IS
THAT IT WON'T TOUCH THEM AT ALL
I JUST I FEEL LIKE THEY WOULD
HAVE.
A DIFFERENT ANSWER THEY HIM YOU
WOULD.
AND IT'S NOT AGAIN IS NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE A DEBATES ARE NOT
GOING TO PUT YOU IN THAT
POSITION I WOULDN'T ASK OUT OF.
RESPECT FOR YOUR CHAIRMANSHIP
AND THE LATE HOUR THAT IT IS.
BUT I JUST.
THIS IS VERY THIS IS TROUBLING
FOR ME I GET WHICH YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO I KNOW I HEARD YOU SPEAK
ABOUT THIS MANY TIMES IF YOU'RE
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT IT AS ARE
MOST CALIFORNIANS I THINK WITH
RESPECT TO OUR COASTLINE. BUT I
CAN'T.
I THINK THERE'S A BETTER WAY TO
DO THIS WITHOUT SACRIFICING OUR
CALIFORNIA VALUES AND PRINCIPLES
AND MORALS IN EXCHANGE FOR.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE SORRY BUT WELL
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THE PASSION
COMES FROM A VERY LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN THE PASSION ALSO
COMES? FROM REPRESENTING A
DISTRICT THAT'S BEEN REALLY
IMPACTED BY THIS.
AND IN A THINK TO YOUR POINT.
ABOUT HAVING COMPELLING
INTERESTS THAT ARE LOOKING FOR
YOU I THINK AND THE IDEA TO YOU
AND I'VE I'VE SAT HERE.
IN IN THIS PARTICULAR COMMITTEE
FOR YOU KNOW A YEAR PLUS.
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S NOT
ONLY ONE ANGLE TO LOOK AT THIS
THE OTHER ANGLE IS WHAT DO WE DO
S. CALIFORNIANS. TO ENSURE THAT
WERE MORE MOVING MORE TOWARDS
THE GREEN ECONOMY RIGHT TO A
GREEN MOVEMENT A MOVEMENT THAT
IS ALSO A LINES TO OTHER
CALIFORNIA VALUES OF WANTING TO
PRESERVE OUR ENVIRONMENT OF
WANTING TO HAVE CLEAN WATER AND
CLEAN AIR AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE COMING FROM.
I RESPECT THAT YOU HAVE THE
CONFLICTING COMPELLING INTEREST
ON BUT I THINK THAT UP FOR ME
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW MY
FELLOW CO AUTHOR AND OR AUTHOR
AND THE JOINT. AND IT'S IT IS
MOVING TOWARDS THAT PARTICULAR
SPACE TO A SPACE THAT IS ALIGNED
WITH CALIFORNIA VALUES AND I
KNOW THAT WHEN I BROUGHT THAT.
RESOLUTION FORWARD I AM I
BROUGHT IT FORWARD KNOWING THAT
MORE THAN SIXTY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA FEELS THAT THIS AND
THAT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT LETTER
IS NEXT TO THEIR VOTING RECORD.
AT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS REFLECTIVE OF FOR
CALIFORNIA AS A STATE WANTS TO
SEE US GO ANSWER FOR THOSE
REASONS WE FIGHT FOR IT.
AND IF I COULD JUST ADD TO THAT.
.
YOU KNOW I MEAN MY DISTRICT IS A
IS A GOOD EXAMPLE YOU HEARD THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION TO TESTIFY ABOUT HOW
IN HERMOSA BEACH THERE THERE
WAS.
OVER EIGHTY PERCENT OF PEOPLE
OPPOSE NEW OIL DRILLING IN
HERMOSA BEACH AND THAT'S WHEN
YOU CAN GET TO THOSE KIND OF
NUMBERS WITHOUT HAVING.
REPUBLICANS AS WELL AS DEMOCRATS
YOU KNOW.
OPPOSING OIL DRILLING THAT THAT
THREATENS OUR OUR OUR COAST IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND I THINK WE SEE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE COAST WHICH IS
WHY.
YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE THE
STATEWIDE SURVEY OF CLOSE TO
SEVEN PERCENT. OF CALIFORNIANS
OPPOSING NEW OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING
THEY HAVE MADE THE CHOICE THAT
THEY WOULD RATHER. PUT THEIR.
.
THEIR THEIR STAKE IN AND
CALIFORNIA'S.
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADERSHIP
IN RENEWABLE ENERGY PRODUCTION.
TO ACHIEVE ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
RATHER THAN DRILLING FOR FOSSIL
FUELS THAT THREATEN OUR COAST.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
VOICE.
OF TIMES YOU DO IT BUT I STEPPED
OUT WITH EMOTION. WE DON'T I
WOULD LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
AND THEN I I I THINK THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE TO SHUT
DOWN OIL PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA THERE. PROBABLY ARE
PEOPLE WANT TO DO BALLOT
MEASURES ARE. BILLS BUT THIS IS
NOT THE BILL I THINK THE BILL
HERE'S. WERE ASKING FOR THE
FLORIDA TREATMENT.
WE DIDN'T QUITE GET THE FLORIDA
TREATMENT AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO THAT.
THAT THE NEXT.
BEST ALTERNATIVE IS TO.
STRUCT OUR STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S INTEREST TO PROTECT
OUR COAST AND SO I THINK THIS IS
A SMART WAY ABOUT DOING THAT AND
I THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE ADOPT
THIS.
THANK YOU.
ANY BEEN ANYONE ELSE OKAY.
MISS MATTEUCCI I. CAN ACCEPT
THAT IS A CLOSURE YOUR LAST
COMMENT ACTUALLY ASK FOR AYE
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS SECONDS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE ITEM ON AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY MEMBERS
MATTEUCCI AND LIMON.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MARTUCCI GUY RITCHIE I ACOSTA NO
ACOSTA NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE CHAU. CHAU AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMOS I LIMON AYE
MCCARTY.
CREEK RD.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
STONE. STONE AYE SEVEN THREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THEY HAVE THEIR OPEN FOR.
WE LOOK THE CALL ON.
WELL OF THE CALL THE REMAINING.
BILLS WERE ABSENT MEMBERS
PUTTING MYSELF AND THE. CLERK.
FOR THEM UP THANK.
ITEM SEVEN ABC NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE I CHIU. CURRENT VOTERS FOUR
TO FOUR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE LIMON.
THIS IS ITEM SEVEN A. B.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY CHIU.
LIMON I.
SIX FOUR.
THE BILL IS OUT.
YOU WERE GOOD.
YES I HAD VIA PRINT BLOOM.
I DON'T TWELVE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE BY MATHIS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED CURRENT
VOTE FOR TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ABSENT MEMBERS
ACOSTA.
RIGHT
ACOSTA AYE BLOOM.
CHAU.
A I'M SORRY.
BLOOM.
NOT VOTING OKAY.
BLOOM NOT VOTING. CHAO.
I DON'T TWELVE AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY ONE MATHIS.
SHALL I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
STONE.
STONE NO.
SEVEN ONE BELLEZZA.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY NINE BY BLOOM MOTION TO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED TO
FEDERAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIAL COMMITTEE. GROUP VOTERS
FIVE TO FOUR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
SHALL I.
SIX TO FOUR VILLISCA.
NEWMAN IN ORDER.
A. B. OUR I DON'T TWENTY ONE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY SIX BY
MELINDA'S THE MOTION TO PASS
REFER TO HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT THE CURRENT VOTED
THREE TO TWO. WITH A CHAIR
VOTING NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BLOOM.
BLOOM NOT VOTING.
PHONES ARE AND THAT.
CHAU.
JOHN UP VOTING.
MCCARTY.
AND STONE.
STONE NO.
THREE TO THREE.
THREE.
I DON'T TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY
NINE OH EIGHT BY.
BERMAN THE MOST ACTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO
TWO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA NO ACOSTA
NO CHILD.
CHAU AYE.
STONE.
STONE I.
SEVEN THREE MELLISA.
LAST ONE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FIVE BY
FRIEDMAN. DO PAST REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FOR TO TO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU
TRIAL AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING.
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA SNOW.
FIVE THREE.
BILLS ON CALL
.
YEAH WE CAN DO AFTER.
YOU WANT TO GO THERE.
BECAUSE OF FRIEDMAN.
YEAH SO.
.
ACR.
ARTICULATED.
ANNOUNCER.
WE.
THAT IS.
SO IN THE COMING
.
PLEASE.
YEAH. BUT THERE'S.
LOS.
THANK.
RIGHT. BY.
BUT HOW CAN YOU SAY.
AND WHAT I HAD.
REPUBLICAN.
FANDANGO. CASE.
DISCLOSURES.
WE CAN.
HE'S A PEOPLE
I DON'T TWENTY FOUR A BETWEEN
AND SEVENTY FIVE BY FRIEDMAN
PAST REFERRED AMID PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
TO THREE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
MCCARTY.
THREE ALRIGHT THAT GOES OUT
.
I MELENDEZ TO PASS REFER TO
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT CURRENT VOTERS THREE
TO THREE WITH A CHAIR VOTING NO.
ABSENT MEMBERS BLOOM.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
MCCARTY.
THREE THREE.
ALRIGHT
THERE.
YEAH.
BECAUSE I DON'T REMEMBER.
SEVEN TO TEN DAYS.
I DON'T.
WE DID.
HERE THE.
CALDERON.
FLORA EGGMAN SHALLOW.
FEDERAL ORDER.
PROUD.
.
BLOOM CHILD.
UNDER.
I THE BRIAN. DAHLE.
I.
YOU NEED TO DO A LOT OF.
BECAUSE.
ASSEMBLY FINE. ITEM FIVE AB
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR PATTERSON.
BUT ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE MCCARTY.
STONE. STONE AYE.
NINE ZERO.
THEY'LL JUST.
ITEM SIX ABSENT MEMBER CHAU.
CHAU AYE TEN ZERO.
ITEM SEVEN AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE.
THE VOTE THIS.
THAT GOT OUT WITH THE SIX FOUR.
ITEM MADE AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN
ABSENT MEMBERS BLOOM.
LIMON.
MCCARTY.
SIX ONE.
TITLE NINE A. B. TWO ZERO NINE
ONE ABSENT MEMBERS ACOSTA. CHAU.
CHAU AYE STONE.
STONE I.
NINE HERO.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
TRIAL AYE LOW MOAN.
ITEM ELEVEN.
LIMON I.
TEN ZERO.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY NINE. THAT GOT OUT ON
THE SIX FOUR.
ITEM TWELVE TWENTY THREE FORTY
ONE.
ABSENT MEMBERS BLOOM.
LIMON.
OH TWENTY THREE FORTY ONE
MATHIS.
OKAY.
SO THAT GOT OUT ON SEVEN ONE.
I DON'T FOURTEEN AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY ONE ABSENT MEMBERS CHAO.
CHAU AYE TENDS ZERO.
I DON'T FIFTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
OH FOR.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE LIMON.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR OH
FOR O'DONNELL.
LIMON I.
MCCARTY.
STONE.
STONE I.
NINE ZERO.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
FORTY ONE FRAZIER.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE STONE.
STONE AYE TEN ZERO.
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY NINE.
ABSENT MEMBERS MERIT TO CHEAT.
MURATSUCHI I.
CHAU.
CHAU I.
EIGHT TO.
I DON'T FUNNY. AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE STONE. THAT GOT OUT
ON SEVEN TO THREE.
I DON'T TWENTY ONE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY SIX.
ABSENT MEMBERS BLOOM.
WELL YEAH WE DID THAT ONCE.
THREE TO THREE.
I DON'T TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR LIMON.
HAVE SET MEMBER CHILD.
CHAU AYE SEVEN THREE.
I DON'T TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE
OH EIGHT.
THAT GOT OUT SEVEN THREE.
I DON'T TWENTY FOUR TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY FIVE.
ABSENT MEMBER MCCARTY.
THREE.
ITEM TWENTY SIX AB THIRTY TO
THIRTY TWO.
THAT ONE WAS ON AUTHOR PAUL.
YEAH. WHO?
SO TWENTY SIX A. B. THIRTY TO
THIRTY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE.
SEVEN THREE.
LET'S.
ALRIGHT.
MEETING IS ADJOURNED